All right, I now call the November 6th, 2019 meeting of the State Board of Education to order.
We'll commence by saluting the flag.
Vice President Strauss, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Right hand over your heart.
Ready?
Begin.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the Republic
indivisible with liberty and justice for all.
Okay, I am going to wait and do the public announcements when the public comes in.
So the board will now go into closed session.
Right, and we'll take action on the following litigation, which is L.A.T.
versus the state.
And I ask any members of the public who happen to be here to please clear out of the boardroom and turn off the microphones.
Okay.
I'm going to ask everyone to find a seat if you can find one.
There are a few in the front, but those might be safe for the staff.
I'm not sure.
And so that we can get ready to begin.
Okay, we're reconvening the November 6, 2019 meeting of the State Board.
And I'm now going to instruct you on what's going to happen today.
There is one public hearing on a November agenda, item 8, which will be heard later today.
There's a handout on the table in the lobby identifying the proposed items on the consent calendars.
The proposed regular consent items are items 10 through 14.
The proposed consent waiver items are 1 through 7.
I'd like to remind board members that any members wishing to remove any items from the proposed consent calendars Please advise our executive directors Karen staff Walters by 10 a.m.
Today We will take up the waiver My mic is on
We will take up the waiver consent items and the regular consent items later this afternoon.
In terms of public input, speakers should sign in at the table just outside the room.
Binders are on the table with separate pages for each item number.
Signing in on the page that identifies the item number on which they would like to speak will help ensure that we keep track of all the speakers for a particular item.
Item 16 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on items that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
Public comment will be limited to one minute per speaker.
In order to ensure that everyone gets their one minute, there is a timer at the podium that will flash a red signal to each speaker when the one minute time limit has been reached.
This is we are seeking again this month to do a one-day board meeting We're getting into a new habit perhaps But that means we have a very very tight time frame.
We're aiming at this point to finish by 6 p.m.
And your participation in moving the meeting along will enable us to meet or exceed that benchmark and so
I want to encourage you to each take your own breaks whenever you need one.
We'll do the same.
We're going to work through lunch, and people will be sort of given permission one at a time to get their lunches so that we maintain a quorum.
I will need to be out for a bit after 1130, so Vice President Strauss will take the reins for part of the meeting.
And we're moving item number five to later in the meeting just before item 15.
And with those instructions, I'm going to invite State Superintendent Thurmond to provide the superintendent's report.
Thank you, Madam President, members of the board.
Good morning, all.
It is great to welcome our Student Advisory Commission members to the chamber.
You know, my first reaction is, well, why aren't they in school?
But we are glad to see you here because
We value civics education and your participation in your community and raising your voices on behalf of students across the state has a value to our students.
It has a value for our board and the Department of Education.
And we believe that it has a value for you because in some future time, many of you will be sitting on this dais or other governing bodies across the state and this nation.
And so we welcome your participation and look forward to what you share today.
For me, I want to share with you how proud I am of the students of California.
They are very resilient.
We've spent the last few weeks really being challenged by environmental challenges, wildfire winds, gusts that are up to speeds that have not been seen in recent times, power safety shutoffs that have had its own impact on our schools.
Our students and educators and families have found a way to persevere in very, very, very difficult times.
At one point,
During the power safety shutoffs, more than 352,000 students were impacted by schools that were de-energized.
Nearly 975,000 student days were impacted by de-energization.
I really want to say that to put that in context of what that has meant.
There are counties where almost every school needed to be closed because of fires.
But in other cases, some counties found a way to stay open
when they didn't have power.
They use generators, they use creativity, but our students have been resilient and the focus has continued to be on providing quality instruction even during difficult times.
This means that we have to think about a lot of things.
How do we address lost instruction time?
And we've had conversations about that.
Districts have asked us to think it through with them what their school calendars look like because we know that with changing conditions and climate that we're likely to see more of the same.
The staff at the Department of Education are really studying what happens in other states to see where there might be practices that we might employ and deploy in California and then make recommendations to the state board on how we think about our work going forward.
Our governor and our legislature have approved putting a bond measure on the state ballot that could provide some answers for school districts on how they use alternative energy, including solar energy, to help them answer questions during times
of being without power.
How do we make sure that meals are secure at school?
A lot of our districts saw food basically get wasted because they didn't have power to keep the food refrigerated.
How do we keep our districts that are on wells able to have fresh water?
How do we maintain sanitation needs?
These are all the things that educators have to think about and we'll have to think about them together.
Our governor has taken some leadership to address issues around our public utilities.
Again, I just want to comment on the resiliency of our students and our educators in getting through these difficult times.
I also want to acknowledge that some two dozen or more staff at the Department of Education have been actively involved.
in the State Operations Emergency Center and really helping to have conversations about how we support students and schools and citizens who are impacted by these conditions.
I want to commend all of them and thank them for their work.
We'll continue to be involved with the Office of Emergency Services and others to find solutions and ways to support our schools.
We engage in a conversation with most of our county superintendents to see how we can be helpful to them.
The board would not be surprised that they're
Their biggest question is about J-13A waivers and how their schools are going to be impacted when these closures occur because these were not planned closures and they don't quite fit the definition of a climatic response or a weather response or an emergency.
And so our staff has provided them consultation on this, as well as how to make the determination of when it's not safe enough to keep your school open and how to address air quality.
And so I wanted to share with you what's been happening here as it relates to weather conditions in the power safety shutoffs.
I want to thank Board President Linda Darling-Hammond and others who participated in a conversation on yesterday about how we support student learning as it relates to state test scores.
As you know, in the last few weeks, the cash scores have become made public.
While there is some moderate growth in some areas and there are some districts that have been bright spots throughout the state, we know that our opportunity gap continues and it persists.
And we want to have brave and courageous conversations about what we do to help close the gap so that all six million of our students get a great education.
And on yesterday in this panel that we had, we did a deep data dive to understand the trends, to understand why the gap persists and in some cases has widened, to understand why for some groups scores decline.
And we had a number of leaders and researchers.
We had our board president.
We had Pedro Nogueira from the UCLA School of Education.
We had Joe Johnson, who is the executive director of the National Center
for urban school transformation, some leaders from Ed Trust West, a number of folks who really could dig into the data to help us find the reasons for the trends.
What we see often is that in the elementary school grades, there are inclines, but what we find is in the higher grades, sometimes we see declines.
And we want to make sure that we're doing all we can to support all of our students, African American students, Latino students, English learners, students with disabilities, API students, students from low income backgrounds.
We want to give every student a chance at a great education and a chance at a great life.
And a lot of great conversations emerged.
What do we do to provide more training and professional development for our staff?
How do we make implicit bias training and unconscious bias training more part of our practice in preparing our students for the future?
How do we close our teacher shortage and make sure that we have teachers who are prepared to support our students and have the right training and the support?
How do we address leadership at every level of the school?
Our president talked about on average, superintendents stay at a district only 19 months.
With that kind of churn in leadership, we are seeing trends of fatigue for our educators.
We're figuring out what initiatives are we working on and how do we make the most impact for our students?
It was a very fruitful conversation and is part of an ongoing series that we really have made our future interests at the Department of Education, what we're going to do to close the achievement gap.
We welcome input from the state board members on that and just know that we are working to align all of our efforts at the Department of Education to be focused on how we close the gap.
I wanted to also just share that we've had an opportunity to have that conversation with most of the staff at the Department of Education on last week.
We hosted an all staff meeting here in Sacramento and just over 900 staff members in one place to have the conversation about how we align our efforts in closing the achievement gap.
I mentioned in closing that we look forward to our STEAM symposium in December.
This is one of our major professional development opportunities provided for educators in the space of STEAM.
Registration is now open for that event, which will take place on December 9th and 10th in Anaheim.
This year, we welcome legendary Laker Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
I'm a Warriors fan, but anyway, I digress.
To be one of our guests, Mr. Abdul-Jabbar has become a spokesperson for expanding STEAM education for our students across the state, and we're very excited to have his presence and to help lift up that conversation at the STEAM Symposium.
So know that registration is open, that we look forward to your participation, and we look forward to the remarks from our students today.
This concludes my report.
Well, as State Superintendent Thurman has noted, over the last few weeks, we've seen a series of devastating fires in northern and southern California.
And this month also marks the one-year anniversary of both the Camp Fire and Woolsey fires, which ravaged the community of Paradise and areas of Ventura County.
Last month marked the two-year anniversary of the Tubbs Fire in Napa and Sonoma counties.
And these fires and other disasters related to climate change, as the superintendent noted, have a devastating effect on our schools and our educators and our students.
And so I'm going to take this opportunity to recognize some civic engagement on the part of students who are really dealing very proactively with climate change.
It's not only an existential threat, but also a threat to our ability
to provide safe and healthy learning environments for our students.
We have with us today middle school students and others from Schools for Climate Action, a grassroots organization in Sonoma County.
And in just a moment, I'll invite these students and their teacher, Park Guthrie, to come forward to be recognized.
But first, I'll just tell you a little about them.
Schools for Climate Action is working to empower educators, students, and elected officials to speak up about climate change.
Because of School for Climate Action's advocacy on this critical issue, more than 100 educational organizations have passed climate change resolutions.
The work of this group dovetails with the state's work to improve the quality of science education and environmental literacy so students become engaged in issues surrounding the national world.
You may remember that the next generation science standards adopted in 2013 are designed to help students become critical thinkers who can analyze the many ways that humans impact this planet that we all share and draw their own independent conclusions.
We've been pushing a shift towards inquiry-based instruction to give students the skills that they need to learn and care about environmental issues so that students can develop curiosity, analyze and evaluate information in seeking answers.
We're also working to integrate environmental principles and concepts into the entire curriculum.
So you'll see guidance on climate change instruction in the language arts and history, social science curriculum frameworks adopted by this board as well as in the science framework.
And this is not all new.
In 1996, the California Department of Education created the California Regional Environmental Education Community Network Program, which assists teachers with locating grade appropriate lesson resources, field trip opportunities for students that help students understand their local environment.
So there's much work going on and more work to be done.
And I'm thrilled to see so many students who are also pushing for more and better
Learning and action on this front.
You're very inspirational.
So with that, I want to present this certificate and I'll tell you what it says to the students from schools for climate action.
The California State Board of Education presents the certificate of appreciation and commendation.
In honor of your contribution to the students of California, your dedication to empowering educators, students, and elected officials to speak up about climate change, we congratulate you, and we'd love to invite speakers from the Schools for Climate Action up to the podium to make a few brief comments, after which we'll get some pictures.
Thank you for speaking up for climate action.
It really means a lot to us that such a high-ranking education leader is speaking up for climate justice.
Climate change directly affects students, so everyone, especially education leaders, should speak up to help enact change.
As of the last two years, I've personally suffered four climate-related disasters.
There was the Tubbs Fire in 2017, the Paradise Fire in 2018, Russian River flooding earlier this year, and most recently, the Kincaid Fire just last week.
School closures due to horrible air quality and unsafe roads meant more than three weeks of school was lost.
So many students in California, Florida, Texas, Puerto Rico, and other places experienced climate-related catastrophes each year and suffer accordingly.
Congress has had the opportunity to prevent climate harm for more than three decades.
They have simply chosen not to act.
This is neglect.
And by continuing to remain silent, most education leaders are enabling Congress to continue to neglect the climate.
I hope that education leaders all over the country follow Dr. Linda Darling-Ham's example and speak up for climate justice.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Juan.
I'm in seventh grade.
I deeply believe that everyone can and should speak up for climate justice, especially education leaders.
Last December, we had a Zoom meeting with the executive director of the California Associations of School Psychologists.
In just a few minutes, she told us she was interested in bringing a climate action resolution to the next board meeting.
We were so excited, three months later,
In March, CASP did pass a climate action resolution.
It is that easy to speak up for climate justice.
All education leaders, all 1,000 school boards in California can easily pass a climate resolution.
If CASP and Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond have spoken up for climate justice, all education leaders can.
This will send a powerful message.
Thank you.
My name is Sabine Wolpert.
I'm in seventh grade, and climate change has been a defining element in my life.
I have had countless adults praise my climate activism and tell me that my generation will be the solution.
However, no one in my generation is one that has not greatly contributed to this problem, should have that weight on their shoulders.
I've watched floods, droughts, and fires in a few years.
I've watched education leaders claim to support my generation and then fail to change their actions, words, or principles.
The American Academy of Pediatrics said in their 2015 policy statement that, quote, failure to take prompt, substantive action would be an act of injustice to all children, unquote.
That was four years ago.
This spiral of climate silence that includes most educational leaders is allowing national and global climate neglect.
We all know that denying the climate crisis is dangerous.
Members of Congress commit child neglect by understanding the consequences and still failing to act.
This is an abuse of power at the very least.
This is why Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond's statement is so important.
All education leaders must act to help this injustice.
We're calling for a change.
Your words and actions now will make a difference for generations to come.
Thank you.
Good morning, trustees.
Thank you for this opportunity to speak.
My name is Lola Guthrie.
I'm a sophomore at Credo High and a co-founder of Schools for Climate Action.
I want to be honest.
When I thought about what I might say today, I was so angry and sad that I could hardly thank adults for simply speaking up about the climate crisis.
As someone who was born into a world already on its way toward disaster, it is impossible for me to imagine how adults can justify remaining silent about this while also working so hard to support students in other ways.
You can't protect or support students without confronting the greatest threat of our times.
I was in this room with my family exactly one year ago.
We were in the midst of a climate-related wildfire then, just as we are now.
We asked the California State Board of Ed to speak up for climate justice, but nothing happened.
Four months later, the National School Boards Association considered a climate resolution, but they were unwilling to even use the words climate change in it.
How am I supposed to have hope about the future when 90,000 school board members in the country won't even admit to the reality of this climate crisis?
I have to wonder that if the California State Board of Ed had spoken up when we first asked, in November of 2017, whether the NSBA would have done the right thing and simply stated the truth.
Some people hope that the NSBA will find the courage to act, but I don't think that it should take courage to simply say climate change hurts America's schools and students.
Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond, thank you for speaking up for climate justice.
I hope that members of the California School Boards Association, National School Boards Association, and the National Association of School Psychologists will be inspired by your powerful example.
There are many things I find difficult.
Watching my little sister choose what to put in her evacuation bag is difficult.
Driving away from my house and not knowing if it will be there when I return is difficult.
Watching a fire truck pass with its sirens on and not letting panic seize my chest is difficult.
But simply saying that climate change hurts students and that Congress should act is easy.
All education leaders can and must take this simple step, and together it will send a powerful signal.
Thank you.
I appreciate the personal shout-outs, but I want to be clear that the actions I described came from this entire State Board of Education.
The California Department of Education has been on this path for many years, since 1996 in fact.
And so, you know, on behalf of us collectively, I want to be sure that we're recognizing
the civic engagement of our students and the activism that is well called for in this arena.
I want to invite the folks who are here from the school to come up for a photo and I hope Superintendent Thurmond will join us and if we can get the rest of the board members in that would be great too but I don't know how many people we're talking about so we'll see what the crowd looks like.
Board members want to stand up in the right behind here or...
Just a cornucopia of student treasures today and the next item is the 2020-2021 State Board of Education recommendation of three finalists for submission to the governor for consideration and appointment.
And the SBE screening committee recommends that the state board approve the three finalists for the position of 2020 to 2021 SBE student member as identified in the item addendum.
The names of the approved finalists will be forwarded to the governor for his consideration and appointment as the student member.
I have to say that I know from Vice President Strauss that this was an extraordinary group of students and very hard to select from among them because they're all so extraordinary.
This item will be presented by the Screening Committee Chair, Vice President Strauss.
Please begin.
Okay, so good morning.
As in the past years, we had, actually we had a larger and stronger pool than ever, amazing.
And the job of the Screening Committee and the State Board of Education was to narrow the field down and present, as President Darling-Hammond said, the three candidates to the governor, and then the governor will consider and make the selection in the spring of next year.
The screening committee consisted of member Ortiz-Licón and Patio Bronson and myself.
We narrowed, we read all the applications and narrowed them down to a pool of 12 semi-finalists.
It was really hard, I'll just tell you, but hard in a good way because it was so amazing to read these applications and to realize what the hope of the future is with our next generation of leaders.
We reviewed it and selected 12 that we thought represented the best cross-section of applicants across the state.
All the semi-finalists have attended the 2019 Student Advisory Board of Education, which you're going to hear about and see them soon.
That's sponsored by the California Association of Student Council, and it started on November 3rd.
the student delegates voted for six candidates from the 12, so they narrowed it to six.
After listening to their presentations, and my understanding, there was also round tables where students could go and listen to what each candidate was offering.
So yesterday morning, the screening committee, joined by student member, Pangilin, I hope I say that right.
We and Patricia DeCoste from the state board, we helped during the interview process,
I have to say I've done this before.
It was amazing.
Like, in the end, we said, well, maybe we'll just give 6 of the governor's office and let the, but our job was to narrow to 3, but the finalists were incredible in so many ways and you'll hear them in a minute, but we did.
Come to an agreement to support the 3 finalists today.
So, based on the board's decision, we will forward the names of the 3 finalists to the governor's office.
Then they'll go through the governor's office appointment process and the governor will have the difficult job of making the final decision.
I think it's going to be really a tough decision, but he's got some amazing candidates to pick from.
So at this time, I wonder if I should – do I present the certificates first or do you want me to give you the names of the three finalists right now?
Okay.
Okay, so our first, so I'm gonna present the names and then students after this I'm gonna have you each come up and we have a certificate and we're gonna take a picture too, okay?
So we have three finalists, not in any order.
Arlene Compa, Arlene you can stand up.
And Michelle Alice, Michelle?
and Zaid Fata.
So I'm actually going to, so first I think we're going to take a vote on that and then we'll introduce all the finalists, is that right?
So the screening committee is recommending these three finalists be presented to the governor's office for next year's student board member to serve with us.
I have a motion.
We got so many motions.
Pick one, whoever is keeping the minutes.
Do I have a second?
You wanna second the motion?
Okay, great.
Any further discussion?
All right, all in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
All right, the motion carries.
Thank you, Vice President Strauss.
So now I'm gonna go down to the podium and I'm gonna then present each of the students and we'll give you your certificate and then State Superintendent Thurman and President Darling-Hammond are gonna come down and take a picture with all of you all.
Yeah, I'm gonna say all of them.
I'm gonna go down to the front.
Okay, so our first semi-finalist is Christian Calcinas.
Christian?
You're going to come up.
And our second semifinalist, Jennifer Chavez-Vegna.
Our next semifinalist, Rosemary Gomez.
Our next semifinalist, Dayla Metcham.
I think Dayla came from Paradise.
I think she's not with us today.
Lea Perez.
Lea?
And our next semi-finalist, Jessica Ramos.
And our next, Ethan Collier, was one of our candidates that we interviewed.
He was a semi, congratulations.
And Elena Medina.
Elena was also one of our candidates.
And Oliver Zhang, Oliver?
And now our finalists.
And again, I'll bring up our three finalists and you can meet them and then we'll have the whole group.
So Michelle Ellis, Michelle?
Arlene Kampa.
And Zaid Fata.
So I present to you now our recommendations.
These are representative of an amazing group of students who you are now gonna hear.
And so I'd invite State Superintendent Thurman and President Darling-Hammond with them and we'll kind of take a really great picture of these amazing students that you're about to hear from.
Thank you.
No, I think this is, you're gonna hear from everybody today.
Could we have the shorter people come in the, it's just an awkward, it's an awkward photo.
But while we're taking the pictures, I'm just gonna add some of the high schools that these students are representing, because I think the public would be interested in knowing the vast cross-section of our state.
So Michelle Alas is from North Great High School in the Mount Diablo Unified District.
Arlene Campa goes to Los Angeles County High School for the Arts in LA County Office of Education.
Zaid Fata goes to Monta Vista High School in the San Ramon Valley Unified School District in Contra Costa County.
Ethan Collier is Hilltop High School in Sweetwater Union High School District in San Diego.
Elena Medina, High Tech High, Chula Vista in San Diego Unified, and Oliver Zhang, Castro Valley High School in the Castro Valley Unified School District.
Christian Calcines, Valley Academy of the Arts and Sciences between LA Unified, Jennifer Chavez-Veina, Ramona High School in the Riverside Unified School District, Rosemary Gomez, Ramona High School, also in Riverside Unified School District, Dayla Metcham, Paradise High School in Paradise Unified in Butte County, Leah Perez, Shasta High School in Shasta Union High School District, and Jessica Ramos, Skyline High School in the Oakland Unified School District, Alameda County.
These students represent the best of California and the future of our state, which we're now going to hear from.
So I just thought I'd highlight the variety of districts and counties that our students come from.
Okay, so I'm gonna turn it over to our students now who are going to be presenting their proposals.
The students have been working as part of the Student Advisory Board of Education, and they're going to share with us some comments and recommendations for our work at the state level to improve education for students.
They have lots to tell us today.
Good morning, State Superintendent Thurmond, President Darlene Hammond, and Vice President Strauss, esteemed members of the State Board of Education, and honored guests.
My name is Avery Reed.
I'm a senior at Credo High School in Sonoma County and current state president of the California Association of Student Councils, or CASC.
CASC was founded in 1947 by the California Department of Education with the intention of amplifying student voice across the state.
Today, the presentations you will hear are a vibrant manifestation of this voice.
This year's Student Advisory Board on Education has unified delegates from across California.
From San Diego up to Reading, the students seated before you identified six topics of interest in our education system.
They brainstormed respective root problems and developed original solutions to remedy the issues that they identified.
An integral part of this conference and our delegation has been the election process for the 2020 to 2021 student board member on the State Board of Education.
I would like to recommend and commend many of the people who have made this conference and process possible.
The 12 semifinalists who have taken an active role in their candidacy and their respective proposals, as well as the current student board member, Brenna Pangiolini, for conducting the elections she went through only a year ago.
Our consistent platform of presentations to the State Board of Education is an honor for us all, always.
Once again, it is CASC's privilege to represent the California Department of Education's emphasis on the inclusion of student voice in development of education policy.
Without further ado, I welcome the CASC Education Policy Director, Isaiah Colmenaro, for further details on the conference.
Thank you.
Thank you for that introduction, Avery.
Good morning, and thank you, Superintendent Tony Thurmond, President Darlene Hammond, and Vice President Strauss, as well as our esteemed board members for allowing us this amazing opportunity to present our proposals to you today.
My name is Isaiah Colmenaro, and I am a senior at High Tech High at the San Diego Unified School District.
I'm the current Education Policy Director to the California Association of Student Councils.
and the 2019 Student Advisory Board on Education Conference Director.
For over 40 years, students from all over California have come to critique, assess, evaluate the state of their public education and school systems at the annual Student Advisory Board on Education Conference.
It's been a long three days and nights of dedicated hard work, and I can assure you that the six proposals that we're presenting to you today are some of the strongest we've had.
The delegates behind me are intelligent, bright, exceptional, and open to feedback and change.
Their passion for their own education, their willingness to be flexible, and their desire to actively work for positive development in the education system inspires not only me, but the staff that helped me with this conference.
Our qualifications are simple enough.
We are the students that get up in the morning and attend school.
We are the ones who experience the California education system.
These delegates here have proven themselves to be competent in advising the State Board of Education.
With this in mind, this year's delegates have had complete control of the topics presented to you.
With no bias from staff members, delegates debated, voted, and decided on six topics that truly embody what the delegation views to be areas of concern in the California education system.
On day one, the delegates launched themselves into a long process of brainstorming possible topics.
Over the course of three days, they took it upon themselves to compress all of our different experiences, ideas, passions, wants, and needs into six sustained proposals.
We've worked long hours into the night, laying out a foundation for the proposals via root problems, assumptions, causes, and evidence associated with each individual topic.
As the days went on, the delegates refined their word choice and feasibility of these proposals.
The six issues that the Student Advisory Board on Education has decided on are areas of concern that need to be addressed in our California education system are in order, restorative justice, achievement gap, cultural responsiveness, mental health, student board member support, and sustainability.
Thank you.
We will be hearing from our first proposal, restorative justice.
Good morning, Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, and Vice President Strauss, and esteemed board members.
My name is Anika Mohanpour, and I am a senior at Berkeley High School in Berkeley, California.
The words restorative justice have come to mean a lot to me throughout my time in high school.
During my freshman year, one of my close friends was caught cheating on a test.
I can still remember the look of alarm etched into her face as the teacher sent her to our school's on-campus referral center.
Later, during lunch, she approached me, her eyes brimming with tears as she whispered to me that she was being suspended and that this suspension would go on her permanent record.
Years later, as I look back on the incident, I wish our school had different measures in place to help my friend.
Traditionally, schools have used harsh zero-tolerance policies, a practice that has led to an unnecessarily large number of suspensions and expulsions.
Certain student demographics are disproportionately affected by these suspensions and expulsions.
For example, in the 2017-2018 school year, African American students
made up only 6.5% of total California school enrollment, but composed 15.6% of total suspensions classified under willful defiance.
In contrast, white students made up 23.2% of enrollment, but only 20.2% of willful defiance suspensions.
Through conversations with students from across California, we found that students are experiencing a common underlying issue.
At most schools, the disciplinary system does not allow for students to learn from their mistakes in a restorative manner.
Some schools have been extremely successful with the enactment of positive disciplinary practices, such as restorative justice.
These programs emphasize the principle that the individuals most affected by a crime should be able to participate in its resolution.
However, many schools have not implemented positive disciplinary practices.
Suspensions and expulsions often have long-lasting impacts on students.
A study done by Johns Hopkins University found that suspension increased the chance of a student dropping out of school from 16% to 32%.
Suspensions and expulsions also lead to feelings of negativity among students about school and contribute to the school-to-prison pipeline.
Once students are put into contact with law enforcement for disciplinary reasons, many are pushed out of the educational environment and into the juvenile and criminal justice systems.
Statistically, students of minority backgrounds are punished more harshly than their white peers.
The treatment and opportunities people receive in their youth fall them into the future.
A single suspension in the first year of high school doubles the dropout rate chance for that child.
Children who are expelled are three times more likely to end up in the juvenile justice system.
For these reasons, the Student Advisory Board on Education proposes that the superintendent of public instruction facilitate the publication of a blueprint for positive disciplinary practices
which would serve as an implementation model that local educational agencies could reference when developing alternative ways to address and correct student misbehavior.
This blueprint, facilitated by the Superintendent of Public Instruction, will serve only as a primary resource and provide guidance to local agencies, not create a statewide mandate.
The proposed blueprint could perhaps contain information that would aid schools in implementing positive disciplinary programs such as peer-to-peer mentoring groups as well as faculty training.
There is an imminent need for this blueprint.
A couple of months ago, Governor Newsom signed Senate Bill 419.
To summarize, this bill would prohibit schools from suspending students in grades K-8 for willful defiance.
This bill will be enacted in July of next year.
This means that within the next seven months, school districts that have traditionally suspended students for acting out in class will need to find new ways to address and correct student misbehavior since they can no longer suspend or expel for willful defiance.
Without guidance from key experts, researchers, and other stakeholders, school districts may unknowingly implement new practices that are ineffective and counteractive to what the bill intends to address.
While some individual school districts have already implemented restorative justice systems, not all districts have the prior experience or the capacity to create quality disciplinary plans in such a short time frame.
The role of the California Department of Education is to assist local educational agencies in making the right decisions for their own students.
The creation of a blueprint using statewide resources could guide any school district, regardless of prior experience or resources, in the right direction.
We envision an education system with positive disciplinary measures that allow students to grow from their mistakes and feel supported by staff.
As such, the Student Advisory Board on Education proposes that the Superintendent for Public Instruction facilitate the creation of a blueprint that serves as a reference for schools to develop alternative methods to addressing and correcting student misbehavior.
This new blueprint would provide guidance for local educational agencies to flourish in a manner that is most beneficial to their students.
Thank you.
So this proposal had a number of folks who are involved in developing it so I want to ask them to stand and come forward because if you have a few questions we can ask the representatives of this proposal.
Are there others here who were involved?
Come on forward.
Thank you all for the great work on this and well after each of these we'll take a few minutes to see if anybody has any questions they want to ask or any comments they want to make.
What a good looking group.
So my understanding is that you are asking the Department of Ed, the California Department of Education, to create a resource for school districts to use to help implement restorative practices, is that right?
Go ahead, you can say something on the microphone and answer.
And include student, come to the microphone and tell us specifically what you're asking, because we're actually talking to State Superintendent Thurmond about his,
work that they might do that you're asking for.
So, want to clarify that?
So, the creation of this blueprint is solely to be a resource for schools and for local educational agencies.
We understand that not all areas are the same, not all schools are the same, and all schools have different needs.
But for the schools who do not have the resources or the experience or the capability to go in depth on what practices would be best, this state-researched and explored blueprint would provide a strong resource for them to implement positive disciplinary practices.
First of all, thank you for the presentation.
I think it is an excellent idea.
The only question I have for you at this time is, is this something that you'd be willing to work on from the idea, concept, formation stage to actually presenting it before an assembly committee to bring it forward if it requires any legislative action?
Would you be willing to work on it?
Rather than leave the idea on my desk, which I'm happy to have,
Are you willing to also put in some elbow grease, you know, some work to actually see it implemented and actually used?
We would most definitely.
Very good.
And we would be honored to be able to help in the process.
Well, we have you on record now.
And I'll just say that in the past, you know, I have introduced legislation that has come to us from CASC.
And two bills, actually, one that has been signed into law that guarantees that every school board in the state should have a voting student board member.
And so your efforts have real impact.
And so our team is paying attention to what you present today.
We have a whole bunch of questions about how we get implemented.
But I applaud you for your interest and for your presentation.
Go Yellow Jackets, my old assembly district.
Thank you so much for what you presented and we look forward to working with you.
Thank you.
We have a second presentation.
So we have six presentations.
So we have five more.
And what we'll do is just so the committees of the students are ready after the speaker from your group is we'll have the committee come up and then we'll have any clarifying questions from state board staff or the department of it.
So next group.
So good morning, Superintendent Thurmond, President Hammond, and esteemed board members.
My name is Alvin Lee, and I'm a junior attending Mission San Jose High School in the Fremont Unified School District in Fremont, California.
We, the Student Advisory Board on Education, also known as SABE, collectively worked together this week to identify issues we saw that were pertinent to the California education system.
Throughout the course of the conference, through deeper discussions with my fellow committee members, we identified that achievement gaps within the California education system are symptoms stemming from a lack of student involvement on superintendent appointed work groups and state board commissions and committees.
And so we ask that the superintendent of public instruction appoints one or more students to 12 superintendent appointed transition teams, which can be referred to in section three of your proposal packets in front of you.
In addition, we recommend that the State Board of Education add student members to its commissions and committees, specifically onto the California Practitioners Advisory Group, the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, and the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
I have a good friend, Miguel, who lived two houses down from me.
His parents were both undocumented immigrants who fled from Mexico about four years ago.
He comes from a socioeconomically disadvantaged background and has very limited access to educational resources.
He lived in the garage of his uncle's home.
and didn't have access to basic technological needs to succeed in today's academic environment.
He often came over to my house to eat dinner, use our computers, get homework help.
Miguel is tasked with being his own advocate when it comes to attaining educational resources that are given for me.
It is for this reason that students must have a platform in which to advocate for each other and their education.
The State Board of Education and the Office of the Superintendent of Public Instruction cannot equitably allocate resources among students without their firsthand experience.
We recognize the efforts being made by Superintendent Thurmond via his transitional team work groups.
We also recognize the work of the State Board of Education through its commissions and committees such as the California Practitioner Advisory Group, the Commission on Charter Schools, and the Commission on Special Education.
However, we believe that in order for these bodies to be used to their full potential, they must include the perspectives of the main stakeholders, the 6.3 million diverse students here in California.
Historically, both superintendent-appointed work groups and State Board of Education commissions and committees have included all educational stakeholders except students.
Students bring a unique perspective that can only be captured through firsthand experience, which points the respective groups in otherwise overlooked directions.
The achievement gaps are a symptom of this lack of recognition to address student issues via student voices.
Through their firsthand experiences, students are able to better identify overlooked issues that are the primary contributors to the achievement gaps in and of itself.
Additionally, educators, policymakers, and the superintendent all have their own understanding of what the achievement gaps are, either in a theoretical sense or based on dated past experiences as students.
On the other hand, students of today have firsthand knowledge of what their needs are.
Thus, student perspective in these respective groups is pertinent to bridging differing understandings of the achievement gaps.
Furthermore, the perspective of student board members shapes the respective group's understanding of equity, which allows the state board to more effectively allocate resources.
This, in turn, restores a sense of urgent agency within students, empowering them to become actively involved within their education.
Having students on these respective groups fosters a sense of transparency, as it gives students the authority to hold the respective groups accountable for their actions and implementations.
This engagement combats historical minority disenfranchisement within the education system, giving way to potential for increasing graduation rates and ultimately the pursuit of higher education.
At first glance, we understand the relationship between student involvement and achievement gaps may seem like a stretch due to its unorthodox nature.
However, through careful consideration of the rationale outlined in the proposal in front of you, a clear correlation can be drawn.
Students who are the primary stakeholders in the education system are absolutely essential to bridging the various understandings of the achievement gap.
It is imperative that we add a student representative to these respective work groups and commissions.
Thank you.
So will the committee that came up to develop this proposal come forward and then board members or Department of Ed or State Superintendent, President Darling-Hammond, we might have some questions for the students.
Okay, so Member Sandoval, and then Member Rucker, and then maybe State Superintendent Thurmond, right?
Okay, so Member Sandoval?
Thank you so much for your well-thought presentation and paper and your research, and I know many of you were up all night finishing your work, so thank you.
I have the privilege of serving as the liaison on special education issues with the Advisory Commission on Special Education, and there is a student member
on the Advisory Commission on Special Education and has been for a very long time and that student voice is so important to everything that we do and particularly regarding special education issues.
So I do want to let you know that that voice is certainly represented and we often hear from students and family members out in the community.
So thank you so much for your good work.
Member Rucker.
Well, I want to thank you all for being here today and I noticed as I was listening to Mr. Lee's very cogent presentation, the diversity of school districts that all of you come from.
What I really appreciated about the thought that you put into this comment, this is probably the freshest perspective I have heard in my time on the board.
about student voice because you touched on the issue of student agency.
For most students in your high schools, the students who have that sense of agency are people who are in positions and doing work like you.
But you're aware at your own high school campuses among your peer group that a lot of your peers don't have that same sense of agency that you have.
And I can tell by the way you're nodding your head that that's true.
And so this issue about student voice is not just something you're giving lip service to.
You are explaining and helping us to understand it's not just the presence of the students on these commissions, but what it actually says about the commitment
of the people in a leadership position to each of you individually and to your student peers as a group.
So I really want to thank you for the perspective you gave about this idea of agency.
And I do have just one question.
So when you go back to your campuses and with the students and your peers that you thought about, that you had in mind as you were doing this, what are you going to be able to tell them
about what happened today and what it is you were able to bring back to them as a promise.
What do you think you'll be able to tell them?
So through this process of participating in the SABE conference, I found out that my school board, so my school is under the L.A.
County Office of Education.
So we do not actually have a district board for student voices to be heard, and we do not have a member on the Office of Education board because it's not mandated.
So I think what we're going back into our communities is our own sense of agency to take control of that.
And then also, you know, the fact that there are different ways to demand change that maybe aren't legislative.
Maybe that's, you know.
a little sit-in on the principal's office or challenging what a teacher might have to say.
There are small victories that we can take in order to regain sense of agency within our own education.
I appreciate that answer, so I'm going to give you a piece of advice and remind you.
Frederick Douglass once said, power concedes nothing without a demand.
It never has and it never will.
So I will be right there with you in spirit as you do the work to do that advocacy and get a student member on your local boards.
And again, I really want to thank you for the conversation you offered us today and that very fresh perspective about student agency.
Superintendent Thurmond.
Well, there you have it.
You have a quote and a mandate and a charge from board member Rucker citing Frederick Douglass.
Thank you for the presentation.
So as to your question, as to your demand, I should say, that there be students on our transition work groups, the answer is yes, we accept your demand and your inquiry.
What we'd like to do is work with you to make sure that student participation is not in any way a token kind of participation.
We want students to have equal voice and access and so we'd like to work with you on that.
By the way, our office has been working on creating student focus groups to ask students across the state
for impact on how we help our students do better on statewide tests, especially because we've noticed a huge drop off in the older grades.
We suspect that students might have some ideas about how we help to counter that.
And so my question to you is, would you be willing to work with us in that way?
And could you see a way of creating
At the school level, groups that are focused on closing the achievement gap, meaning student-led groups that are focused on how we close the achievement gap and advise the educators and leaders on campus and advise the Department of Education and the State Board on how we connect it all up statewide.
Would you be willing to work with us on developing out such a concept?
Well, yeah, I mean, to answer your first question, I think I can collectively say on behalf of all the committee here, heck yeah, we'll work with you on getting students into your transitional workforces.
But in regards to your second question, which is an amazing point, CASC here, specifically at the SABE conference, it represents a diverse collection of students from across California.
And a lot of members here are actually students.
A lot of members here are actually local student board members that sit on their local board of education.
And so it would be really impactful is if perhaps, like you said, we collectively work together, CASC as well as the Superintendent Office of Public Instruction, to really hone in the student board members
in lobbying to their local school board or local superintendent on instituting these select task forces or whatever select committees on their local school board's institute for these kind of identifications and solution processes.
We're excited to work with CASC.
It's been an honor to work with your members.
I would just say this, you know, you all, you know, there are a thousand, more than a thousand school districts in the state.
And so we can't expect you to be everywhere.
And so we want to work with you, but we also want to figure out how to engage other students who may not be a member of CAST, who may not be a member of a youth organization.
to be a part of the solution, maybe on their school site or in their county.
And to be frank, we're actually thinking that by asking students to get involved, we might even be able to help students themselves improve their own student performance by asking them to be part of the solution.
So, but we like to do that with your kind of coaching and guidance on how to set that up and how to maximize that and make that a really effective strategy.
You down for that?
Yeah, let's do it.
Awesome.
And Member Sung wanted to follow up with a comment too, Superintendent Thurmond.
Just wanted you to know that two or three staff in the office, in the room, in the chamber, who are going to want to meet you today.
Julian Cuevas, who is the head of our government affairs division, is going to want to talk to you all.
He's been walking around and talking to the restorative justice participants.
And Mary Nicely, who's overseeing our work groups, is also in the room.
They're going to want to meet you and figure out how we make this more than a one-off, and that we find a way to work together to move it forward.
Great job, and thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, and also I just want to thank the excellent proposal.
Thank you very much.
And then I just want us to be cognizant that to have students participate, we also want to ensure that we provide funding for transportation to these committees and then also to ensure that they get excused from school from the principle that this is a very worthwhile endeavor and educational endeavor as well.
All right.
Well, thank you.
We have more to hear.
So thank you all.
We're going to look forward to hearing the next proposal as well.
So thank you all very, very much.
Okay, the next group come forward.
Next presenter, please.
Good morning, Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, and esteemed board members.
My name is Angel Jimenez, and I'm a senior attending Mountain View High School in the El Monte Union High School District, where I proudly serve as its student board member.
On behalf of the Student Advisory Board on Education, we strongly recommend that the Superintendent's Existing Professional Development Transitional Work Group create relevant cultural responsiveness resources for California educators and staff, and make this material available on the Teacher Resource page of the CDE's website.
My kindergarten teacher was the first teacher I ever had that looked like me, a male Latino in education.
His name was Mr. Montoya, and every day I came into his classroom with such curiosity and excitement that I felt that I could save the world.
I remember the safe environment he created in discussing significant cultural figures, Cesar Chavez, Martin Luther King Jr., Harvey Milk, all leaders who represented the underrepresented, the traditionally oppressed groups of people, including, but not limited to, Latinos, African-Americans, and members of the LGBTQ plus community.
Mr. Montoya's teachings have stuck with me for the 12 years since I was in his class.
And I know this to be true, not just because he looks like me, but because he understood my cultural background as an underrepresented student.
I have been fortunate enough to have had the opportunity to be taught by similar teachers who are culturally competent, even when they do not look like me.
However, not all students have this opportunity.
In observing situations across various regions of California where educators are not as culturally competent, we found that underrepresented students are overly encouraged to attend community college when they're more than qualified to attend a four-year university.
They were encouraged to aim lower than their ability.
At a school in Danville, a student wrote, whites only, no blacks allowed, in Sharpie, on a school bathroom urinal.
At a school in Bakersfield, politically motivated students stood outside of a Gay-Straight Alliance meeting, forming a tunnel to bombard students exiting the meeting and saying they would, quote, burn in hell and their club shouldn't be allowed.
In light of observing these situations, we believe that uninformed and misinformed educated perspectives on the experiences of underrepresented students allows for the proliferation of hate speech, academic inequality, and injustice in the classroom.
When thinking about what we could have done differently to have prevented these situations, we questioned whether or not relevant resources were in place for teachers to access.
We researched the resources that already existed and stumbled across a page for teachers on the CDE website under LCFF priority one, which linked us to a cultural understanding module from Vanderbilt University.
The module included an outdated video depicting a single oversimplified situation where two white teachers were struggling to understand and assist a Mexican immigrant named Maria.
Resources like this module only highlight cultural misunderstandings between educators and students.
Although we do appreciate that this page exists with the intent of improving cultural competency for teachers, we believe that new resources should be created to provide methods for educators and school staff to learn how to empower and teach all students regardless of their perceived cultural differences.
We are not proposing the creation of new curriculum, but instead suggesting a framework designed by recognized experts already within the Department of Education.
This framework is geared towards educators and school staff who need to navigate sensitive cultural topics in a comfortable and respectable way for all.
In creating this new relevant page that replaces the old, teachers can effectively facilitate charged conversations with enhanced cultural comprehension.
Considering California Assembly Member Jose Medina's Assembly Bill AB331, which mandates ethnic studies as a graduation requirement, California's education system is taking a necessary step to providing all students with equal representation in and outside of the classroom.
The proposal that we provide with you today would bolster AB331 by demonstrating the importance behind this new curriculum to their students.
As a result, this proposal enacted would prepare educators to feel comfortable teaching culturally sensitive topics and handle difficult cultural situations, thus allowing students to feel accepted, motivated, and safe at school.
We can't expect students to thrive in a school environment where they do not see themselves positively reflected.
This proposal would therefore decrease chronic absenteeism among underrepresented populations.
I stand here today, much like the leaders I learned about in kindergarten, representing the underrepresented.
With a new diverse generation of students in California schools, there needs to be an increase in attention on cultural competency, as it is every student's right to learn in a safe and comfortable environment.
For these reasons, we strongly suggest that the superintendent's existing professional development transitional work group create relevant cultural responsiveness resources for California educators and staff and make it available on the teacher resource page on the CDE's website.
I hope that California can pave the way to an education system where no one has to feel misrepresented.
Thank you.
Can we have the committee that supported this work come forward and then we're going to start our questions with board member Ortiz-Lincoln.
Thank you for that.
I'm very inspired by everything that you said, Angel, and welcome back.
I know you were a finalist last year, and I had the privilege of interviewing you, so I'm happy to see that you have continued the work.
I have to say that as you were speaking,
I thought a lot about some of the things that we're living now that perhaps that video that you saw would not have anticipated or was not accurately addressing.
When we think of culturally responsive practice or materials, we really need to think bigger.
We need to think of a culturally responsive system, right?
So I think it's great to have those resources available to classroom teachers, but really we need to think of practices, policies,
the microaggressions that sometimes are hard to point and say, I felt like I was offended, but I can't really figure out why, right?
Those are microaggressions.
It's the new way of being culturally, attacking somebody culturally.
So I know that for all of you standing before us, and yesterday I want to say that Elena
You really touched me when you said three things during your interview.
You said, whenever we approach something, you should always ask, is this ethical?
Is it student-centered?
Is it evidence-based?
And I think that's also very appropriate as we look at our systems.
Are the systems that we have, are they student-centered?
Are they responsive to the students that we're serving?
And if not, we really need to interrogate those systems and change them.
So I want to encourage us to think of how we could provide those resources for educators
But think a little bit bigger in terms of how do we create a system so that teachers who are your first grade, Mr. Montoya, feel supported.
So they're not just the sole star in the constellation trying to shine bright, but that there's a system of support for him.
We want to make sure that there's leaders that encourage that in their school settings.
We want to make sure there's superintendents, that there's policymakers, so that this is a system of culturally responsive practices that really dignify the students that are part of it.
And I thank you, all of you, for bringing this to light for us, and I hope that we really take some of your recommendations to heart.
Thank you.
Thank you Madam Vice President.
I just want to acknowledge you all for your great work and somewhere Mr. Montoya I'm sure is smiling proud and you know as you laid out the presentation you touched on several things that the department and the State Board are working on.
Most of them are ways to we've set an aspirational goal to get to a place that we're not at right that we would
be able to diversify our workforce.
And those are things that we're talking about.
And so as I sat here listening to your presentation, I thought, wow, you've got our playlist.
And it would be great to have you and your colleagues be our technical assistants and advisors on all of these things that we're dreaming about and the things that we're doing, that you all could coach us and give us your perspective on all this research that you've done.
You literally ticked off a million things, right?
The way you started.
We've been talking this year about how do we expand
a pipeline of male educators of color in education, particularly in the elementary school grades.
And then you came up and you just made that your dissertation, right?
You said kindergarten.
And all I could think of was that saying that they say, everything I needed to learn, I learned in kindergarten.
And you got it all, and you're using it to help others.
We have been talking about implicit bias training and addressing unconscious bias.
And so your focus on culturally relevant training and a curriculum is certainly in tune with that.
We have been continuing to work on how we deliver a model ethnic studies curriculum guide to help our school districts have conversations
in ways that students see those who've contributed who look like them and they can see the connections and so just every you know we we've supported legislation this year that the governor has signed to help us help educators better support lgbtq students in our school spaces so everything that you outlined
are key issues of the day and we'd like to work with you all if you are willing to be advisors to us to help us create stronger proposals in each of these areas.
So thank you for your presentation and great job.
Thank you.
We'll take our next presenter.
Good morning Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, and esteemed members of the board.
My name is Mina Lee and I am a sophomore attending John Marshall Senior High School in the Los Angeles Unified School District.
I am here to speak about the rising issue of mental health on behalf of the students of California.
We propose that the superintendent of public instruction ensure one or more high school student members are appointed to the student mental health policy work group with full voting rights and duties.
Youth in California have experienced deterioration in mental health due to a lack of implementation of existing curriculum, chronic absence, family problems, and more.
This decline has led to consequences such as truancy, chronic absenteeism, self-harm, and even suicide.
Students struggle with anxiety, depression, and other challenges, yet due to stigma surrounding these issues, existing mental health resources are not utilized.
This lack of accessibility is exemplified by the fact that 42% of students are unsure if they're properly managing their stress, and 13% do not even consider their stress levels.
Improperly treating mental health issues, even relatively minor ones, leads to irreparable harm to students' well-being and future.
All students who worked on this proposal know multiple peers who have struggled with mental health issues, including suicidal thoughts.
A year ago, a close friend of mine told me that he attempted suicide.
He attempted to take his own life because he felt like he did not have support.
He felt alone.
Coincidentally, I was also going through the same thoughts because of the same reasons.
I, like many students across the state, felt that there was no emotional support or acknowledgement that we were human beings, not just statistics.
No students should ever have to feel this way.
Issues regarding student mental health in schools is an extensive problem, but it is a problem that can be solved.
We envision a school where every student is provided with the same environment to talk about their insecurities, where students are aware of resources and support around them, and where no student takes their own life for any reason.
Schools prevent mental health issues so that everyone feels represented and supported.
To aspire this vision, we urge the superintendent of public instruction to ensure that there is at least one high school student member on the student mental health policy work group at all times.
This work group focuses on the development of policy recommendations related to mental health training for educators, student safety, and other mental health related issues.
Although this workgroup was developed with the intention of helping students, it lacks a high school student member to provide critical feedback and a relevant perspective.
The implementation of a high school student filling the student member role every year will require an updated and standardized application process with questions in essay format, an application deadline, and a selection timeline.
To publicize this position, the superintendent of public instruction will publish a letter to all students, teachers, counselors, principals, and other constituents of California school districts.
The superintendent will then work with a variety of advocacy groups who work with students directly, such as CAS, to identify potential students to serve on the work group.
It is vital to have a high school student on the work group because almost all students experience some form of mental health struggles and therefore have a crucial perspective on this issue.
We believe that without a student member, the work group is unable to counteract the mental health challenges facing students today due to their limited perspective on this issue.
With the prevalence of media and many other ever-changing cultural challenges, a student's voice is necessary to fully understand this issue.
This student representative will speak to the ideas of their community and generation.
Please prioritize the student mental health by ensuring that there is at least one high school member in the student mental health policy and work group.
Thank you for your time and consideration.
We have the students who are part of this work group come forward and then we'll ask the board members for some comments.
Anybody want to talk?
Thank you.
I just want to acknowledge you for a great presentation and say, thank you for what you've presented and what you've requested.
And the short answer is yes, we will be happy to work to ensure that there are high school students on the mental health work group.
I also wanted to thank you for all that you presented.
You're a great leader, and I think it really speaks to an issue in our country that we fail to talk about the importance of addressing mental health for young people and for all people.
And when we start talking about it, we remove the stigma that allows people to get support.
And so it's a critical issue.
We'd like to work with you directly on it.
Thank you for your leadership on it.
And know that the governor and the legislature have provided $50 million in the budget that just passed this year for school-based mental health programs.
There's a state mental health advisory oversight commission that's making decisions about how that money would be spent.
We'd like to make sure that your voices are included in what those guidelines should look like.
So thank you, and we look forward to working with you.
Thank you guys very much.
Thank you all.
Thank you.
Good morning Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, and honorable members of the board.
My name is Aubriana McNamara and I am a junior at Somerville Union High School within the Somerville Union High School District in Tuolumne County.
I am here to speak with you upon the topic of student board member support.
The Student Advisory Board on Education proposes that the Superintendent of Public Instruction directs the creation of a board outline on how to guide districts and provide training for student board members.
We the students believe that this topic and the guidelines should include, but is not limited to, roles and responsibilities, procedure for meetings, skills of being an effective voice, critical thinking, implicit bias, which should be implemented through the student board member training blueprint.
With this, we strongly believe that after the blueprint is created, it should be located on the California Department of Education website and that it is distributed to all district boards and superintendents.
We understand that each district has very specific needs due to the diversity within California.
Our overall goal is to provide guidance for school districts so that they can best make the decision on implementing this training blueprint.
Over the years, the student voice hasn't been heard on a local level.
The lack of student voice has created a disconnect between students, board members, school staff, and policy makers.
The disconnect between the adult direction of education systems and the students in the classroom has created a lack of motivation and involvement.
In what ways can we address this feeling of being misunderstood and unmotivated?
First of all, there is a need to improve the quality of student voices, and this is where we need your help.
We found that there isn't a free and in-depth student board member training.
There are organizations that specify board member training, like CASC and CSBA, where the training is attended by members of certain districts, but others are not always provided with the same opportunity.
Audrey Mollet, an Ablin Unified School District student board member, attended a CSBA training and expressed that, although the training was a positive learning experience, I wish there was more district-specific components to guide my experience as a student board member.
She believes that the district-level training would benefit the students in a greater way to see what their district better needs to serve.
Yet, she's an example of a fortunate one.
Many student board members are not able to attend these trainings due to high costs.
Although there are ways to get scholarships, it's a very limited selection process.
I personally would not be here today at this conference without a scholarship due to financial circumstances.
Lacking financial aid leads to the need for student support, which I luckily had.
But we know that many student board members who need but lack the opportunity to and ability to attend these trainings.
The way we believe we can fix this by allowing a free training at a district level.
In a survey conducted by Coagula Institute, 66,000 students were surveyed and it was found that 53% of students felt they did not have a voice in their school.
And 54% of students felt that they were not a valued number in their school community.
But all hope is not lost.
Students believed that they did have a voice, were seven times more likely to be academically involved.
We believe that increasing the voice of the students begins with maximizing the mechanisms of the student voice that already exists.
This can easily be executed through our proposal of creating a statewide blueprint and training student board members to reach their full potentials.
As we know, there are applications and ways for individuals to join district boards as a student member, but in order to accurately voice the student's opinions and concerns, the board members need training.
Creating this process will allow student board members to be more self-aware and aware of their surrounding peers and community through lack of support of state holders in the education.
This concern of student voice and the student board members would become involved with the needs of the school and the students and be able to speak upon important educational topics.
Training districts and student board members will allow them to gain credibility and trust within the state of California.
Similar to how Brenna, the state student board member, is trained by the State Board of Education, helping her students' needs with an extensive knowledge base.
Why are we not training our district student board members at the same capacity that we are training our CSBE board member when we have those training materials?
The improved communication between the board level policies in the classroom will help close the gap through the explanation of student board members.
Therefore, we urge the California Department of Education to provide a blueprint on how to train student board members.
Many states, including Oregon, Texas, and New York, have already created these student board member training processes.
Why is California, a progressive education state, falling short?
California needs to meet these other states in preparing their student success, especially in standing up for their own needs.
Being a student board member has a steep learning curve.
And in most cases, student board members only serve for one year, and when the next student board member enters, they're just as unprepared as the last.
With this tool of developing a training system, districts will be able to ensure that students enter the board member position, prepare to serve effectively, and create a positive change for students they represent.
Thank you for your time.
So let's have the committee that helped develop this recommendation come forward.
and see if we have any comments from our board.
First of all, thank you all for your desire to be well educated as board members.
We'd like all board members to want that kind of training and it's just really a wonderful thing to hear about students both desiring to be effective and understanding that
there are ways to actually get that background information to do so.
So I just want to congratulate you on both the desire for learning and the very good ideas for how to acquire it.
And I know it's something that we will want to be advocating for in the in the work in this state.
Okay, thank you.
Well, we have another comment.
Oh, sorry, I didn't see.
Go ahead, please.
Thank you for that and I'm sorry I missed some of the presentation, but you know as you were presenting, I honestly don't know that we gave board member pendulum and a lot of onboarding training I think all of us just come in.
No, it's just like, hi, you're here.
And so I think that that would be a really action.
I think it's a great idea though because I know that because of the recommendations we heard last year, we now have a student that will be joining the Instructional Quality Commission.
And so it is important for us to prep the students and let them know just make sure that you have an authentic voice at the table.
We never want a student who comes into the room serving as the only student and then getting their energy sucked by all the adults in the room, right?
And so, and which it happens, and it could be very intimidating.
So I do think that if we consider putting more students in different commissions, there has to be an onboarding process for them so they understand why were you selected, why is your voice important, how does it work to turn on the mic?
The small things from the logistical things, the reimbursement eventually will be huge.
We never want a student who should be at the table not being able to travel because they don't have credit cards, they don't have money.
That is a reality of many of our families.
And so I wanna make sure that we are very thoughtful in when we bring students so that they understand what their role is and also what the task is at hand.
So thank you for that recommendation.
Okay, well, thank you all very much for the work, the rewrite, the research, all the data and your passion for wanting to be an informed voice to help us with our work and at your local level too.
So thank you very much.
And we have one more group that we're gonna hear about that will be a different proposal as well.
Good morning, distinguished board members and Superintendent Thurman.
My name is Estrella Pacheco.
I attend the Annalee High School in the West Sonoma County Union High School District.
And I am here today to speak to you about sustainability in education.
For the fourth time in a period of three years, students in my county have been unable to attend school because of a natural disaster.
Just this last week, a quarter of a million students, including myself, were out of schools statewide due to wildfires.
California's fourth climate change assessment projects that if greenhouse gas emissions continue to rise, wildfires that burn over 25,000 acres will increase in frequency by 50% during the next 100 years.
Evidence like this has created growing concern among California students regarding the current climate crisis.
and the detrimental effects it will continue to have on posterity.
These concerns include deterioration of health, loss of school days, progression to an unlivable planet, and lower quality of life.
With this in mind, our group has created a proposal that will both provide ways for students to move towards a sustainable future and outline model practices to achieve this.
Currently, local education agencies are required to address eight statewide priorities on their local control accountability plan or LCAP.
Within the first priority area, basic services, schools currently address three key areas.
These being one, teachers are assigned and fully credentialed for the students they are teaching.
Two, students have access to standards aligned instructional materials resources.
And three, school facilities are maintained in good repair.
Our proposal is that the LCAP template be modified to add a fourth key area called school facilities are environmentally sustainable.
As the State Board of Education is currently updating the framework of the LCAP, the addition of the fourth key area is timely and easily implementable.
I'm sure you are all concerned that we are trying to add a new priority to the LCAP.
I assure you, we are not.
We understand that adding a priority to the LCAP requires legislative action, which is not under your jurisdiction.
To clarify again, we are not proposing the addition of a new priority.
What we are proposing is the addition of a new key area under an existing priority.
Doing this is under the jurisdiction of the State Board of Education.
This way, when local educational agencies are developing their LCAPs with stakeholders, they are considering goals and actions that address sustainability.
By adding the environmental impact of facilities as a key area within basic services on the LCAP, schools would actively create goals to work towards sustainability when developing their funding plans.
The LCAP would also recommend that schools implement model practices outlined in our proposal or sustainable practices within infrastructure.
This would increase the standard for sustainability in California's education.
California is often acknowledged for being notably progressive in regards to environmental policy and action.
In 2018, Governor Brown signed Senate Bill 100, which states that California will transition to 100% renewable energy by 2045.
This simply cannot be accomplished without the cooperation of the school system.
As the state is already moving towards this goal, our schools should be fully able to join in on this transition.
Blueprints from the California Department of Education and both the Senate and Assembly bills provide guidelines not only for easily adoptable and sustainable practices in school districts, but also for methods to measure progress and effectiveness of their action plans using water usage, energy usage, carbon footprints, and other metrics.
The addition of this segment to the LCAP would provide districts with plans to move towards sustainability, which are concrete, feasible, and proven to be effective.
In the city of Salinas, the transition to the use of solar and LED lights are expected to save the Salinas Union High School District $32 million over the next 25 years and offset 826 metric tons of carbon dioxide emissions.
Imagine both the fiscal and environmental impacts that could be achieved if all California public schools could make a similar transition.
As microcosms of society, schools provide the perfect opportunity to influence students' actions.
By implementing sustainable facilities in schools, students will be inclined to make environmentally friendly decisions off campus as well.
The modification to the LCAP framework would simultaneously counter the effects of the current climate crisis and create environmentally literate students at no additional cost to the California Department of Education.
The science is clear, the time for action is now.
There is no reason that California's educational system should not move towards sustainability, as such a transition will protect the future of the students within it.
It is certain that the climate crisis will change our schools, but it is up to those who oversee our education to determine whether these changes will be detrimental or not.
By choosing to implement this proposal, you will help our schools create a path for California's students to have a positive, sustainable, and livable future.
Thank you for your time and consideration.
Will the students in this committee come forward?
Member Rucker, as soon as they're here, then you can start.
Well, first of all, I want to thank all of you for your very thoughtful and very creative idea.
You know, I have family who live across the country in other states, and when they watch the news about the fires in California, not really understanding the geography of California,
they will call me with great concern to ask me how close the fires are and should they be concerned, do I need money and all of those types of things.
So while I appreciate that, what I become aware of, especially today, is that for a lot of folks, the environmental concerns that have directly impacted
you, and particularly Australia, are things that are just news items.
It's not personal to them and it's not of a great concern to them.
What I appreciate about what you all did with your proposal today is you made it clear that our schools are a contributing factor to the very problems and the very personal impact that you have experienced multiple times in your life.
And this is something that this is another thing that we that demonstrates how we compartmentalize the conversation about climate change and the impact of climate change.
So what I appreciate most about what you suggest is not only why it's important,
but understanding how it changes the way we have this conversation and how it changes the way we choose to live with this conversation by modeling that it's not something singularly compartmentalized to an area of policy about changing gas emissions or changing the kind of cars and the type of energy we use,
but also creating the environments that students live and work and learn in.
So I really appreciate your proposal and I do support this notion and this idea.
I know that there's more to making changes on the LCAP template than just simply
adding a statement like this, but for students, it makes the students who especially have been in areas impacted like yours, it changes the complexion of the conversation to know that there's another part of this discussion, another part of the policy community
that's choosing to get engaged in a very specific way.
So, I appreciate not only your articulate argument, but also the rationale about what the sustained effect of a proposal as simple as that can be.
So, thank you so very much for being here today.
You've brought, yes, great job, and you've brought us full circle from our conversation this morning, so we appreciate that, too.
This has been a theme of the day, and you've come up with a really good, concrete proposal for how to advance the cause, so we appreciate your thinking concretely as well as passionately about the issue.
I'll just close by thanking this committee and all the other committees for not only making a strong argument to us, but the research that you gave us to support your arguments around data and research that you did and looking at our website and all of our links really showed the thought and the depth of trying to build on what we're doing.
really to a credit to all the students who participated in the organization of it.
We just really appreciate the thought and commitment and the persuasiveness and the arguments that you made for us.
So thank you all very, very much.
Did you want to get a photo with the students or?
Okay, all right.
I'm fine.
Thank you again to the esteemed board members, Vice President Strauss, President Darling-Hamden, and Superintendent Thurmond for listening to our proposals from this year's SAVE Conference.
And I sincerely hope that very shortly we can turn these ideas that started in a conference room into actions implemented by you, the State Board of Education.
Thank you for your time.
I think we want to appreciate all of the groups and say how much it brings inspiration and
sort of reassurance to us about the future of our state to see the quality of passion, commitment, and thinking that this process and these students have brought.
So I think at this point, we're going to go on with the agenda.
Students, if you're ready to move on, you can.
But if you want to sit for the state board meeting, you're also welcome to educate yourselves further.
And we'll give you a minute to exit if you'd like to.
Yeah, not for too long.
We should take a photo.
Yeah, right, for all the... Either is fine, yeah.
1130, we'll... Do you want me to meet you up there?
Okay.
I'll meet you in your office then.
Reconvene.
Thank everyone for your perseverance, stamina.
We're going to move on to agenda item 3, which is the system of support item.
CDE will be presenting.
Stephanie Gregson will be presenting for us.
The CDE is requesting feedback on the continued development of the statewide system of support.
No action is being recommended at this time.
So, Stephanie, please proceed.
Yes, good morning everyone.
We're excited today to present about the progress on the system of support because as we know, this is a journey.
This is a journey that we're on together in this work and with me I have Ronnie Jones from the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
They are our partners along with the state board in the system of support.
As you might remember, the system of support is made up of geographic leads, SELPA system improvement and content leads, multi-tiered system of support lead, the community engagement lead, the Title III English learner liaison that's a lead for the 11 English learner leads across the state,
equity leads and the early math initiative.
These lead agencies were selected because they have the experience or expertise in specific areas described in the statute and this map shows you the coverage of California with all of the different leads.
The intended purpose of the statewide system of support is to provide coherent and effective supports to local education agencies through coordinated activities between the California Department of Education, the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, and the State Board of Education, and the lead agencies on the previous slide.
And it's growing.
The intent is growing, as we've learned and had a discussion about yesterday with our panel discussion on our data pieces.
Research tells us that coherent and effective systems create intentional connections, are interdependent, adapt to new learnings and shifting environment, such as the introduction of the California School Leadership Academy and the Educator Workforce Investment Grant, and I think there will be more.
Okay, and positively, and this is most important, and positively impact student opportunities and outcomes.
Our goal for the system of support is to ensure that all LEAs have access to the supports they need to improve outcomes and opportunities for students.
This means that the systems we're building looks like this web.
If the LEAs are the blue marbles, then the lead agencies are the black and gray marbles.
This system supports capacity building at both the LEA and county office of education level, develops and shares and implements resources targeted to local needs, and facilitate improvement and equity in the LEAs and the county offices across our state.
This is a complex structure.
And I'll turn this over to Ronnie to explain the complexities and set context for our presentation today.
Great.
Thanks very much.
As Stephanie said, I'm Ronnie Jones.
I'm the senior manager for the system of support for the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
And what we want to do today with our presentation is to communicate to you the different layers of the system of support.
And so today you're going to hear from the Kern County Superintendent of Schools Office, who has been selected as a geographic lead for their area.
And you're going to hear also from one of their partners, the Selpa System Improvement Leads, who they're working with around their area of focus.
And so during the presentation, you might hear about the initiatives that are represented on the graphic in front of you, which makes it seem like it's pretty small and it's pretty limited in its scope.
But what we want to do is we actually want you to think about the system that we're talking about more in the scope that you see on this graphic.
Not only will you hear about the work that Kern County is doing with its partner county offices, but please remember that each of those partner county offices are connected to all of the LEAs within their counties.
So those are connections that you can make sure that you're envisioning as Kern is presenting about their work.
Also know that
that there are going to be connections that they may not be able to talk about just given the limited time of their presentation today.
So Kern County not only is working with the self-assisted improvement leads, but they're also partnering with the multi-tiered systems of supports, MTSS, who are in turn connected with LEAs across the state.
Other connections that you may not hear about today, or you may only hear about briefly, is the connection through some of their other county offices.
You can see on this graphic that L.A.
County Office of Ed is working in partnership with the Community Engagement Initiative, which has some peer learning and leading networks, and I believe Ventura County is also working with them.
At some point, the graphic became too confusing if we tried to put all the connections on there.
And then you'll also see that the geographic leads are coming together on a regular basis in order to share resources across the state and ensure that, as Stephanie said, that we have coherent and effective systems.
So one of the things that we just want to highlight is that in the past there have been questions about, well, how are all of the geographic leads and the county offices calibrating their support for districts?
And so today Kern County is going to talk about that, about how
They are sharing and improving differentiated assistance strategies across their geographic area.
But the previous graphic actually made it seem as though Kern County as a geographic lead might be a gatekeeper to some of the resources.
But we also wanted you to know that the system not only is spread out like a web, but there are also layers within the system so that different counties are connecting with the leads maybe on their own or with other county offices to partner.
Today, Kern County is going to talk a little bit about in depth that partnership with the system improvement lead, but also about
how their partner counties are connecting with one another through differentiated assistance case studies.
So, again, today, during the presentation, it may sound, when Kern's doing their presentation, as though it's a simple connection of one county talking to another, but know that these complex webs of relationships are developing within the system of support, and at any time, if you have questions after the presentation, we'd be happy to answer more in depth about some of these things.
So today, to get us started with our presentation, we're going to ask Kristen Wright, the Director of Special Education, to come up and give us a little bit of context around students with disabilities in the state of California.
So Ronnie will be familiar with this conversation that we've had at the collaborative, but if I go back to those two charts, there's sort of two things that strike me.
One is that the LEA that is seeking differentiated assistance should be at the core.
If I'm unicorn school district,
And I say, I have a lot of trouble in reading with my third grade African American students.
Who do I turn to?
I feel like all of our conversations are coming from the top down.
And we're doing a lot to try to figure this out.
And you know me, all of these acronyms, I'm thinking about people who are watching this on the screen going, what on earth are they talking about?
And DA case studies sounds like a criminal activity to me.
I know for sure we don't intend it to be.
So anyway, I'm struggling a bit here with the communication and I'm struggling with the lens through which we're viewing this.
I want our lens to be, how do we help a teacher in a classroom improve the outcomes for those students?
And this, I get lost in this.
And as you know, I'm fairly well informed about it.
So just a suggestion about how going forward we communicate with it.
And I don't wanna like pull a fast one on Mary and Kern County and go, okay, I want you to like completely redo your presentation.
But I do want us all to think about that as we move forward and we continue to talk about this.
Thank you.
So I think Kern is prepared to talk about their connections with LEAs and that work that they're doing.
And then throughout the presentation, too, we also are going to hear from Ed Manansala, and he has brought a district superintendent with him to talk about how they're receiving services within their district.
Thank you.
And I can assure you that we're going to get a little bit in the weeds.
We were worried maybe a little too much in the weeds, but it sounds like you want to hear some weeds around how this is going to connect actually to helping our districts.
And I feel a personal sense of gratitude in a way that we are
being incredibly responsive.
When the flashlight was shined from the dashboard the last few years, the state has pivoted and basically gathered together to surround how we assist our districts in serving our students with disabilities.
And I just wanted to make sure to bring my favorite slide in the whole wide world, which is really talking about that overlap between the student groups.
And I think what you'll see today is that the collective of individuals coming together
are coming together around whole children.
The fact that we have children who are students of color, who are students who are English learners, who are many other things besides students with disabilities.
And certainly at the statewide level, we're trying, and why this is so critical is we're really trying to model at the state level that we are all in this together for all students.
And personally, you know,
having the special ed division under my purview, we feel like part of a larger system now.
Whereas before it was like something was going on with special ed, special ed needs to fix it.
And so I hope that that's what you'll take from today is that there is truly a statewide effort to encircle all students in all schools, in all districts to help make this happen.
And the capacity building that it takes to do that
has been a challenge and an opportunity and so I feel like the fact that district superintendents are saying the words performance indicator review and they know those are about the federal indicators for students with disabilities and all those things, it's a different day than we were talking about a few years ago.
So, just reminding us that in California, our students with disabilities represent about 11.6% of the student population, but if you look at the other student groups, they represent more of a piece of that pie, which makes it even more important that we're working across titles.
And I'll just highlight a second about our work around English learners.
that over the last year we've developed an English learner practitioners guide for English learners with disabilities and have had the opportunity to go across the state and working with a lot of districts and county offices around pushing that out for folks to gather around.
As you know, it's really great to have something to work around instead of just an idea and have some real solutions to provide real professional development to our teachers and our educators and giving them something to go to.
So again, and this has stayed consistent the last three years, our students with disabilities are represented, 70% of them are in one or more of the local control funding formula student groups.
And so we're really talking about the same children.
And again, I'm really excited to talk about this collaborative
Our SELPA leads are making us proud.
We, as you know, have two types of SELPA leads.
The system improvement leads, which are really working around how districts can understand their data around special education and that relationship to the larger system, as well as our content leads.
One of them is the English learner with disabilities content lead.
Another one is around disproportionality, doing some great work around
predictive analysis and helping districts before they're disproportionate see a trend that's going in a negative direction.
And so basically today they're going to talk about how we're using data to concentrate efforts, really implementing feedback loops, improving the differentiated assistance process to be more responsive, depending on what happens year to year, and partnering really across the system of support to build capacity.
And so I'm going to ask the Valley to Coast Collaborative to come up and then they'll introduce themselves.
We'll start with with Mary.
Thank you.
Thank you, board members.
We're very honored to be here today to share with you the work of the Valley to Coast Collaborative and how we are using and leveraging relationships within the statewide system of support to improve outcomes for students with disabilities.
So I want to share a little bit of information with you.
My colleagues will introduce themselves.
They are here behind me as they come up.
It's been very worthwhile to put pen to paper and really think back about the work that we've engaged in over the past 10 months that we've been part of this geo area work.
Just as a refresher, the Valley to Coast Collaborative includes Fresno Kern,
Los Angeles, San Luis Obispo, Ventura, and Santa Barbara County Offices of Education.
And as you might know, of these six County Offices of Education serving 207 districts,
with 3,244 schools over 2.1 million students.
Now 36% of those districts are in fact eligible for differentiated assistance and of those 36%, 70% of those districts are eligible based on outcomes for students with disabilities and 43% of those districts are in their second year of eligibility and when diving into
The data that is why we as a geo area decided this would be the focus of our initial work as partners So our goal today is to do three things We want to ensure that we inform the board about How we went about this process so that you can understand the continuous improvement process that was used by our geo area work group
to develop an action plan based upon how we would provide outcomes and improve outcomes for students with disabilities.
We want to talk to you a little bit about our continuous improvement process and how we are using that to build the capacity of all COEs within our geo area.
Secondly, we would like you to understand how we have engaged and leveraged partnerships across the system of support to calibrate, to coordinate, and ultimately to address our own problem of practice as geo areas.
So we are learning together and how we will continue to build those supports for the LEAs within our area.
And finally, three, we would like to inform you of our anticipated next steps.
And to give you detailed information about the continuous improvement process and how that directly impacts local education agencies, I'll turn it over to my colleague, Dr. Rob Arias.
Good morning.
So as Dr. Barlow stated, one of our outcomes for today is to understand the process that we used in our geo area in order to determine our game plan and our work together.
So in our original geo grant,
Go ahead and click to the next slide.
We determined that we weren't going to actually create a plan independently in Kern County, that instead we were going to work as a team, as a geo lead in order to determine what our work would look like and ultimately what an action plan would look like.
In addition, we determined that we would use Kern County's continuous improvement process, which we had great success with, with school districts in our county that were eligible for differentiated assistance, as well as county offices in our geo area that were eligible for differentiated assistance, that we would use that continuous improvement process in order to determine what our action plan might look like.
So the slide that you see here on the screen is a depiction of that process.
So what I'd like to do is just take you through each of those steps to describe how we go about actually organizing our work.
So as you can see, our process begins with data inquiry.
If you don't know where you are, you're not going to know where you're going.
So we spend time with our geo area leads, or excuse me, geo area partners, understanding what data we're going to actually look at.
process data, we look at outcome data, and we look at perception data, and we first determine what data do we need to understand, what data do we need to collect, what data do we need to analyze in order to understand the current health, the status of our geographic area.
So our skilled facilitators take us through a process of understanding what that looks like.
We go through an analysis of our data in order to determine what the current status of our area is.
Specifically, we looked at the California dashboard, for example.
We looked at student outcome data.
We looked at indicators.
We looked at LEA type and size.
We looked, of course, at the DA status across our geo area of our individual county offices.
And we also studied the level one services and level two services that are currently being provided by our county offices in our geo area.
An important step here or point to make is that data inquiry is not a one and done.
Data inquiry in our process all it's depicted here is you start there and you end there.
That's really not what happens.
We come back to data on a regular basis as we learn more about what it is we don't know or perhaps something that we need to study or understand more clearly.
So as a result, I'd like you to, if you could, imagine that data inquiry is something that we revisit on a regular basis, depending on what our learning needs to be.
So data inquiry sets the stage.
It grounds us on basically our current status.
The next step in our process is the identification of a problem of practice.
Dr. Einstein once said if I had an hour to solve a problem, I'd spend 55 minutes actually trying to understand what the problem is and five minutes developing a solution for that problem.
So this is one of the basic tenets of our work.
Traditionally, I think we're all probably guilty of it.
I was a superintendent and I was guilty of it as well at certain times in my tenure and that I see a problem or we collectively see a problem and we go right to solutions.
We start defining what it is that we're going to do about that.
Our process slows down that natural adult tendency to go to solutions and instead really take the time, thoughtful time necessary in order to identify what are we actually trying to solve.
And this is the process that we went through to design the work of our geo area.
The next is root cause analysis.
This is another important tenet of continuous improvement in general.
Root cause analysis is what is creating the problem.
What's causing the problem to occur or what's contributing to the problem.
An important point here is that we actually create an action plan ultimately around those root causes and that really
attacking the problem of practice directly.
We're tracking it indirectly by addressing those root causes.
An important distinction, something again that traditionally that we don't do.
Generally, we're working on a problem, we see the problem, let's find solutions and solve the problem.
Instead, what we're trying to do is exterminate or alleviate those root causes that we identify.
We go through a process of prioritizing what those root causes might be.
So you can imagine that if you have a specific problem of practice,
that there are many things contributing to that particular problem.
We go through a, you probably have heard of the five whys, or you've heard of a fishbone activity in order to drill down into what specifically the causes might be.
Important piece here is that we try to look in the mirror, not out the window.
We're trying to identify what it is that the adults in the organizations are doing to contribute to the problem.
This is not about blaming parents or blaming students in this process.
This is really about what the adults are doing.
The next step in the process is a theory of action.
I'm sure you've heard of that before.
It's borrowed from the scientific methodology.
If we do this and if we do that, then this.
So we take those prioritized root causes and we convert them into a theory of action.
That theory of action is basically putting a stake in the ground stating this is what we're going to work on.
If we do this and if we do that, then this will occur.
We will extinguish or eliminate the problem practice.
It's an important step.
We always get distracted, I think, by any number of priorities that are around us.
It's important to identify what it is we say we're going to do.
It sets the stage for measurement and for monitoring as well.
It prevents us from chasing rabbits, to be perfectly honest.
It focuses on specific work that we're intended to do.
So it's a very important step, the theory of action.
I'm going to be sharing with you our theory of action to date after we finish with these slides.
So once we've identified our theory of action, we identify basically initiatives and actions.
So what initiatives would we create, would we use in order to address each of those if statements?
So each of our if statements has an action plan around it.
So if we do x, well, we develop an action plan around that specific if statement.
The action plan is short-term and long-term.
It's an important piece here in that we create short-term goals and long-term outcomes as well during the action planning process.
Traditional action planning who's doing what when are they doing it?
That's all part of that as well But we extend that may be creating outcomes that we're actually trying to address When we're going to monitor and how we're going to monitor them another piece I think that we found through our studies and our work with school districts and other county offices is that We really don't do a good enough job.
Frankly monitoring our own work.
I think we're all probably have been a part of creating an action plan
Either putting it on the shelf or other things take on more priority than our initial action plan.
So we've embedded some very deliberate steps to monitor our work after creation of an action plan and to analyze where we are in that regard.
I didn't share this, and Dr. Gilbert, after my piece of this presentation, is going to discuss this, but we have a number of feedback loops throughout our process.
So in our traditional process that we would use for the school district, we would engage stakeholders, parents, board members, teachers, classified employees, administrators in this process and put a team together.
And that team would identify the problem of practice, the root causes, theory of action, ultimately an action plan.
Well, we do that in cohorts, so we have other teams that are similar come together and provide feedback on their work along the way.
This geo area is a little bit different than that.
We don't have a school district.
This is a broad geo area, so we engaged the
players, the actors, the lead agencies, the content experts of the system of support in order to provide that feedback.
What do you think of our problem of practice?
Do you think that we have identified the right problem of practice?
Have we been thoughtful?
Have we been careful?
Have we identified the right root causes?
By doing it in that manner, you get a neutral voice, a neutral body that's able to point out, frankly, some areas that perhaps are blind spots for us, right?
And we encourage that feedback on a regular basis.
So Dr. Gilbert's going to speak to how we've leveraged those partnerships going forward.
She's going to speak to specifically what those partnerships look like as we develop our action plan.
And then lastly, I'd like to describe some of the products that we've created as a result of this process that we've used.
So our problem of practice is to improve outcomes for students with disabilities.
We as CSAs need to prioritize building effective partnerships, aligning internal systems, and continuing to develop our expertise to increase the capacity of LEAs.
So we came together.
with all of our county offices across our geo area, and we asked ourselves the question, what is our common problem of practice?
And when you start this process, you have to be authentic.
You can't artificially embed what you believe, current county believes, our problem of practice is.
You have to let the process take you where it's going.
And our process went to students with disabilities.
It was an area that we all collectively did not have an answer to.
It was a group that we needed to address, and we all shared the same problem.
So the first if statement.
So this is our if statement.
This is our theory of action.
So if we continue to prioritize, include, and affirm the needs of students with disabilities in our work, and if we continue to develop expertise in providing systemic support to LEAs for students with disabilities, and if we coordinate and calibrate within and among COE departments, SELPAs, and other organizations in the California Statewide System of Support,
And if we continue to develop consistent and trusting relationships among COEs, LEAs, and SELPAs.
Then we will increase the capacity of LEAs to improve outcomes for students with disabilities.
So that's the work that we've done to date.
We have a meeting actually Friday to continue this particular work to look at the specific initiatives as well as the actions around this work.
We'd love to share that with you going forward.
So at this time I'd like to turn it over to Dr. Gilbert to describe the partnerships that we've engaged in.
Thank you.
Good morning.
So as Dr. Arias shared with you a little bit about that process, I'm hoping that you are seeing the importance of relationships within that work.
In order to get to those really honest, transparent conversations,
In order to be able to look in the mirror and be honest about what gaps we're seeing and what we need to do better ourselves and that those relationships are really a foundational part of that work and so just please know that as we initiated our geographic area efforts
And we truly took a collaborative approach.
We recognize the fact that ourselves as well as all of the other five county offices really bring a lot of expertise, different perspectives into the work.
And so we've really tried to recognize that and build from that.
So, as you're very familiar with this graphic, but we wanted to just again recognize that this system has been built out and we are very excited to be a part of this system and have already started benefiting from contacting the other resources within.
So you're very familiar with this slide as well.
This just identifies the current lead agencies across the state.
And so we thought we'd bring this up and kind of share with you how we have connected with and engaged with each of the entities that we have thus far.
So, the first is the state agencies.
We have really appreciated CDE and CCE's outreach, the opportunity for them to bring together all leads and really discuss what the system is looking like and how we can come together to build it out to be the most impactful in really changing student outcomes across the state.
So both CDE and CC have been great partners.
And in fact, we have invited CDE and CCA staff members to come and be a part of our geographic area meetings.
Just most recently, Ronnie Jones and Josh Strong came to present to our geographic area information specifically about current events on the statewide system of support, as well as helping us to connect some of the work around differentiated assistance and LCAP and so on.
The SELPA Systems Improvement Lead Agencies, this has been alluded to, as a geographic area, as we really studied our data, it just became glaringly obvious that our students with disabilities needed some additional support and assistance.
And again, by looking in the mirror, we recognized as COEs, we had some growing to do as well, right?
That we needed to build our expertise there.
So we reached out to the SIL leads,
immediately became involved in their work.
They invited us to have conversations with them about a data tool that they were building out, and they got our perspective.
And then we invited them to come to our geographic area meeting to help us understand that special education world.
You'll see as they come up, and you mentioned this, Sue, a whole new world of acronyms, right?
And so as geographic leads, we really started trying to invest in understanding that current reality that our districts are dealing with, right?
So a lot of our districts are not only identified for differentiated assistance, they're also identified under the quality assurance process.
And so trying to bridge that gap for our districts and really having that mindset of how can we as county office help them navigate that and streamline our efforts to make sure that we are supporting them in the most meaningful ways.
And you'll hear a little bit more about some of the specific work that we've been doing together from Jackie Williams after I present.
Next was the SELPA content lead agencies.
Ms.
Wright mentioned these.
So we have been engaging with these agencies, again, to try to start developing relationships with them because we're not quite sure where our work is going to lead and where we want to necessarily focus.
But we have asked them to come and throughout our process, as we identified our problem of practice, as we identified our root causes, and then our theory of action, we have actually asked them to come in and we've explained the process, we've explained where we were landing, and asked them to give us very specific feedback on things that they are seeing as gaps, things that they agree with, things that they disagree with.
And so we're asking that expertise to come into our process so that we can end up with a better product.
In addition, we have connected with Dr. Christine Olmsted, the Assistant Superintendent of Orange County Office of Ed.
And as we have started to narrow our focus around our theory of action, it became obvious that the MTSS initiative is one that we want to make sure we're well grounded in, assuming that that will ultimately become part of our actions as we move forward.
So we're very excited to have her.
She's actually coming to our geographic area meeting this Friday.
And then finally, geographic lead agencies.
From the very beginning, we were excited to connect with our other geographic lead agencies to understand how they were approaching this work and learn from them.
Again, thank you to CDE and CCE for creating the meetings for us to be able to connect and discuss that.
In addition to the meetings that the state agencies have put together, as geographic lead agencies, we've also been creating our own meetings.
And I'm very excited about the progress that we're making there.
And that if you think about that, our California state is so diverse, right?
And these geographic areas all represent different sections and different perspectives.
But we have come together and identified our collective goals and how we are defining our roles as geographic leads and what work we want to do together within the statewide systems support.
and then what work we're going to do individually to support this system.
So we have really appreciated the partnerships with our other GEO lead agencies, and they have also been providing feedback to us specifically at every step of our process.
So again, we want to kind of disrupt our group think, have other people come in, we have to explain our process to them, then they give us the feedback and the questions that we need to refine and improve that.
And now I would like to ask Jackie Williams to come up.
She will be explaining to you the work of the SIL, but also how specifically we have partnered around our focus on students with disabilities.
Good morning, everybody.
Thank you so much for allowing me to share a little bit about the work that we've been doing.
So I am Jackie Williams, as Lisa stated, and I'm the assistant superintendent of the West San Gabriel Valley SELPA, located right in that little town of LA County.
So there's about, I think we have 25 SELPAs in the LA County area, one of which is myself.
So I wanted to tell you how we grounded our work.
So when we were thinking about applying for the grant, we really went back to this one system theory.
So the system improvement leads grounded their work in the 2015 special education task force report.
And we focused on the belief that all children are considered general education students first.
And all educators have a collective responsibility to see that all children receive the education and support they need to maximize their development and their potential in one system.
So, I'd like to introduce you to my colleagues, so myself, and then there's Leah Davis, and she is the executive director of the Riverside County Office of Education SELPA and Tamara Clay, who is with Eldorado County SELPA.
This is our SELPA System Improvement Lead Theory of Action.
We believe that if we build partnerships with SELPAs, LEAs, County Offices of Education, System of Support Lead Agencies, CDE, and CCEE, and build capacity of SELPAs and LEAs in the areas of data governance and use, continuous improvement, and accesses to resources to support and implement high leverage practices and evidence-based practices,
that then students with disabilities will have access to a cohesive and effective school system intentionally designed to provide the necessary supports and interventions for educational and post-secondary success.
So now I want to tell you about our exciting work with the Kern County GEO Lead Agencies.
We're incredibly grateful that Kern reached out to us and asked us to be a partner.
As we are into this work, only about seven, eight, or eight months, knocking on the doors of the geographic areas and saying, hey, let us in, let us in, we want to collaborate.
Everybody has so much going on.
And Lisa approached me at a CISC conference that we had done a brief little presentation.
and ask us to come out and work with them.
So what's resulted from our collaboration is that we actually took the West San Gabriel Valley SELPA team, the SEAL team out there, four of us, to a current geographic lead area meeting.
And we presented a three hour workshop for them.
And we went all the way down into the basics of special education.
Okay, so the workshop structure, a lot of information here, and I'm going to focus on a couple of areas, primarily the APR report.
The other things are things that we talked about during our three hours, and what we did.
So I want to give a definition of the annual performance report, in case anybody in the audience is not familiar with that acronym, because I know in special ed, I could acronym my way through an hour of speech, I tell you.
It would be very easy.
There's pages.
So, the Individuals with Disabilities Act, the IDEA, requires that each state to develop a state performance plan annual performance report that evaluates the state's efforts to implement the requirements and purpose of the IDEA and describes how the state will improve its implementation.
The APR
report for each district includes data on 14 indicators and we're going to talk about one of those specifically today.
The results of these indicators are used to determine corrective actions required by the districts.
Our work with Kern resulted in a deeper dive into the State Performance Plan Indicator 5.
And Indicator 5 consists of three different, it has an A, B, and C. We're going to talk today about what we're looking at on Indicator 5.
And that is least restrictive environment.
So one of the tools that we felt that we needed to show this large group of individuals from the County Offices of Ed at our GEO lead meeting was this wonderful tool that was developed through the SIL grant.
And it's a resource for school leaders and staff to gain a deeper understanding of the California State Performance Plan, the SPP indicators.
I'll be referring to those as the SPPIs in future slides.
Let me show you the work that was done here.
Eldorado County Office of Ed and their director, Tamara Clay, took the lead on this project for the SIL team.
And this is a very brief overview of this unbelievable dynamic document that is available on our website.
And dynamic, I say, because you'll see in here right now, we refer to casemists.
We don't have casemists any longer where it's all cow pads and casemists has sailed off into the sunset.
So this particular section, these are handouts that are like grab-and-goes that you can print out to give to individuals who have come to your trainings.
So this section of the SPPA guide
It digs down deeper into the components of the 14 indicators, which include the data source, how the data source was calculated, how it was identified, the calculation methodologies, and where did that data come from.
And when we were working with Curran, we went all the way down to where that data comes from, which is our students' IEPs.
If you mark this box, then that data is going to go here.
If this is the least restrictive environment and they're in the environment more than 80% of the time, well, that's one of our indicators.
So we went down and we reviewed that IEP process with them to show them where this data was coming from.
What we found very well received is the connections that we make at the bottom.
If you see indicator 5 making connections.
So what that does
is it's going to show how that particular indicator is related to the dashboard, the LCAP priorities, and also the quality assurance process that we do in special education.
So this resource is available, by the way, on our website, which I'll show you towards the end of the slide, you'll be able to access it.
So the SIL team is currently in the process of launching our improvement data center.
And this center, this site will house all of our data tools and resources and will be couched in our SIL landing page on our website.
So this will be one of the tools accessible.
So what we're striving for is to help create a culture where data is more easily accessible,
educators as they plan for their students specifically and ultimately through the West San Gabriel Valley side of the grant.
We're looking at the development of a data governance toolkit which Riverside SELPA has been working on with us, a guidance to the SPPI indicators, and a common set of data tools.
Make sure we push the right button.
That's the most challenging, just making sure I push the right button.
All right.
So this is a snapshot of one of the pages in our Improvement Data Center.
And what you can see here are the six little icons at the bottom.
So when the user goes to this page, you can see the Data Quality Toolkit, which is being worked on by Riverside, Root Cause Analysis Tools, which is future, the SPP
I am monitoring, that's what we're working on now, improvement monitoring, and towards the end cycle of our grant, we'll be working on some predictive analysis and other things that we come up with.
So right now,
What we are focusing on again is the SPPI indicator for indicator 5 and the least restrictive environment.
I want to show you an example of what we have been doing.
This is just showing what I just stated.
So the state of California has the annual performance report, and I explained what that is earlier in the presentation.
Has anybody ever searched for an annual performance report on CDE's website?
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
So we have a special present for you today.
So what we did is
Oh, this is a promise?
We've already kept the promise.
So we just haven't made it public yet.
So through our work with Kern, we learned that, of course, least restrictive environment, the more time our students spend in the general education classroom, the better the outcomes are for those students.
And we know this.
So we were focusing on that.
So what we did with the data that you find on CDE's website is we worked with CDE to get that data in an Excel format.
So we have a data sharing agreement with myself and what we did is we worked with that and we
created the entire state's APR reports in searchable PDF format.
So you no longer have to, and this will be ongoing, we'll get caught up, but right now, this is a searchable tool, you can go in and, here it is, you can select your year, you can select your county office of ed, your LEA, or your LEA,
or your SELPA, and you can pull up those districts that you want to see their APR reports.
So it's dynamic, it's ongoing, we're going to be building up and getting more current.
We have three years on there now, and this will help us monitor that data much more effectively.
So I skipped an entire thing.
And right now we have three years of that data on there.
This is our most exciting work that we're currently very close to rolling out.
And this one, again, we're looking at indicator five.
And we beta tested this with the current county geoleads at our workshop.
We actually ran the reports using this tool and took that to each of the county offices of ed that attended.
And we sat down and we workshopped around that and asked them to identify
where they're seeing some challenges and comparing them with each other.
So it was exciting work.
So with this report, the users are going to be able to graph their respective indicator data.
And we've used, again, Indicator 5 for this.
And this tool is going to be searchable by county offices of ed.
SELPAs, geo areas, so Kern could search their entire geo area, and LEAs, and it will also allow them to create multi-years graphs, and we'll do it one indicator at a time and roll that out as we develop them.
So this is our most exciting tool.
You can see here, we have the total number of students receiving services, our total number in the 80%.
The percentage, our target, and this particular pretend agency actually met all the targets.
If a district or SELPA didn't meet their targets, it would have a red X.
And so we would be able to graph that and compare to other SELPAs, like SELPAs, like districts.
And this one, we're just waiting on figuring out how our permission levels are going to work.
And eventually, when we figure out the logistics and the legal things that we need to figure out, districts will be able to upload their CALPADS data.
into our system and run data, more current data on their students in their districts.
So we're looking forward to being able to do that.
And lastly, this is our absolutely magnificent, beautiful landing page for our website and our web address is on there.
And I thank you so much for your time and thank you for your dedication to the System Improvement Leads.
We and our students are grateful.
Thank you so much.
Hopefully we have accomplished our first two bullets in terms of outcomes that you understand now a little bit more about the continuous improvement process that we have been utilizing and also how we have engaged with our partners across the statewide system of support.
Now we are going to move on to share with you our anticipated next steps.
And we're bringing the process map back up because we've explained to you how we have taken those first four steps.
And now we're at that final step of identifying our initiatives and really putting pen to paper to identify the actions that we will both collectively as a geographic area take to reach our goals and address that problem of practice, as well as each county office of education individually
creating plans on how they will contribute to addressing that problem of practice because we definitely want to recognize the local contexts in which we are all working.
In addition to going through this continuous improvement process with our geographic area, we've also simultaneously been doing some of the work that is called out in statute as geographic areas that we need to do.
And so I'm going to share with you a little bit about that.
But I think it was mentioned earlier in the presentation
that we as a group have really discussed and struggled with how to best share our work around differentiated assistance, right?
So one of our jobs is to really make sure that we're coming together to coordinate and calibrate that assistance that's being provided to school districts.
And so we have done, we've employed a number of strategies to do that.
We've been sharing practices and doing activities around that.
But the group decided that they really thought a case study format would be really valuable so that we could go a little deeper into our journeys with specific districts and what challenges we faced, what successes we've had, and what we can learn from each of those case studies.
And so at our last geographic area meeting, three of our county offices presented those case studies, and then on this next Friday, the remaining three will be sharing those case studies.
Just as a specific example, Sue, specifically to speak to your point about how are we getting this work down to the district and classroom level, we shared our case study last meeting, and we're able to share specifically about our work with our largest school district,
who realized in going through our process that there was some work to do around coherence.
They had a large number of school sites that were all kind of doing their own thing.
And so in coming together in our process, it really helped them to bring that diverse team together to get perspective from across the district.
And they created an action plan specifically on how they were going to improve all of the interventions that were being provided to their students.
And so they address social-emotional learning.
They address their academic interventions.
They are implementing PBIS and restorative justice types of programs across their district.
And they have also began the restructure around becoming more inclusive.
We had staff actually attend a beginning of the year meeting in which they informed all, I believe, 23 of their principals
about how they were going to be moving into a push-in model for their students with disabilities and how that represented a significant mindset shift as well as resource shifts that were going across the district.
So we are seeing concrete examples of this process leading to changes occurring that will ultimately benefit our students very specifically.
So the other piece that we've been trying to work simultaneously on is our asset mapping.
So one of the pieces of language on statute say that we want to identify resources across our geographic area and identify how we might share those.
So we have been working with WestEd and identified those assets across our geographic area.
So each county office has been in the process of doing that.
And with a lot of discussion around what is an asset, right?
And then also how might we actually share these assets once we've identified them.
So we came up with an organization for our asset map, and we're really close to being completed.
But what we did is we organized the asset map to identify assets for each county office and where they would reside in alignment with the California School Dashboard.
What we would anticipate is a county office or a school district wanting to see specific resources around a specific problem that they're facing.
So for an example,
If a district was really wanting to address chronic absenteeism and see what assets and resources exist around that particular issue, in our asset map, they would go to academic engagement, which aligns with the category that the school dashboard uses, and then drill down into chronic absenteeism and be able to see by county office what assets and resources are available to address that specific issue.
In addition to those three categories that align with the California School Dashboard, academic performance, academic engagement, and conditions and climate, we added two.
We added governance because we saw that there was a lot of work to be done and being done in our county offices around leadership.
Also about specific processes.
And then in addition, we thought it was important to include in our assets, the assets and resources that our SELPAs bring to the table, especially with our problem of practice.
So we added a community section to address that.
You'll see we also within our assets recognize the need to work on and encourage parent and family engagement.
And so you'll see that is an area and we will be identifying assets and resources specific to that under conditions and climate.
Okay.
And then the next conversation was about how we would share.
So once we've identified the assets, how will we determine how we might access them and share them with one another?
So we created four different categories, and each county office is identifying how they might share that asset or resource.
The first is just share.
So they've put together documentation so that it's just something we could pick up on a website,
or a packet of information that we can take and use immediately so that we can employ that asset.
The next offer is that if they can share it through shadowing.
So will we be able to invite other COEs to come in and observe the process or the asset and be able to discuss that with them so we can learn from them.
Also service, there are times when we may not be able to share our shadow, but for a fee for service cost recovery, we might be able to go to another county office and share the resource that way.
And finally, we're asking as much as possible if they have a trainer of trainers opportunity so that if that asset can be shared through a trainer of trainers program, then we might be able to then try to replicate that work within our own county offices.
And then finally, as we were preparing for this presentation, which we are very grateful for the opportunity to come and share with all of you, we thought it was really important that you not just hear our voices, because we have approached this work very genuinely and authentically, recognizing that what all of our county offices bring to the table.
And so we just created a very brief video so that you could hear specifically from the other county offices about our process and what they've gotten out of it.
See if I can get this going.
Deep work is happening.
Schools and districts and counties are engaging in it.
We're trying to do something as a state that hasn't been attempted before.
We are operationalizing the California way.
We're turning it into actual work that happens in schools, classrooms, and school districts.
And the support of each other make it possible.
We have this shared experience of learning with a real problem that we want real answers to.
What has been valuable for us is really just learning what other county offices do, actually getting to know the other people in the other context, our counterparts in the other county offices.
And so we have an opportunity to learn from each other and build on each other's strengths.
We have our continuous improvement process, which we ask them to participate in.
Continuous Improvement, it's created a unifying philosophy for how we will approach complex problems and I don't think that as a county office or as a state we've had that kind of unifying message before.
Using the tools in it to understand the root causes, really being able to understand at a deep level what the data means.
You feel grounded in what the work means and what it can do for you as you move forward.
This year, out of the 35 of our districts that are eligible for differentiated assistance, I believe 23 of them had students with disabilities as one of their qualifying student groups.
And I think it's been clear for years, even prior to the dashboard and prior to the system of support, that we need to do better for our students with disabilities.
We're finally going to have really transparent, deep conversations about how we are serving our students and what service means.
Nice.
The first letter is H. We'll see some really deep systemic changes that will create systems in which our kids can be more successful.
So we really strive to be collaborative thinking partners.
That is our goal.
What I would hope to see five years down the road for this collaborative is that we have a very streamlined
network and system of sharing resources and support so that we're a model of how not to do this alone.
Our GEO lead group is not one fixed group of people.
We're iterative, just like the work that we do, and I think that that's an important consideration that people who enter in bring in their expertise and also benefit from the expertise of the group.
So that in five years from now, it's a seamless process of networking, sharing resources, learning, so that no matter who enters the county office, the school district, you're plugged into a system of support.
So to close this presentation, you have a graphic before you that shows adults in the system, children in the classroom with the teacher, and ultimately children succeeding.
And the graphic is because we realize this work is really all about the students.
And we know that ultimately it's about providing the opportunities for the teachers to create that magic and that relationship with the students in their classrooms.
So we are all in, we are committed to this.
We're talking about disrupting the predictability of student outcomes.
We genuinely believe that factors that are outside of students' controls, whether it is income or the zip code in which they reside,
their ethnicity, gender, language, or their learning ability.
It should never predict a student's outcome.
And to do this work, we must work through adults.
We need to work through changing mindsets and behaviors to ultimately see changes in the classroom.
It's about scalability.
So as GEO leads, we are creating coherent systems of support across our county partners to strengthen our own practice, to better then support school district leaders,
who in turn will support the school leaders that they lead, then they will be able to equip the teachers in the classroom with the best practices to improve student teaching and learning, instruction and learning, so that ultimately we will be able to see improved student outcomes.
Now we're scaling this across 2.1 million students, 3200 schools.
It's going to take time.
We appreciate your patience.
I am not patient.
I want to see numbers.
I want to see action.
I want to see results.
And I'm not alone, I don't think any of us are alone in that.
But we are asking for your continued support, we're asking for your guidance, and we're asking for your support of continuing in this effort, because we do believe it's the right work.
Thank you for your time today, and we're available for any questions you may have.
Dr. Brother and your team, thank you so much for really helping
We're going to stop for a 2nd here board members because we want to kind of ask you some questions and give us a chance before we go to document a solid in the next step.
So, just helping us understand how the geo leads and all the everything in the, in the graphs that you've been sharing and how complicated is just to reinforce your support for building capacity and articulating across.
all the different players to build that, and we realize how complex, how big our state is, but even in your geographic area and the counties you have.
So I have a question that builds on Member Burr, and I'll ask her to follow since we're the liaisons for accountability, and we'll ask each board member if you have one question to clarify before we move on.
But you talked about building coherent support, which we know there's a lot of stuff going on out there, and it hits districts and principals.
And I appreciate Rob talking about what you're, you've tried to look at what level one is for everyone.
What are the supports for every, what does everybody get?
What do you do for tier level two?
And what are we doing for targeted for three?
And so I'm interested in sort of how that impacts a district that's probably got capacities, probably got a teacher shortage, there may be some literacy issues in mathematics because they got identified for support.
Besides just students with disabilities, as Kristen was saying, they're overlapping the group.
How do you build a coherent focus?
Do you serve as a broker for the LEAs to help them guide what research?
There's so much stuff out there.
How do they get a focus?
to actually make some growth.
So I'm interested in sort of that tiered support and how it directly impacts the LEA based on all these different opportunities there.
So I don't know if that's, Mary, if you're the right one to, or Rob, to share that, but that would be helpful.
I'll be inviting both Rob and Lisa up here with me, but I'm gonna start with sharing this.
As the County Office of Education, our goal and all of our partner goals within the GEO area is to be a broker.
and to understand that we are not experts in every single area.
And so when meeting with the LEA that is eligible, one of the first things we do is a deep dive into what they've identified as their areas of expertise.
problems of practice, but also looking at data, because sometimes we have blind spots, right?
And so by going through that exercise and that review, we're better able to identify resources that they then need to be connected to.
We as GeoLEADS, through our asset mapping, will be also able to work through other COEs to identify those resources that may not reside in Kern, they may be in LA.
They may be in Fresno.
They may be outside of our GEO area.
And we will be brokers, if you will, or connectors to bring those resources to any LEA in the GEO area working through our partner COEs.
Anything to add to that?
Okay, well, thank you for that.
I'm going to go to Member Burr, who's also, we both, liaison to accountability and system of support, and then we'll let each board member ask a clarifying question before we move on to the second part of the, the next part of the presentation.
Sure.
So, I'd just like to express my appreciation, too.
I really, I know how hard you're working, and we heard from you early on before we got to this point, so appreciate all the work Kern is doing.
And I really appreciate your example, Lisa, because I think it's just hard to make this real for people.
And we get lots of feedback from our stakeholder folks going, what is this?
How are we helping people?
And I know it's taken a long time to sort of build up your structure so that you are able to help them.
But I do, I just sort of want to reinforce what I said, that I think going forward,
it would be helpful to approach it from the LEA lens, to say, just as you did, this LEA had an issue with coherence, that's what we worked on them with.
And to the extent with asset mapping, if I, again, wake up and I'm in Guadalupe District in Santa Barbara County, and I say, wow, I really need help with my English learners, who's out there to help me with them?
How does that get to that level, and how do they access that?
And I'll just, you know, I'll sort of address the elephant in the room a little bit, because we get this question as well all the time of, what if I don't want to work with my county office?
Are you in your asset mapping also saying, well, there are private providers, or there's WestEd, or there's whatever?
How inclusive is that?
I think it's helpful to know that as well, because I think that those are questions that continue to come up.
So I'll just leave it at that.
are at the final stages of putting the asset map together.
And I think to your question specifically, we have not yet included those other external type agencies.
However, when we created that community
Category, our thought was if there were other resources that were available and would specifically align with assisting districts or COEs around one of those indicators that we might include them in that section.
And the goal ultimately is that any LEA within our geo area would be able to look at that map, understand the resources and the assets that are available to them and reach out, preferably first through their county office of education where they have the relationship.
But as you know, as in statute.
eventually working with the GEO lead if necessary.
And our particular idea behind this, along with our colleagues, is that we're working alongside our other county office partners.
And so together we will build that bridge and we will create, you know, any type of trusting relationship that might not yet exist for whatever reason and ultimately improve that outcome so that they're more tightly working together.
Thank you for your presentation, and Dr. Barlow, I also suffer from being a little impatient with things.
And so as I was looking at this, and I understand the monumental task ahead, and I was looking at this diagram here, and the role of the GEO leads, and I thought,
How do you know that what you're doing is working?
What are the metrics that you have, and are these metrics aligned to the system of support?
Because as policymakers, we often look to the system of support and we're like, well, it's going to be taken care of there.
And so if you're worried about your English learners, well, the system of support is there, and we have tiered levels of support.
But I do wonder,
We are asking to completely transform the system that we have.
It would be great to have a sense of a realistic timeline informed by the jail leads and other partners.
Is it two years that we need just to build a system to teach people how to work beyond the silos, how to collaborate and how to communicate?
Is that what we are looking at?
After two years, we should be able to see A, B, and C.
how often are we seeing outcomes?
So I think just collaborating is a great outcome, but this system was built to address academic, community engagement, specific student populations.
And so for me, I would like to know what are the metrics that you're using when you're looking at the work you're doing, and are those aligned to the system of support?
So how are we evaluating this entire system?
And are those the same across the state?
And what is the sense of timeline that we're looking at?
Because one is building the system, transforming practices, shifting mindsets, but the other is actually how do we get to the outcomes?
A lot of community and a lot of the letters we received, they want to know what is the role of community and stakeholders?
Why are we not part of this system?
And so if you could address how that is being addressed through your GEO lead,
But again, I think this question is global.
How are we evaluating our system of support?
I'm gonna start with giving a broad piece on evaluation and Ronnie will be speaking on it because specifically that is the role CCE has taken on for us.
But what I wanna say is first, it starts with evaluating changes in practice and being able to look directly at that and then moving towards seeing actual outcomes for students.
And we're already measuring that.
Let's start.
Great.
So, CCEE has brought together resources so that we have actually hired an external evaluator to evaluate many components of the system.
So, specifically, CCEE in statute is tasked with supporting the system of support, the GEO leads, the SELPA leads, and the community engagement leads.
And so we actually will have an individual evaluation plan for the GeoLEADS, the SELPA LEADS, and the Community Engagement Initiative.
And then there will be an overall evaluation plan for the system of support.
Our vision is that this will be a five-year evaluation, but each year there will be data and a report.
In the first several years, that data will be much more formative so that it will inform the system about the changes that need to be made to make it more effective.
And then at the end of that five years, there will be a summative report.
So that's where we're going.
We've just engaged with the evaluator.
The evaluator has been attending meetings, getting to know each of the participants, doing interviews about what their work is in order to identify those common components, because each element of the system was a separate grantee, and so we're having to pull together each of their action plans in order to identify those common metrics.
So that's coming down the pipeline.
Thank you.
Member Rucker, you're next.
Well, first of all, I do want to thank you all for this presentation.
And like you, I have a great deal of impatience, even though the three legs on the stool that's supposed to define our system of support is patience, persistence and what's the third?
Humility.
So here
And in knowing that I only get one question, even though I have a whole lot.
Yeah, okay, there'll be another round.
Okay, okay, so I Like my like board member Lee cone I saw the diagram that I'm familiar with that tries to define the system of support in places leas at the center as I was listening to you speak.
I was trying to understand how all of these graphs fit into that diagram and at the same time I'm sensitive to what stakeholders are saying about
you know, we're not involved in any of these conversations.
So I'm going to tell you what I heard from your presentation and then I'll ask my question.
What I appreciated most about what I heard in your presentation was the amount of time and the deep thought you put into how to organize yourselves to do this work.
And I heard how the time you took and the thoughtfulness that you took has borne fruit for the people responsible for managing this process.
And you have created some tangible tools to help you do this work.
So here's the thing.
This is the LCAP and the accountability system that the LCAP is supposed to be helping LEAs to guide and plan what has been in place since 2013.
And the need that districts have had
to have some support and a relationship with their county offices to provide that system of support, I'm going to assert has also been a need and has been in place since 2013.
So here's my question.
I think it's fantastic that you all have done all these things to help you understand how to do your work.
For the LEAs that were left out of your asset map at being at the center of this.
For the teachers who are not even identified as stakeholders in the work that you've been doing.
For the parents and community that are also not included as stakeholders in the work that you're doing.
For the students who came here this morning and demanded to have a voice.
and participate in the work that you're doing, how did this improve anything for them right now?
That is a very fair question.
I want to share with you.
Okay.
I don't want to hear it's a fair question because usually when people start with that, it means they don't have an answer.
But let me share with you that we do work with all of those student groups, parent groups, and community members through our continuous improvement process.
When Dr. Arias talked about who we bring to the table, we intentionally bring parents.
We intentionally ask the district to go back and work directly with their school community, including more parents and students,
and teachers to ensure that we have a really diverse stakeholder voice when developing a plan with the school district.
That information has been shared with all of our other geo area counties.
So they're familiar with this process and they are also engaging in more of an authentic stakeholder process.
The second thing we're doing is we're ensuring that we're getting out to our LEAs
and giving them training on that authentic engagement and what it looks like.
So from our office, we're taking different approaches, getting along, getting involved with other county offices as well as our advocacy groups to reach traditional populations that we might not be able to bring to the table and do it in different ways.
And so we are doing that type of work to impact
the access to make sure that they feel welcome, that they understand that we do want to hear their voice and that it has impacted the LCAP.
I can give you a direct example of one thing that happened last year.
After the LCAP was created, a community group came forward in one of our largest school districts in our county and said we are very unhappy with this particular LCAP because it changed something.
It's already been approved, but it changed something that we believe should be promised and should be continued.
That advocacy group met with the superintendent, met with his cabinet, met with the board, and we facilitated discussions so that they could better understand, both sides, what the concerns were.
At the end of that, there was a compromise that was reached.
So we were helping to broker that conversation.
And so that's part of our work.
It's not easy, but that's part of our work to ensure that all voices are heard as we conduct this effort.
Now, I will say that has it changed outcomes for students?
We're kind of excited.
We're seeing that we're actually outpacing the state of California in growth.
Let me tell you, we have a long way to go.
We have an enormous gap in Kern.
I am acknowledging that.
But we are outpacing the state of California, and I'm speaking specifically as Kern, not as a GEO lead right now.
But I'm telling you that I believe this work is showing promise.
And it's making outcomes, or it's creating outcomes for students.
in Kern County.
Thank you very much for that explanation.
Let me say in all the slides that you use to develop the depth of this explanation about what you all were doing, none of that's apparent in this presentation and you need to make that more apparent because if it's not visible in what you're presenting, for me it doesn't exist.
Thank you.
So we're just going around once and then we're gonna, we'll let the Eldorado county come forward, but just because it's a long presentation, we want to give everyone a chance to clarify.
So I'm going to start on this.
It's okay, but I just want to make sure if there's a question or clarifying comment that you want to make.
Not a clarifying comment, just a question about professional learning and how all this work will help teachers and students in the classroom which is really the heart of her question in my opinion, what I heard of it.
So I did hear some elaboration on that and I don't know if in the next presentation there will be more attention paid.
But I was looking on the website and there are a lot of wonderful resources but I did see professional learning kind of buried and I had to search.
And to me that's so important about how that's going to change teaching and learning in our schools.
When you mentioned you looked at our website, are you talking about our geographic area website?
Okay.
So professional learning is absolutely in our mind that's the build capacity piece of our responsibility.
And so currently we've been providing professional learning as Jackie mentioned to our within our geographic area.
But we anticipate having specific actions in our action plan on how we will expand that to the district and teacher level.
So we are first having to make sure that we have
We've all created a foundation of knowledge within our planning group, if you will, and then we will start identifying the specific actions that we will take.
I am certain there will be a large professional learning emphasis on that, but we just haven't put the pen to paper on exactly our actions yet because we're trying to agree on what we will collectively do as well as what each individual COE will do.
But as an example for one COE, we looked at all of our outcomes and disaggregated data across the entire county and identified areas that we saw commonalities and all of our professional learning was reorganized around those priority areas.
So this year, our calendar is much more robust and intentional.
And if I may, when you mentioned the system leads website and our professional learning, we have offered
Many, many professional learning opportunities throughout the state are including students with disabilities in the accountability system.
We registered over 700 people for that and we continue to present that.
We've also done UDL learnings that are at capacity.
So I'm not sure why it wasn't available today.
We just launched it last week.
But those resources are on our website and eventually we'll host all of the professional learning opportunities
for our content leads also.
So we have done that.
We have Dr. Anthony Mohammed coming out with over 100 people attending that.
And again, so we've done a lot of work around that in the first seven, eight months.
And I apologize that you weren't able to find that.
Oh, did you?
A buried?
Well, that's great feedback, because I absolutely, we want to know that, because our goal, of course, is to make everything easily accessible.
Thank you for that feedback.
So again, we're going to move around quickly.
If you don't have a question, that's fine, or clarifying, because we do it the rest of the presentation.
Brenna?
Hello, is it working?
Okay, so I just, I want a little bit of clarification on the way that these geographic leads share best practices.
And I was a little bit worried about the stakeholder aspect of it.
And so say even if your geographic lead does do that and is involved in stakeholders, what about the other ones?
If you're the prime example of a geographic lead that's already doing what should be done, what about those who aren't?
I really noticed this looking at some of the other geographic leads, and I can never tell if it's because I'm a student, or if it's really not saying anything, but when looking at it, sometimes it says, you have the classic sentence of looking into, moving forward, and addressing certain capacity, and can I not understand it, or is it actually not saying anything?
So, I just kind of wonder,
Is there a way to really amplify sharing best practices or just making sure that these geographic leads are actually being used for the best way possible?
And then having, like you said, a way for students and for communities to actually see that the work is doing something.
Because when we read sentences like that, it's not really promising for community members.
Thank you for your feedback.
I think that really making it concrete is important and actually showing outcome data and showing the services and supports that are connected to better improve outcomes for students.
I think LEAs definitely are benefiting from this, but it's early in its infancy.
Are all GEO leads doing exactly the same work?
They all have different focus areas, but collectively,
We are coming together, working with the CCEE and the CDE as partners to learn from one another and, again, share those resources.
Sometimes I, too, get a little bit impatient with the edu-speak or when I talk about the philosophizing kind of sound of things, and I just want to be direct.
Just tell me what you're going to do and tell me how it's going to make a difference for children So I completely understand and we'll take that back in and consider that as we provide our next Presentation and any training and website access.
Thank you.
So continuing to move around remember Thank you for the presentation and I also just want to lift up that it's it's an incredibly ambitious Undertaking it's a third of the state.
I mean, it's more
which is both very exciting but also daunting to make a dent in terms of child outcomes.
The question I wanted to ask was actually about how you're approaching root cause analysis and whether you're incorporating a look at early identification and interventions.
Yes, we are, and I'm going to invite Dr. Arias up here.
Actually, we explore all root causes.
So we have actually looked at that particular piece and what impact that might be playing.
You saw in our theory of action that we had multiple if statements that we've identified.
And some of those if statements have been used, actually, combined root causes that have been identified into one particular if statement.
And that particular area that you discussed is part of a specific theory of action that we already took into account in the if statement.
So the answer is yes.
We've taken that into account and we've identified root causes connected to your comment within our process.
Say a little bit more about how you all are approaching that.
Well, what you asked was whether or not early identification.
early identification was taken into account and what we do is we study basically what are our processes around early identification and whether or not there is actual root cause related to our problem of practice.
Are we identifying early enough?
Have we done a good enough job identifying that?
Those are the kind of conversations that took place as we developed our theory of action.
So those conversations have taken place and we've looked
again, in the mirror versus out the window to identify where we failed in this work.
So yes, we have taken that into account.
We have to bring in outside partners who are doing that work as well.
It's not just, you know, the school district as you know.
There's so many other agencies that are engaged with early identification.
One of the things we're kind of curious about is to what extent is the early prenatal care and birth information able to inform us and how can we better connect
that to then early intervention and support for students.
I just have a very quick suggestion that I hope is going to be constructive.
So given the questions around audience of understanding what the system is and the complexity of the work, I would suggest that instead of a web, that the graphic that had a web, it be an infographic from the perspective of how an LEA would approach, you know, the multilayers of support, et cetera.
Thank you.
Okay, just again, we're, we're growing this.
We know you're working so hard on it.
We know that Eldorado has another presentation.
We'll do some clarifying and then we'll have some public comment on it.
So, thank you.
Kern county and the whole team and.
Yes, thank you.
And we're going to further this conversation by hearing from Eldorado County Office of Education, who is not a geographic lead, but they are part of a geographic region and they have identified how they want to ensure that they're effective partners, not only within the system, but with their districts that they serve.
And so you're going to hear from our superintendent of El Dorado County Office of Education, Dr. Ed Manansala, and he had the foresight to bring with him the superintendent, Dr. Marcy Guthrie, from Mother Lode Union Elementary District, so they can share with you the impact of the county office directly to the district.
Oh, slides, sorry.
I'll get you to your slides.
There we go.
Good afternoon, members of the board.
It's always a privilege to be here with you.
So my name, again, is Ed Manansal.
I'm the county superintendent of schools in El Dorado County.
It's my privilege to introduce to you Dr. Marcy Guthrie, who's the superintendent of Mother Lode Union School District, who recently was highlighted in the Learning Policy Institute's Positive Outliers report.
And so looking forward to her sharing the work that Mother Lode has been doing in the context of El Dorado County into the broader context of
the work that's occurring statewide.
So in the context of the system of support, we'd like to overview the significant shifts that have been occurring throughout county offices in respect to our role, our organization, and practice, and specifically the manner in which we've been supporting districts.
And once again, in particular, looking at
in the context of a county and a local school district.
In many ways, just try to demystify this work that we're explaining to you.
So since the inception, let me shift here.
So since the inception of LCFF in 2013, and this was being referenced in previous comments, we embraced that the new accountability system, so I'm just stepping back for a moment, is one that is more than a single number, where equity is at the heart of this work, and three, it's a focus on local control.
specifically the challenge in terms of meaningful and authentic stakeholder engagement.
We are fully aware of that.
A key link to the success of these reforms is the effective implementation of the system of support.
I would like to highlight within the context of a continuous improvement strategy.
So supporting the continuous improvement of districts has required COEs to reframe our focus, culture, and structures.
And so let me now start to just share the story of what it looks like at a local level from the perspective of a county.
So in spring 2019, so not too many months ago, the 14 superintendents of El Dorado County, representing the 15 school districts in the county, we were on a retreat.
And we were at a retreat in Lake Tahoe reflecting back on the changes that have occurred since 2013, where we are now, and where we are going.
I want to give you a sense of what that sounds like from just the voice of one of our superintendents in this idea of looking back, again, at the state level, county level, and local level.
So this is a very respected superintendent coming out of Lake Tahoe, Dr. Jim Tarwater, and he said, I've been leading for over 30 years in education, and while I believe in the overall direction of these changes, I've had a great struggle in putting all of these pieces together.
And so, Tahoe is one of the most beautiful areas of our state, but when you look at the issues around the achievement gap,
When you look at the issues around providing meaningful and authentic teacher support, there's challenges occurring there.
But let me share with you why he's sharing what he's stating there.
He's still making adjustments around really utilizing the LCAP.
That's one.
This past year, so in 17-18, the year that he's referencing, the district became qualified for differentiated assistance.
So continuing to refine the LCAP, making adjustments around, or learning to go through the process of differentiated assistance.
This district was also identified for a special education performance indicator review, the PIR.
Then again, just continue to layer this.
And then was also identified from the perspective of ESSA as a comprehensive support and improvement.
district, right, so there was a school in particular that was identified, and then to put the cherry on the cake, or however you want to describe it, it's like, congratulations, Dr. Tallwater, you're going through WASC this year.
Right, so, he's reflecting on this, and again, we talk about steel walls with our superintendents, and let's speak real with one another, and while we were talking about the changes and acknowledging
we sense that there's improvement going on.
There was a declaration through this discussion of like what's the greatest lever and let's focus on this as a county and individual districts over the next, and it was declared 24 months.
So if you had to guess what it was, here it is.
let's relentlessly focus on teaching and learning over the next two years.
That's it.
So this, for a county office, while we're listening, we're trying to think through how do we make sense of the feedback that we're getting, the data that we're looking at, and then developing comprehensive system of support around our districts.
So I'm not gonna go overly in detail, but what I'm sharing with you is we're hearing the voice of our superintendents and leaders
and then creating our system of support.
And this is what it begins to look like.
So before I go into the detail of El Dorado County, I do want to acknowledge my colleagues throughout the state, and I'm referring to the total of the 58 county offices of education.
We've been in a partnership with PACE, the 58 county offices, and we've acknowledged in our work with PACE and having discussions, we're recognizing there are three important shifts with county offices.
And again, I'm taking a step back, looking at the big picture, and then I'll come right back into El Dorado County.
And I want to share with you the three shifts that we've concluded as we're doing this work.
So one, COEs have shared responsibility to improve student outcomes.
What do I mean by that?
Realizing the vision of continuous improvement means that every layer of the system assumes a shared responsibility to improve student outcomes, which requires a mindset shift in COEs from their historical role, meaning
We are owning the results with our districts.
It's a tone, it's not about compliance, it's about shared responsibility and that's what's being felt with our districts and our leaders and our teachers as county offices too.
To support continuous improvement in districts, COEs must themselves experience and lead through continuous improvement to build their own capacity and to run their county offices as improvement organizations.
So while we're using a lot of terminology like improvement, science, and looking at organizations
In respect to continuous improvement, we know we need to be demonstrating that and living it.
Third, COEs must break down departmental silos and have access to data systems.
So in particular, COEs must break down departmental silos and have access to data systems that provide reliable, timely feedback to coordinated resources in order to lead the continuous improvement of districts.
So these are principles and shifts that are occurring throughout the state, and I'm gonna give you examples
Now what that looks like in Eldorado County.
And I go.
relatively quick through these, I just want you to get a taste of them.
I think it's most important that you hear from a district superintendent who's living this.
So first of all, just in respect to the local control accountability plans, we've set up, we, our county offices, set up just a calendar of, a structured calendar where we are meeting with our districts on a regular basis around the LCAPs, both formally and informally.
So the support around LCAPS comes in a collaborative environment where districts can bring business partners or
individuals from instruction, and across obviously different departments, essentially breaking silos.
It's a place where we analyze data, we look at the LCAP summary, and then of course we're looking at annual updates.
But what I'm pointing at is we are constantly looking at structures that make sense for districts around improving work.
And in one area in particular where we're seeing
that we needed to improve was around just stakeholder engagement.
And when you begin to see a district that is really becoming innovative and looking at good work around stakeholder engagement, and then is in a collaborative environment with other districts, that's a place just to share best practices.
So we have developed a learning network.
It's called the Eldorado Professional Improvement Community.
We had a partnership with Pivot Learning years back that we acknowledge there was areas and learning networks that they were doing good work that helped set up a template for us and we've really launched in that work.
So districts are given the opportunity to build professional capacity while working with county colleagues across districts
It's a place for us to bring experts in the field and looking at high-quality data tools to implement change ideas leading to improvement around dashboard results.
In particular, like three areas of just in respect to problem areas that we've identified
El Dorado County, we're looking at ELA, math, and then chronic absenteeism.
Tomorrow, actually, our district superintendents are going to be focusing on chronic absenteeism together as a county at a retreat.
Principal development is an important piece.
We're constantly looking at how we could develop leaders and have stability across the county and really developing that bench.
But I think this partnership that we are actually doing with
University of Washington around principal development.
The shift here is that we're looking at capacity building.
It's an important piece of the work.
When I say capacity building, the county office is looking at how we are working closely with Eldorado Union High School District in building their capacity to support instructional leaders and their principals and how to do that really well.
and it's a presentation in and of itself, but it's the capacity piece around principalship development is an area that I wanna highlight.
Content area specialists, as I've shared, we've seen themes around ELA and math.
These are voices from our teachers.
Again, when you're looking at a rural community, you're looking at a different type of capacity, and so we're identifying individuals to really support to go throughout our county, specifically around ELA and math.
The last piece that I want to speak to, we know that the importance of the relationships with labor and management is an important piece.
And so we have partnered with Sac County Office of Education, Eldorado County, in participating in the Labor Management Initiative.
So these are opportunities that exist for our districts, again, to look at specific training and supports around the critical piece with labor and management.
So what you see is a comprehensive view of how we are trying to be responsive to our district leaders and teachers and of course community members as well.
So it's my privilege to introduce to you Dr. Marcy Guthrie who will expand further on the work within her district.
I feel like I need to give you a brain break.
Thank you.
I want to just kind of say that I'm glad I'm in the presence of people who are impatient.
I'm in good company.
I want to tell you that I'm
My mom told me I shouldn't say this, but really, I'm the mother of Motherlode Union School District.
I've been the superintendent for seven years.
And I stand here having participated and engaged in a lot of things you learned about today or were reminded of today.
So my colleague, Dr. Tarwater in Lake Tahoe, when he was working through the LCAP, he had differentiated assistance on his radar.
He had performance indicator review on his radar.
Then he needed to worry about CSI.
And then all of a sudden WASC.
Well, I had all of those except for WASC because I'm an elementary school district.
And instead of CSI, it was ATSI.
But at the end of the day, really, that's kind of what we were up against.
And so I think Dr. Manansala laid it out that we've gone, we are continuing to evolve.
And I just want to tell you a little bit about Motherload.
So we have 1,050 students.
We serve students in the towns, not cities, towns of El Dorado, Diamond Springs, and the unincorporated parts of Placerville.
We have over 60% of our students who are unduplicated, meaning they are low socioeconomically.
That's their status.
They're English learners or they're foster youth.
We have 59% that qualify for free, reduced, and meet that no high school education graduation rate for parents.
So that's a match, 60% of our student population.
We have nearly 14% who are English learners, 12% who are special education.
We turned in our numbers yesterday.
We have 72 homeless students out of 1,050.
12 of them are students with disabilities, 10 of them are English learners, and nine of them are unaccompanied youth.
So you're not surprised.
What did I say?
Mother Lode has a full-time nurse, a full-time counselor, and a full-time school psychologist when other jurisdictions might not have that kind of staffing level and investment in people to support students.
OK.
So back when Differentiated Assistance launched, I knew when my phone rang and I saw Ed's name
that I was, that I, now it's not personal, that we were identified for differentiated assistance.
Our students with disabilities, their academic outcomes and their suspension rates had triggered differentiated assistance and it was the first year and I'm new, right?
New to this like the county office is new to this.
But fortunate for me, I've been in the county
Now, at that time, four years.
I have relationships.
I know my staff.
I know my community.
And I know my student and my demographic.
Well, when you're working your plan and you're doing all of the things that you know we are supposed to be doing in differentiated assistance, which is coming up with a root cause analysis and defining your problem of practice, and I want you to know I heard your questions.
Everything is tied to the LCAP.
So what drives differentiated assistance is what really ends up happening when you're doing your annual update in your LCAP and you're drafting your next year.
So it is a cycle of inquiry, like a plan, do, study, act, process throughout the year.
But we were identified in December.
And we were doing all this work.
And it was in time to shape our LCAP for the subsequent year.
But it wasn't in time for us to have any real impact to do anything to change what would be
landing on the next year's dashboard.
So year two rolls around, and we're still working our plan that we developed in the spring of the previous year, and we're working our LCAP.
Well, the new indicator, chronic absenteeism, is added.
Well, not only are we still identified for special education academic indicators and suspension rates, but oh, guess what goes hand in hand?
The chronic absenteeism indicator.
So that was our new indicator, and we added a new student group.
So across the board, our students with disabilities were lighting up our dashboard, and now our white group was also chronically absent.
And then we got to address the performance indicator review, which means let's get some stakeholders together and let's take a look at this through the lens of special education.
But when we attacked differentiated assistance in the first year, we backed up and said,
It starts in general education.
If we focus only on special education, we will have missed the mark.
So I get a little passionate, sorry.
And I'm kind of hungry, okay.
But, and I could use a Kleenex.
But I wanted you to hear a few things today, and I'm so glad that I was like the lone district superintendent here to say, I've been living this, and I think that there is promise in this work.
And I also want you to know, thank you.
Why I think there's promise is, and I wish she was here, she's in the T-zone, Dr. Darling-Hammond and colleagues identified the positive outliers, right?
Who are the districts that are having unprecedented growth for students of color,
African-Americans and Hispanics, despite their demographics.
And the letter loads on page 29, number 45 out of 167 school districts that were identified as positive outliers that are making a difference for students that are Hispanic or Latino, despite the 60% free and reduced, despite the 72 homeless students.
So I guess when I am impatient and thinking about outcomes,
I'm right there with you.
But I also know that change takes time.
And I think that leadership matters.
So even, and I have teacher leaders, my instructional leaders are my principals and my director of student support services, and we're in the work with our, together, and we bring in our teacher leaders.
I would say that we always have room to improve when it comes to how do we engage our parents.
And I want you to know that I listened to the student voices this morning and I thought, gosh, I miss high school.
I miss high school because, well, I just love kids, but high school students are so passionate.
And I kept thinking, I was not that articulate when I was in high school.
Thank God there are smart kids out there.
But we listen to our students.
And as a matter of fact, through this differentiated assistance process, we used a tool called empathy interviews.
And we were trying to get our hands around what's up with chronic absenteeism, right?
And so instead of making all of our own assumptions as adults, we asked.
We actually asked students.
And their answers blew our minds.
So I could bore you all day, but what I want you to know is what makes a difference for Motherlode
And so we're engaged in the work.
And we're partnering with our county.
And we're partnering with our sister and brother districts out there.
Because when you're small, and you're rural, and you might have six teachers at your largest grade level, there's no other school that has that grade level to talk to.
So our teachers find great, they find great
pride and joy in talking to one another, but also reaching out and talking to their fellow colleagues across the county.
And the County Office of Education and our partnership has created those conditions.
And they are only getting better and more refined as we move forward in this work.
I'm going to stop talking.
But I want to thank you for the opportunity and the Kleenex.
So just moving forward, I'd like to summarize on a few ideas.
So first of all, as I was sharing to you the challenges that Dr. Tarwater was speaking to, and one of the things that the superintendent shared with us in the spring was you need to really begin to map out differently and understand all of the activities that we're involved in, and how do you create a more seamless process?
And we really have taken that to heart.
And of course we're working across counties with our colleagues, but we're using what's called, right now, the theme again is this idea of coherence, and we're developing what's called our weaving project, where even this month we're meeting with key leaders throughout the state, so I'm just giving you an example, like Tamara Clay and Kirsten Comstock from El Dorado County Office of Education, they have an area of specialty in the PIR and disproportionality process.
Jenny Snyder from Sonoma County Office of Education.
She has an emphasis or obviously really understands differentiated assistance well and improvement science will be coming to a meeting.
And what I'm pointing out to is how do we make a coherent process when you're engaged with all of these different areas?
And how does that make sense for a Dr. Tarwater or Dr. Guthrie?
And I can name out the others who are part of that, but that we just see that as an important part of our work.
And of course, we're going to be working with our respective partners across state agencies.
The last note that I want to touch on was that on, well, actually, let me go back on.
Last week, I wanted to extend a thank you to state
superintendent Tony Thurman and the governor who came out to El Dorado County last week just to really see what the impact of the public safety power shutoffs are in our county.
It's very real and very challenging and this is how I'd like to finish.
So in the spring, the superintendent said the declaration was we're going to focus on teaching and learning.
That's what we want to see throughout our districts and throughout our county.
But then on October 9th,
of this year, 11 of our 15 school districts were without power.
Just imagine the impact on thousands of families throughout our county.
But at the same time, we had a high number of teachers and principals and even some district leaders
who had already planned on that day to go hop on a bus and go down to Sanger to learn about the good work they're doing around universal design.
And to me, it was symbolic.
It's like, even if the power goes out, even if the power goes out,
we're gonna continue to focus on teaching and learning.
So thank you for giving us the opportunity to share what's occurring locally.
I've been in El Dorado County since 2013 and for almost 15 plus years prior to that in an urban district in Sacramento.
And so being exposed to be it urban issues or rural issues, if we're looking at poverty or challenges, I'm very appreciative to the board
that you're willing to listen just to the various voices across California.
Thank you.
So, Dr. Monticello, thank you so much, and Dr. Guthrie.
So, and you all may know, Dr. Monticello also serves with us on CPAC and is a really important voice in our accountability system.
So, we have a short number of public comments.
So, what we're gonna do, since we have a tight schedule, we're gonna listen to our public comments, then we'll have one more board comment, if relevant, before we move on, because that'll kind of tie it up.
So, don't go far, we'll just hear our public comments, and then we'll come back and see if we wanna clarify.
So, we'll call for public comments now.
With the following individuals, please step up to the podium.
Michael Juba, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, Brian Rivas, Leticia Garcia, Liz Guillen.
Let me be the first to say good afternoon.
Time has slipped by.
My name is Michael Juba, and I'm speaking on behalf of California Teachers Association.
And listening to item three, two things popped into my head.
The integrating the stakeholders' feedback, all of them, and building that collaborative relationship.
And on behalf of CTA, we're sharing a letter from the Alvord Teacher Association because they've repeatedly attempted to engage in a meaningful stakeholder process but have been ignored by the administration of the Alvord Unified School District, as well as the Riverside Office of Education.
And we are urging you, the State Board of Education and CDE,
to follow up on this letter and restore that trust between the local association, the administration, and the County Office of Education.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Martha Zaragoza Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
I'd like to thank you for including the Practitioner's Guide for English Learner Students with Disabilities in Attachment 3 and encouraging its use
We believe this guide will provide sorely needed guidance to teachers instructing our English learners with special needs.
While the information in the memorandum and attachments were greatly appreciated, we were disappointed to see that only one geographic lead mentioned their Title III specialist and only one geo lead mentioned that their Title III lead would join their collaborative specific to the EL professional development.
In attachment 4, the only GOA lead for which there is not an update was the EL Lead Agency San Diego County Office of Ed.
We hope that in future updates, information will be provided regarding their work and hopefully more information regarding work of the Title 3 specialists and the Title 3 leads will also be provided.
Thank you.
Madam President, I'm Brian Rebus speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
Kudos to your presenters.
This is incredibly important and difficult work, so I enjoyed the presentation and we're rooting for the success of the overall effort.
I wanted to share, though, that we agree with our colleagues in the Equity Coalition that we would like to see stakeholder and community engagement.
adopted as a foundational principle.
It comes up over and over in our work with community groups.
And just a reminder, we think it would be really valuable for a couple of things.
One, we just think it's the right thing to do, but it would facilitate identification of root causes.
And also looking ahead, we see it as important in sustaining the work the next time we do take a budget downturn.
It's important to have community support for the work.
I worry about what happens the next time that we're faced with a budget shortfall.
So thank you.
Hello, this is Leticia Garcia on behalf of the Riverside County superintendent of schools.
Dr. Judy white just wanted to to offer that we have provided the board and state board staff with a comprehensive response to the
letters submitted by CTA on behalf of the Alvord Education Association that essentially encompasses all the work that our staff has done relative to the LCAP approval and oversight process at that particular school district.
And we stand ready to have any conversations and meetings with board members and with staff to further elaborate on that.
So thank you.
Good afternoon, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates echoing the comments that Brian Rivas made from Ed Trust West.
We really need to see counties be more proactive in supporting LEAs to include stakeholder and community in the conversations that they're having with LEAs and also in helping LEAs to be more inclusive.
We think that the essential role of stakeholders has really been missed and that's why we have been relentless in asking that that be recognized in the foundational principles around the system of support.
We think that without community and stakeholders, changing the mindsets and behaviors is not possible.
And we think that that needs to happen.
Thank you.
Okay.
Well, I want to thank our public for the comments.
And so this will just be a chance.
You don't need to make a comment, but if there were some comments that a board member wanted to make to close out this presentation on system of support and any clarifying with the last presentation, but again, you don't need to comment, but I just want to be respectful in case somebody wanted to.
So I'll start on this side and we'll start with member record.
Just one comment.
Again, I'm reminded we're going to try to do a six o'clock hard stop.
So let's work really hard to make our points really clear.
Okay.
So, um,
Knowing that I'm only going to be able to make one comment, I did have a specific question for Dr. Marin.
Yes, but at the same time, because it is a question about stakeholder engagement, it may be more appropriate for me to ask the question of the superintendent that he brought with him.
Three of the four people who made comments on public comment talked about the problem with stakeholder engagement.
So, I'm and the county superintendent, there was a representative from the Riverside County Office who came to say, well, we've done everything we're supposed to do.
So, I'm hearing three different versions of the truth about what's going on concerning stakeholder engagement.
The stakeholder community seems to be uniform in their concerns that there's some work that counties and districts need to be doing on this stakeholder engagement piece.
And I was going to ask questions of them, but since we're trying to limit our time, I will take my one question and ask the superintendent.
Could you?
Okay.
Okay, so this is not designed, the question I have because I only get to have one, it is a loaded question.
So I'm going to apologize for that in advance.
But you sat in this room and you just heard the same thing I heard.
I heard what you said about the work that you're doing and what I appreciate from both you and the County Superintendent was the candor
about how difficult the work has been for you, about addressing the capacity issues, and particularly from the superintendent from Lake Tahoe, about all the plates that he's really struggling to keep up in the air.
From three of the four stakeholders who gave public comment,
One of the plates that apparently are being allowed to crash, not in one area, but it seems to be happening pretty uniformly across the state, is about this thing about how you engage stakeholders in meaningful ways.
At the same time, the county office from Riverside said, we're doing it.
So I heard something very different from you when you talked about this.
So I'm going to ask you to tell me, what did you hear
from these other folks that you struggled with, that may have been common with what you struggled with, and what do you think you've been doing to try to address that?
So I will open with stakeholder engagement is like communication, right?
It's something you always have to work on, and I'm always reflecting on how we're going to do it differently or better or refine our practice.
So part of me just being honest and being Marcy, right, would say I'm thinking that perhaps some reflection, some
letting down our guards.
I've had difficulties, I will be honest, with my own stakeholders, so I'm going to speak for me.
I have to reinvent some things from time to time.
I have to take a step back, take a deep breath, and figure out a way to make it work.
And I'll give you an honest answer.
My first year in differentiated assistance, my, oh God, this is on TV.
OK, so we had some pushback from our colleagues that this was going to be a long process.
And so we thought we need to hear the voices of our employees, and we need to hear the voices of our teachers.
So instead of not having them come to the table, I actually had my principals and directors of departments
bring the content that we wanted to share to their departments and meetings, and then solicit input on their terms in their time, which would be like a staff meeting, faculty meeting.
And what I found, quite honestly,
was that more people were understanding what the LCAP was, the process that we used to build our LCAP, how we solicited their input, so we kind of had to figure it out, right?
It's like, if this isn't how they want to play, or this isn't working for us, but I still need them to be on this journey with me, I had to figure out something different, and I guess that's it.
I just did some, I tried something else, and it actually worked.
But, you know, thank you so much for... And I will close by saying I want to remind you that the three elements that are important for making this process work is patience, persistence, and what was the hallmark and foundation of your answer, humility.
And I have that quite a bit.
I'm reminded all the time and my mother reminds me daily.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Dr. Guthrie, for sharing that.
I also want to thank you, Dr. Guthrie.
I appreciate your energy.
Your total physical response really spoke to me as a former EL, kept me very engaged.
So I think the other thing I heard from public comment was
How do we, the state board, make sure that we put that affirmation forward, that stakeholder engagement is important?
And so I actually heard a very light request, which is added to your foundational principles.
We have LEAs in schools are more than a single number.
Resource decisions are driven by student need.
LEAs are the primary unit of change.
Sub bullet stakeholder engagement is inherent to this process.
Um, I actually don't think that's a big ask because the process is premise on stakeholder engagement.
I'm not sure why we would hesitate to add that 4th bullet.
I think that's something that's reasonable.
It's what it's.
transparency, continuous improvement, building trust.
It's inherent to the policy.
So I would really like us to consider, and I don't know if there's a hesitation why we wouldn't, and I know that that's just putting it on print and then the hard work is making it happen.
But I think that at least by putting it, by saying this is part of our affirmations, I think that that carries weight.
Thank you.
So I will just say I completely agree with Felicia, and I think that we should, the next time we have an item, we should have that as an action, and so that we can put it on there, because it comes up every time, it's embedded throughout the statute, so I don't, I sort of forgot why we didn't have it in the first place.
It's certainly, it's an omission, it's certainly not intentional.
And to that end, I just want to say two things about the collaborative, our colleague Matt Nava, who's at the collaborative,
a member on behalf of Dr. Darling-Hammond couldn't be here today, so he asked me if I could say a couple of things.
First, I want to thank Ronnie for her presentation and all the collaboration that's going on between the department, Stephanie and your staff and everyone.
to make this work, and you all made visible how complicated this is, and so I just want to express my appreciation.
To the issue about community engagement, I wanted to make sure, because we didn't really highlight that, but that, in one of those slides, we did talk about the community engagement leads, so we are working purposely on that.
It's being led by San Bernardino County, so maybe the next time we talk about this, we could hear a little bit more about
what that effort is and how the learnings from that will be made available to everybody else.
And then the last thing I just wanted to highlight is the collaborative, and Ronnie, you can speak to this if you want, is having a fall event next week, which you're all invited to, called Equity in Action.
It's on Thursday, November 14th.
at the library gallery here in downtown Sacramento from 10 to 2.
So if you're interested, I encourage you to go to the collaborative's website.
I think all the state board members have been invited.
And the keynote speaker is Dr. Christopher Edley.
I think many of you know Chris.
He's a nationally recognized expert and advocate for equity in education.
So again, thank you.
My last thing is Ed, thank you very much.
You hit the nail on the head.
You get a gold star for bringing a district superintendent.
to talk about the work and how they see it visible.
And thank you, Dr. Guthrie, appreciate your presentation.
We move on Stephanie, did you or Ronnie want to make a comment or do you.
Okay, Hank, we're just carrying hold on.
Just stay right there.
We're not done yet.
Okay.
Go around member sign.
Did you want to make any comment?
Um.
Remember, um, yes, so it's sort of interesting from the perspective of being a new board member, because externally, I've always heard the communications is that.
The rationale for LEAs being the unit of decision making is that accountability rests there and rests with community.
And I feel like that has been a part of the public narrative.
So it's a little bit of catching up sort of what principles I think we articulate explicitly to sort of what the messaging I think has been for quite some time.
We don't do robust data collection and transparency just for the sake of informing the LEA.
in order to enable communities, parents, families.
to actually engage with their LEAs and be a meaningful partner in those decisions.
The last thing I'll just say is more concretely, this is I think the first system of support item that has come to the board since I've been on.
And it just might be something helpful to sort of ask our future presenters to actually have a plank in their presentation to talk about what community and stakeholder engagement looks like in the future so that it is a standing part of what comes forward.
Stephanie, since you and Ronnie are here, we'll just ask you, did you want to make any closing comments?
I think with patience, persistence, and humility, we're on this journey together.
I think the difference in other structures previously that we've had, this is new, and the difference is that we're all partners.
We're all in it for the same reason, going in the same way, and that's different than before.
as acknowledged by Mary with the county offices.
On behalf of the state board, just thank you to all of our presenters who took the time to come from your districts and your counties and for the work you're doing every day to put this system together and to really address the issues that we're trying to get to to improve achievement.
And just thank you so much for the presentation.
We're going to move on now to agenda item four.
So this is item four, item five has moved to the end, but this is item four.
Okay.
I don't know if we're, okay.
So we'll start item four with Cindy Casanas.
This is an update on the implementation of the integrated local, state, and federal accountability and continuous improvement system.
The adoption of the English learner progress indicator status methodology and the use of status in LEA and school eligibility assistance determination and the update on the dashboard.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, members of the Board, Vice President Strauss.
I'm Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division.
Today, as Member Strauss stated, we will be going through several of our attachments that we've provided to you in Item 4.
The first is about the English under Progress Indicator, and then we'll walk through what we've been doing as far as getting the word out about the dashboard, as well as stakeholder outreach, and then the actual rollout of the dashboard.
The action that is recommended for the board is that you approve first the methodology and cut scores for the English learner progress indicator status by splitting levels two and three of the English learner proficiency assessments for California, LPAC, summative assessments, thereby creating six LP levels based on the LPAC, and then second, use the very low status to determine local educational agency and school eligibility for support.
So to get us started on attachment one, I wanted to first recognize my staff who is working hard to get out the dashboard, and this is our final action from you in order to get out the 2019 dashboard.
We worked very closely with our colleagues in our assessment division under the direction of Michelle Senner and our colleagues in the English Learner Support Division under the direction of Veronica
So this has been something that we've been working on for actually a number of years and are very excited to bring forward to you this final action to actually start using our new assessment in the dashboard.
So I first wanted to start off with who's actually in this indicator because we've had a couple of changes over the last 12 months to 18 months in which this board, some members of this board who were on it when you approved the Every Student Succeeds Act State Plan subsequently asked for a waiver to include more than just current English learners in the indicator.
So, because that plan or because that waiver was denied, I just wanted to make sure that we were all on the same page about who's included in the indicator.
So, it's English learner students in first grade through 12th grade who had summative assessment results on the LPATH in the current and prior year.
So the English learners that are not included are those who were reclassified, or RFEP, before taking the summative assessment in 2019, students who newly arrived, who were designated as English learners in 2019, and then students who graduated in 2018.
So you need those matched records in order to create progress.
which is why this is very unique.
This is a very unique indicator because of the two years needed to determine whether or not a student is progressing from one level to the next to create status.
So unlike the other indicators, we need those two years of data.
So in looking at the original methodology for the English Learner Progress Indicator that you adopted back in 2016, there was a splitting of the levels to create more opportunities for students to show progress.
And this was something that we knew was going to be something we needed to focus on for
for the new assessment under LPAC.
And so we did quite a bit of simulations.
There are quite a bit of tables in your agenda item that demonstrate why we think it's appropriate.
I'm going to walk through some of those tables now.
So we're looking at expanding what are currently known as the four LPAC levels into what we are now calling six LP levels.
So level one is equivalent, if you're reading this particular slide, is equivalent to the LPAC summative assessment level one, and then we split out level two to a low level two, a high level two, similarly with level three, splitting it out, and then keeping level four at level four.
So in order to make sure that what we are providing to you is based on data and based on fact, we ran several different simulations in order to get to this place.
When I came to you in September, there was some public comment and there was some interest in looking at it by grade span.
So we've done that as well.
I'll show you that in just a little bit.
But for this slide, what we're showing you is that for levels two and three, we are recommending that we split it right at the middle of the scale scores for each level.
So, for example, for grade 2, if we look at the LPAC level 2 scale score range is between 1424 and 1470.
We would split it directly in half to 1424 to 1446 for the level 2L for LP, so our low level for level 2, and our high level starts at 1447 and expands to the top of the range, which is 1470.
So in order to make sure that we didn't see differences in the data by grade span, we looked at, again, information at the grade level, and then in the grade spans one to eight, nine to 10, and we chunked out 11 and 12.
And so we looked at increasing one or more performance levels, or maintaining level four on the LPAC.
We looked at whether or not maintaining performance levels below level four on the LPAC, and then whether or not they've declined.
So that information, again, is included in the item, and we'll walk through
some of it in just a little bit.
So what you can see here is the impact of allowing students those extra opportunities to show progress by splitting the levels.
So if we kept it at the LPAC, the four levels from LPAC, you see, based on the data that we have, that 37.4% increased or maintained levels.
So they showed progress.
We had 48 percent maintained the lower levels and then we had almost 14 percent decline.
When we split, we see more progress in allowing that increase between where the concentration is, which is in levels two and level three.
The maintained lower levels decreases, but the decline does go up to 20 percent.
So that's the balancing out.
I also wanted to mention that we got a new file this last Friday, and while you see 843,000 matched records, that number has actually gone up to 900,000 with the new file.
So we were really glad we were able to use the most recent data when we do actually put out the dashboard, but these simulations were done prior to that file being received.
So the numbers, the match rate is quite high, and we're very appreciative of that.
We know that the match rate will go up even higher coming this year because we will be using a computer-based assessment and we can use CALPADS as a registration to allow students entry into the assessment.
So with that, we have colors that are a little different than what you're used to seeing on the dashboard.
Somebody calls them the Los Angeles Lakers colors.
Yeah, growing up in Southern California, we were always Lakers fans.
So this diagram or this chart was included in the item, but it's meant to show where we're at as far as English learners making progress between the 2018 LPAC levels and the 2019 LPAC levels.
So what you see overall from this is that students are highly concentrated in levels two and three.
So really the middle of the chart is where the chunk of the students are.
Compared to the next slide, again, more purple, gray, and yellow, and lots of numbers, but really what you can see now is just a much more, yeah, smoothing out of the data.
Thank you, that's a good word to use.
out of the data and so that we don't have these chunks of students or these high concentrations of students.
Again, this allowing us to split out the levels provides students the opportunity to demonstrate progress on a year-to-year basis because we know that it takes multiple years if you start at level one to get to level four.
Consider this to be a more fair approach.
So our recommendation going forward, we took this out to stakeholder groups.
Not only was Veronica, Veronica has been very supportive of involving us in all of her stakeholder groups, including the Binding Goal Coordinators Network, but Michelle does an in-person assessment stakeholder group, and I got to present to them last week.
And there was strong support, there has been strong support to the groups that we've been able to reach out to over the last eight weeks on the splitting of the levels.
I think the data really tells the story
very neatly.
So before we go into cut scores, I wanted to bring back some slides that we actually presented to the California Petitioners Advisory Group three years ago.
And we got some questions as the agenda came out about why were we using the methodology we were using to establish cut scores.
And this is really based on your action from several years ago.
And so I know there are some new faces on the board, and I just
wanted to be able to bring these slides back.
If you want to reference any parts of these, this information is actually also was in a memo to the State Board in August of 2016.
So it's been a while, but this is really, this has been our guiding path as far as how we look at establishing cut scores and methodologies being used.
So first, and I'm going to take you through both status and change.
So for status, we look at the data.
What we have done for each indicator is looked at where we're at with the data from an LEA perspective and from a charter school perspective, and we order the data from highest to lowest, and we look at four cut points selected based on that distribution.
Those cut points create the five status levels.
So for change, what we're looking for is, again, LEAs and charters, looking at ordering them separately from highest to lowest for positive change and lowest to highest for negative change.
And looking at those cut points, we do create the same four cut points.
They have different names though.
And then we've always said from the get-go, even when we looked at the language that's in the current SSA plan, that we're going to
keep these in place so that there's some, you know, there's some, the districts aren't getting a moving target from year to year.
But if there's a change that is needed because we are seeing something in the data, some noise in the data, we've brought back those cut points to you and you have approved a change in cut point from year to year if there is something that is extreme.
And so this slide shows you that we use the example of three to five years.
Additionally, we look at, we've talked about this already, but the cut points are done separately for each indicator because, of course, the data is different for each indicator.
Suspension rate is very different than what we're looking at right now today for English learner progress.
So this is the graphic example that we have.
So first, the first step we do is we look at our very low status, and keeping in mind our very low and our very high, it's about 10% of the distribution.
So, of course, very low indicates that that is an unacceptable performance, and that oftentimes combined with the change piece may get a district or a school into obtaining a red color on the
on the dashboard.
So the other step, the next step we do is looking at the high status cut point.
And of course that's a requirement under the Everstudent Succeeds Act.
And so that's our, we have to put that in our plan about what our goal is.
And that goal is written for each indicator that's relevant in the Everstudent Succeeds Act state plan.
Then we do the rest of the distribution.
So you see very low, low, medium, high, and very high.
So it averages out to what you're going to see in just a little bit from our cut scores.
And then in establishing the change cut scores,
Again, starting first with decline significantly, and then moving over to increased, so almost to high, trying to make sure that there's positive change by the majority of the schools is how we set that cut point, and then ending up with the rest of the change distribution there.
So it's just a nice graphic, a nice reminder of where we were at, what we've been using as our guiding principles for establishing the cut scores that you see before you today.
So this is probably obvious, but let me just state it out loud that looking at 2018 assessment results for the LPAC, we see that as grade level increases, the percentage of students in level one increases.
And of course this is noticeable in grades nine through 12, especially when we have students that come in, come from other countries into our public education system.
And so in looking at simulations and producing our cut scores, we wanted to make sure that we looked at those cut scores to see if there was a noticeable difference between the grade spans, between grades one through eight and nine through 12.
And what we saw or what you see here on the table, which is also in the agenda item, is that there's not a noticeable difference.
There's what we see overall.
is that our number of elementary and unified school districts and the percentages pretty much neatly align to the percent of LEAs as well as the percent of high schools.
So without that noticeable difference or not significant differences, we think that it's important that we keep the cut scores the same for grades 1 through 12.
When we do have cut scores that differ by school or district type, I just want to make notice that we do that for the suspension rate, for example, and we do that for the academic indicator.
We have to spend a lot of time explaining why they're different.
And so it does take time away from individuals understanding the actual indicator.
And so if we can keep the cut score distribution together with the grade spans, it helps for communication purposes.
So these are the status levels and the cut scores we're recommending for very low.
We would set it at 35%.
And if we go to that high, so that goal of LP status would be 55% to less than 65%.
And again, this is based on the data.
We will revisit these scores next year when we have to bring back to you the cut scores for change.
And then I would also wanted to mention is that because we're moving to computer-based assessment, Michelle has scheduled as part of a special study for educational testing services to do a comparability study on LPAC and looking at the impact of the computer-based assessments on scores and so on.
So, where these cut scores land are LEAs, the distribution.
Again, it's very neat in that we have just under 10% in the very low, 6.5% in the very high, and then you see the bulk of it in the median, which is what we're looking at for a normal distribution.
and the distribution for schools.
This does include charter schools.
Again, very similar with the bulk of our schools in the medium rather.
So with that, I wanted to shift over to the next piece, which is using this indicator for differentiated assistance.
Of course, this is required by the U.S.
Department of Education because we are out of compliance on this issue as a state.
And so by including the English Learner Progress Indicator as part of identification for schools under the Every Student Succeeds Act, we will come into compliance with that part of ESSA.
So, a year ago, you approved the use of the status.
You signaled to not only to, I think, our stakeholders, but to the federal government that we took this seriously and that we would be, in 2019, coming into compliance by using the LP status for use in determining school identification, but we're also going to be using it for identification under the local control funding formula for districts, including charter schools, for the first time.
So we have spent quite a bit of time on the language that you see here, and what we are recommending is the use of the term very low.
So you're going to see that throughout this piece for this one year.
So it's a proxy for REDD, and we are creating resources around it that you're going to see in just a couple of slides as well.
This terminology has been vetted through the workgroups that you see listed below, among others, and there is interest in making sure that it's different words than using the word red, because it doesn't mean the same thing.
We didn't create a color this time around, right?
This is our transition into a color for next year.
So this is actually a chart I showed you in September, so I'm not going to spend much time on it, but just to emphasize when we're looking at identification of districts under the local control funding formula that you need to be able to show that you're not improving in the different priority areas.
So keep in mind that English language arts and mathematics and English learner progress indicator are all in the same priority area.
So in addition to one of those not showing red or for English language arts and math it would be orange and then a combination with red, you'd have to go out of another priority area.
And so for this one, we see the LP status at very low and the chronic absenteeism of red gets this made up district, Crystal Unified School District into differentiated assistance.
They are eligible based on those two priority areas because their English learner student group is not progressing.
So just a reminder for looking at school support, of course we have different criteria that you all adopted with the Every Student Succeeds Act state plan and the criteria is up here on the screen.
And the example we're using is again the same from September but just to reemphasize the fact that we are looking at majority in this particular example for Amethyst Elementary School, the majority
of the indicators need to be read for this one, and because Verilow is a proxy for red, they will be identified for support under the comprehensive support and improvement, so CSI.
OK, so our recommendation is to, again, use the very low as a proxy for red.
And we look forward to the discussion.
I don't know if you want me to take a pause here.
Actually, I did have two more pieces.
Because there was a lot of discussion, I think, in September from the board and the dais about how are we going to communicate this out to the field, I just wanted to share with you a couple of things that we have in the works.
So we have spent actually quite a bit of time with the policy group, with the English learner progress indicator work group on what the display is going to look like on the dashboard.
And we've gotten actually a lot of great feedback.
And so that display is in development right now.
It'll be ready for the dashboard release in December.
We also have a new flyer that is in progress about how status is calculated, so similar to the examples I gave you just now, you would see something like that in this flyer.
We will have a webinar, you're going to hear a little bit more about the webinar series in just a minute, just dedicated to the English learner progress indicator, which is what we do to support the rollout of the private preview.
And then finally, we have updated, and we do have a webpage dedicated to the criteria that we use for differentiated assistance on the webpage here listed below.
So there's quite a bit of support around this, and again, feedback leading up to the development of these resources.
So, I'm happy to take a pause if there's questions.
Yeah, let's do a pause at this point.
So, let me just say, this discussion piece right now, just one comment from each board member plus the liaison comment for accountability is on the splitting of the LPAC to go to six levels because that's the recommendation that's before us.
And the status, if we could talk about the status.
and the status as well.
So I'll start with Member Byrne, myself, over the accountability liaisons.
Everyone, one clarifying comment.
Everyone will get a chance if you want, and then we'll go to public comment, come back for discussion, and then Cindy can highlight the dashboard week.
So Sue first.
A big thank you, Cindy, to you and your staff, and Michelle, and Veronica, everyone who's worked on this.
I know it's been a heavy lift.
Very thoughtful.
Appreciate all of the stakeholder input that you've received, and I think we're ready to go, but I'll stop there.
So, let me say, this was discussed at CPEG with support from the CPEG, but I did understand that prior to CPEG, you had actually gone to the work group and gotten other input, and I think that helps us understand the stakeholder input.
So, if you could quickly share to be prior, the work group, the stakeholder input that you got on this that actually helped inform this splitting, because honestly, at the CPEG meeting, strong support to going to the sixth level.
So, Cindy, if you'll share that.
So I think it actually started back with the September board meeting and the public comment that you received and the letters you received talking about the need for more transparency around the data simulations.
And so as we were able to work with the data in the month of September, we made sure that the tables that you see reflected in the item today, that we were trying to be as transparent as possible about what the data was showing.
The policy work group, like I said, they got into the weeds.
They got into word smithing, what you will see on the display, using the words like progress, using words like maintained.
We want to make sure that this is ultimately what a parent sees on the dashboard as a parent of an English learner.
It is digestible for them.
I would say that the work that you see reflected in this item has been shaped and molded and iterated because of not only the policy work group, which is made up of practitioners and researchers and very – and advocates in the field, but also our technical design group spent almost two hours on this topic in
I remember which month it was.
It must have been October.
Things are starting to bleed together.
But it definitely was iterated, and so we were updating, actually, these slides up until yesterday because everybody likes to talk about the English Learner Progress Indicator.
So it's nice to have that kind of support.
Thank you.
So let me just clarify for board members.
This is a clarifying question.
Then we'll go to public comment, and then we'll come back for a board discussion before we take action.
So, Member Rucker, I'll start with you.
One comment going around, if you want to make it.
If you want to wait until after, that's fine, too.
Cindy, first of all, I want to add my kudos and compliments to your staff for the work that was done on this.
I think it was a very thorough, comprehensive and thoughtful process that happened not over the matter of a couple of weeks, but this was a long-term
very detailed and very in-depth conversation about the facets of what it would mean not only to create the cut scores, but also what the impact would look like this in the field.
So I'm very grateful for the process that happened with this.
I do want a clarification about
the out of compliance part that you said on ESSA.
You said that in one sentence and you kept going.
So, what did you mean when you said that by approving this, we would fall into compliance?
Because the way you said that made it seem like we were accidentally getting into compliance rather than we worked on this in a purposeful way to make it work for the compliance requirements we had to meet.
I hope that question made sense.
and I like the words that you chose to use instead of the words I chose to use.
I'd like to take it back and let's start over.
I think the board had a very thoughtful approach.
I would agree with you on that.
We have spent probably more time on this indicator than a lot of the other indicators because of the board's commitment to making this work.
So because switching from one assessment to another assessment takes time and we want to be thoughtful about it,
we did not have two years of data until this year to create status.
So last year we were able to show on the dashboard simply how students were doing for the one year of that assessment.
We were not able to use that information to actually show that schools weren't
weren't helping their students learn English.
And so as a result, the federal government deemed that we were out of compliance because you need to use that in the identification of schools under the Every Student Succeeds Act.
So this is a very purposely driven recommendation and it's been a long road that we've all been on together, but this will bring us into full compliance of that measure come when the dashboard gets out in December.
Thank you, Cindy.
I want to just foreshadow some of the comments that we'll hear.
There was a lot of concern about the methodology that we use for the LP.
There was concerns that some students would not actually reclassified within the established timeline of five, four to seven years.
This, when we think of our English learner population, we all know here there's many typologies.
There's not one specific English learner.
And so, I do want us to be thoughtful.
I appreciate the commitment to reviewing our data, our thresholds next year.
We'll have three years of LPAC data.
We'll have one year of data based on computer-based assessment.
And so it will really benefit us to have that discussion next year.
But I also want us to be mindful of who are we looking at when we're looking at our data.
80% of our students that are English learners are born in the U.S.
So there's no reason why any of those students who we take into our school system so early on should ever become long-term Ls, right?
And so just being mindful of that as we're looking at the data moving forward and then revisiting our cut scores to see if those are appropriate.
Thank you.
So, what we're, I guess, Cindy, go ahead, because I need just a couple announcements, then we'll go to public comment, then we'll come back for board discussion.
Great, so this is just giving us a little, showing off a little bit of our work.
How about that?
So, led by individuals in the state board office as well as the CDE communications office and others, we launched a dashboard week in September, sort of a back to school kind of awareness about the dashboard.
And so in this one particular week, it was after the board meeting,
We did targeted messages about the dashboard and the resources that were available.
I just wanted to share some statistics with you.
I think part of this is in the board item now.
In that one single week, we did see 16,000 individual hits to the dashboard, including 9,500 of those being new users.
25%, a little bit more than that, raised from the prior week.
Let the Conversations Begin is the video that you see on the homepage of the dashboard.
There's also three additional videos, and all of these videos are translated into Spanish.
We just got some statistics on that particular video for the length of time it's been up, from December to October, and we've had 10,000 hits on that video.
We still are not getting a lot of hits on the Spanish videos.
So I'm still, even though we did a whole day around this on social media around the translations that were available, and you can see that's bullet four, translated materials, I think we still need to do some targeted messaging to parents.
And because we will be onboarding new languages come 2020, early 2020, I think this will be a great time to also highlight those translated materials that are available.
We did put together, you're gonna see, I'm gonna pass this out and we can look at it at your leisure.
an equity report, and I'm going to show you that in just a minute.
And we did get additional users to look at the mobile app or download the mobile app, so that's good, too.
And then we have a joint newsletter that is a combination of our system of support colleagues in the department, as well as our Title I division, who's helped us to talk a lot about what's going on with the dashboard in one place.
So we've taken this slide and these activities from our colleagues in assessments because they actually created this template, but I like just to reflect on what we've been doing since we last met.
And so we have done 15 in-person presentations.
That doesn't include the two that we did today.
already before this meeting with 1,300 participants.
Michelle is going to show you some things from the conference that they just held, and at that conference we had in my session about 150 people.
So very well attended.
Folks are very interested in the dashboard.
We are starting our webinar series, and so you're going to see that with this rollout piece.
So the flyer you have before you is one that we put together specifically around equity because we wanted to draw attention to it.
Our superintendent is very focused on closing the achievement gap and we wanted to show how we're able to show that on the dashboard at a glance.
And so that's what this flyer is intended to do.
We have other flyers that we're creating, and we've actually rearranged our web page to make it a bit more user-friendly.
Sometimes we get a lot of things on our website, and it's hard to navigate.
And so we did a refresh just this last week.
One of the things that we are going to be uploading in the next couple of weeks are some flyers around how you calculate these things.
So again, with the same look and feel with the color scheme and trying to make it one page or two pages or less will be
updating our college career indicator piece to just make it a little bit more user friendly and a fresh look.
And then we have a flyer on how to compare schools.
So keep in mind that the dashboard has a component in which you can look at a single school district and compare schools across it.
And so there is a couple of different ways to look at that information and we wanted to make sure that we
For those that have not let go of similar schools criteria from the academic performance index from a decade ago or more, this is our attempt to say you can still look at comparing schools.
Here's how you do it within a different, not similar schools, but in a different context.
Then we also are going to do a flyer on what is our dashboard alternative school status.
So we are very busy.
This is Jenny.
Jenny Singh leads the effort to make sure that the division, the entire division is on task to complete the activities in the time that we've told the field we were going to do that.
We've just sent out for private preview chronic absenteeism data.
The suspension data got a little more complicated this year.
We added some factors in for cow pads.
So we're still working on that data.
But on our webinar just a couple of days ago, we had close to 500 people, and I expect more for next week's webinar on graduation rate and college career indicator.
These webinars are open to anybody.
The private preview is only open to designated staff at districts and schools.
So we are on track to release the dashboard the week of December 9th to 13th.
What we are planning to do is to release the companion data request report, so that's the graduation rate, chronic absenteeism, and our discipline reports.
So that is our plan for the next couple of weeks.
And here's your action before you.
Okay, so Cindy, thank you so much for the presentation.
So we're going to go to public comments now, and then we'll come back for board discussion and an action.
We have seven speakers for public comment.
Martha Zaragoza Diaz, Lorraine Richards, Samantha Tran, Dean Drescher, Brian Rivas, Liz Guillen, and Sarah Lillis, please line up.
Good afternoon.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
We support the establishment of the six LP levels based on the LPAC.
However, concerns have been expressed by our members that the proposed cut scores for each level will not support transitioning an EL out of their status within five to seven years, but instead result in many ELs becoming LTELs.
Therefore, we would like for you to seriously consider using a criterion reference versus a norm reference methodology in setting the cut scores for each performance level.
We believe this would result in the likelihood of ELs transitioning within five to seven years.
Once the third year data is available, it is strongly requested that a complete review of the cut scores for status and then change be done and that there be a review of the thresholds for the proficiency levels.
Our members stand ready to assist you and have continued discussions on these issues.
Thank you.
Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association.
CTA supports the six levels and will continue to monitor progress of English learners.
Good afternoon, Samantha Tran with Children Now, and I think Martha said it perfectly, so I'll just say ditto and really appreciate the board and staff's work to get the LP on the dashboard this year and hoping that we can revisit the conversation around cut scores when it comes back up next year.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis with Teach Plus, and again reiterating the points made by Kaveh and Children Now.
We also support the six levels, or the split, but we do have concerns about the signal being sent by the cut scores, particularly as it relates to our goal.
When we talk about high as being our goal, if we're saying 55% of students making one level of progress a year is our goal,
clearly the expectations for reclassification and knowing the barrier that reclassification plays in our students' lives, how important that is.
So really pushing, as my colleague said, to revisit that.
Good afternoon, Dean Drescher.
On behalf of EdVoice, all of my colleagues have said it very nicely.
And so I recommend that, again, we use a criterion reference approach versus the norm reference that's been proposed.
And the reason for this is exactly how Sarah just laid it out, which is to increase the likelihood that English learners will transition in five to seven years according to the research that the department cites to justify establishing the six performance levels.
And so we support the use of criterion reference methodology and would encourage you all to revisit that.
Thank you.
Hello, Liz Guillen for Public Advocates.
I agree with everything that was already stated.
And I am happy that we are going to revisit this next year.
And the coalition is as well, the equity coalition.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for our public comments.
So we're gonna go back to the action that is being recommended to us, and then I'll look for a motion and a second, and then any comments before we move on.
So do I have a motion?
I move the department's recommendation.
Okay, so board discussion.
Do we want to make any comments?
Yes, go ahead.
I had a question.
I don't know if this is part of this presentation on the Navigator.
So I'll just ask it because I don't think you're going to model it, right?
Sure.
I am not going to model it today.
The California School Dashboard Navigator is a GIS mapping tool that we've shown to you twice.
We actually reiterated it again because we're continuously improving.
It was so popular that on the webinar it took a while to load.
I will say that GIS mapping is something we continue to work on as a department.
We have a total of one person dedicated to this work.
And they work for Jonathan Eisler.
So his name is Greg Dixon.
He's great, but he's one person.
And he's also doing fire mapping and things that come up in an emergency.
So we have planned to continue to work actually with the comp center to develop out mapping components.
Because I'm sorry, you took me on a detour, but I wanted to say this out loud.
Things like Barbara Murchison comes to me and says, I have this grant I want to get out.
Can you tell me where these resources are statewide?
I think as we look at not only accountability but other data points, the geographic piece is actually a very useful tool, but we need to figure out a way to make sure it reaches the masses.
With that in mind, I invite you all to JS Day.
It's next week.
I think it's the 14th, right?
13th in this room.
This is our fourth year of hosting that.
We have students coming to present, because there are students out there that work with mapping tools, not only at the high school level, but middle, and I think even elementary in some areas.
So the Navigator is just one of a lot of things you're going to see from the department in the future on GIS.
Because as soon as I saw the link, I wanted to look at it.
It is slow.
Even offline, because it was like midnight, and I'm like, oh, let me see what's happening.
And it was a little slow.
I'm not really sure what the no color means, and it would be great to select multiple state indicators so that you could see.
Because right now I'm limited to one student population, one indicator, it would be great to see, to select multiple student populations or even regions and multiple state indicators.
And of course, eventually the LP should be included here, because we don't have one yet.
Definitely be included in there.
Thank you for the feedback.
Any other board, Kim?
A clarifying question for, so in order to revisit the conversation around cut scores, that's something that will come back as we have the third year of data.
There's nothing procedurally that needs to be done that's based on passport action already, right?
Based on passport action, the methodology that we use, but I want to say that, you know, I did reference that we have a normative way of looking at it.
That's what the cut scores are today.
Moving forward those customers are gonna.
You know where our district's land are gonna change and and the research Talks to us about you know what they've they've observed is you know three to five years for oral Attainment and longer for academic.
That's not what the department is saying we want students to learn English as a
as quickly as appropriate.
I think there has been some mixing of terms and we will come back next year when we look at creating a change cut score and we can look at the status cut scores as appropriate next year as well.
more comments from the board members or clarification.
Okay.
So at this point, let's show we have a motion to support the recommendation from CDE.
So can I have a show of hands of all those in favor?
Opposed?
Any abstentions?
So the motion passes unanimously.
So thank you very much.
So I have a quick announcement.
First of all, item five will be heard at the end of our agenda.
And also, we're gonna hear waivers in a little bit, but waiver W-5 has been withdrawn by CDE.
So it'll be posted on the website.
So it's been withdrawn for this board meeting.
W-5 waiver has been withdrawn.
Okay, so we are now skipping we're not gonna we will come back to item 5 and we're going to go to item 6 And again board members if you need to take a rolling break just make sure we have a quorum in the room, okay, thanks Good afternoon
The mics are very soft and quiet today.
So, but I think it's on.
So good afternoon, Michelle Senner, the director of the assessment division here at the department.
So today I'm going to have an item, I lovingly refer to it as our mega item.
So in other words, we do have some action before you today in item six, as well as some informational information that I wanna share with you.
So the action is on this slide right here.
The department asked the board to approve the proposed threshold scores for the California Science Test or the CAST.
Those threshold scores are shown in attachment two.
So in terms of my presentation, I plan to start with a presentation on the proposed threshold scores.
Then I will follow it up with more of the informational parts of the item, and I have some breaks in between those sections so you can ask your clarifying questions.
So in this section of my presentation on the proposed threshold scores for the California Science Test or the CAST, I just want to reiterate that the CAST threshold scores are for the overall scale score for grades 5, 8, and high school.
These threshold scores are in Table 1 of Attachment 2.
Before I dive too much into that, I want to acknowledge and thank Eileen Strauss for observing the standard setting process, and hopefully when we have time for comments, you'll be able to share out on your thoughts of the process that we used.
So the science assessment was developed to comply with the following requirements that you see on the slide here.
It's administered pursuant to California Education Code.
The action before you today also meets the Code of Federal Regulations.
Those regulations require a minimum of three levels to be established for performance, as well as achievement scores that differentiate between those levels.
Also important to note is that the work accomplished was guided by action that the board took when you approved the general achievement level descriptors for this test and will serve as part of our submission to the U.S.
Department of Education as part of our federal peer review process for this new test.
The CAST is aligned to the California Next Generation Science Standards or the California NGSS.
It's administered to students in five, eight, and one time in high school.
It measures three science domains.
Those three dimensional domains are earth and space, life, and physical sciences.
CAST is proposed to have four achievement levels.
Those would be exceeded, met, nearly met, and not met.
This slide here shows the massive amount of work that my staff as well as our contractors have done thus far on this new test.
So just to go over this quickly, we know that the standards were adopted in 2013.
The board approved our high-level test design for this test in 2016, and then in 2017, you approved the general achievement level descriptors as well as the test blueprint for this test.
Following a pilot and field test, the first operational administration of CAST occurred in 2019.
ETS conducted the standard setting workshop in July and August and we brought forth information from that workshop to our technical advisory group in September and that brings us to today where I'm asking for your approval of the threshold scores.
So we did provide to the board a detailed standard setting plan for this science test in an informational memorandum that was provided to you in October.
The standard setting approach utilized the ANGOF method of standard setting.
That's a little new for California, but not a new standard setting methodology.
The method is widely accepted, adheres to guidelines and best practices that are recommended in standard setting literature.
And I'm going to go over in the next few slides just a slight overview of what that standard setting process was.
So this slide might look a little familiar because I used it, something very similar last time when we talked about the Spanish test.
So for the CAST, you see the four levels on this slide.
Four achievement levels mean three threshold scores.
So our panelists define the borderline student for levels two, three, and four.
That's the solid colored characters, I guess you wanna call them.
So, in other words, they looked at what does performance look like for a student that is just in level three, for example.
So that would be the solid pink character in this slide.
Those borderline student definitions are also referred to as threshold achievement level descriptors, are an important tool, and it is what our panelists used to make their recommendations on the threshold score judgments that they did.
The standard setting process involved educators first taking the test.
I think it's one of their favorite things to do when they're with us.
The panelists reviewed the grade-specific achievement level descriptors.
They define those behaviors of the borderline student that I just described.
And then they used all of that information in three rounds of judgments.
and their judgments were the likelihood that students at that borderline definition would answer an item correctly.
And they engaged in quite in-depth conversations between each of those rounds.
So in summary, you can think of the ANGOF method as panelists making judgments on the likelihood of the borderline student answering each item correctly.
So specifically, they were asked what percent of students at each of the borderlines would answer the question correctly.
So that was a very simplistic overview of the process, and it probably doesn't really convey the depth of the conversation that occurred, the content conversations that the panelists had at the meetings.
All you have is me saying so, and maybe Eileen Strauss will also be able to share that that was something that occurred.
Okay, that's just a fascinating part of the standard setting.
I'll go back to that slide.
By the way, it's the same process.
Please watch with the Spanish test.
So it's worth sharing because it's fascinating and so impressive, the process.
So go ahead.
It's a very deliberate process.
So we have
descriptors that define, let's use level three in this example.
That's the pink range here on the slide in front of you.
So we have descriptors that describe student performance at level three in general.
But in order for us to really know where we should set the threshold, we actually need a definition of what the solid pink character looks like.
That is the character that is just in level three.
If you think about what that student knows and can do in terms of how they demonstrate it on the test, it actually looks more like the student that is at the top of the green than it does look like the student that is at the top of the pink.
So they engage in these conversations about what does it mean to be just in level three, just in level four, and they make that definition of that student and what it means in terms of the content they would know.
and they use those definitions to make that judgment about each item.
And they think about, they call it just-in for just-in.
So they think about just-in and whether or not just-in for level three, what is the percent that they would get that item correctly?
Does that help?
Oh yeah, that helped.
The reason why I was asking that is because I recall with Smarter Balanced when the performance level descriptors were adopted, they were adopted with some intentionality by the consortium.
Who developed and adopted these performance level descriptors?
So there are multiple performance level descriptors.
There are threshold descriptors, which is what these definitions are that relate to the student that is just in.
There are range descriptors, which define performance across that entire pink thing.
They are that level, sorry.
And then there are policy descriptors.
So this board adopted the policy descriptors.
That's what I wanted to hear.
Okay.
And our educator panelists are the ones that come up with the descriptors for the threshold as well as the descriptors for the range.
Is that helpful?
That's helpful.
Okay.
Thank you.
So I think I was describing who our panelists were, I think is where I was.
So if you look at attachment three of this item, you will see some information about our panelists.
They were 46 diverse California educators.
These educators have indicated that they have made measures themselves to implement the California Next Generation Science Standards in their teaching.
We all know it's early on in implementation, but these teachers did indicate that they were doing so.
The panel's judgments are provided to you in Table 2, in Attachment 2 of the item.
The CDE consulted with members of the CASP Technical Advisory Group, as well as our own in-house psychometricians, before we finalized the proposed recommendations that you actually see in Table 1.
The proposed threshold scores result in approximately 30% of students meeting standards.
In addition to the CASP technical advisory group, briefings were also held with members of our national science expert design team and the California Science Teachers Association.
So this is a simplified version of the table that you have in Attachment 2 that represents the proposed threshold scores.
So in order to make sure that we maintain fidelity with the work of our standard setting panel, the threshold scores that we are proposing are within plus or minus one conditional standard error of measurement of the panelist's recommendations.
This is all adjustments are within the natural air variance around the panelist recommendation and therefore reflect only slight modifications of their judgments.
So to provide additional context as you consider the threshold scores before you today, I also want to provide you with a little bit of data and information that we received directly from our test takers.
So immediately after completion of our computer-based science test, students took a survey.
So this is self-reported data from our students.
And we asked them about whether they were receiving science instruction in the three science domains, earth and space sciences, life sciences, and physical sciences.
Grades five and eight, we had three survey questions, and in high school we had an additional question, so there were four there.
The survey results you have outlined for you in attachment three of the item.
In general, some of the highlights would be that a majority of students reported receiving instruction on most of the topics covered on the test.
More than one third of the students felt most of the CAS questions were different from the questions that they were getting in their science classes.
A majority of students stated that the science questions were harder or about as hard as questions in their science classes.
And most high school students indicated that they took the test after their last science course in high school.
So looking beyond today, if the board approves these threshold scores, ETS will then generate our student score reports to send out to our districts.
And we would anticipate that the department would then provide its public web reporting of this test in January.
So I'm gonna pause there for clarifying questions before we move on to the aspects that are not related to actions.
Okay, so I'll just make one comment and then I'll go to a member of the Chiesa Cone and anybody else.
So this was really amazing for any of us who, several of us have already seen standard setting processes.
But in addition to the survey that students responded to, I appreciate those comments, Michelle.
The teachers on the panel really committed people who were really implementing NGSS and really have a sense about it.
By the way, ETS did an amazing job facilitating this.
Just a credit to ETS and the work in this process, and I appreciated being an observer.
But the teachers were asked, what would you now tell teachers about CAST and science instruction as a result of you now setting the standards and looking at the difficulty of the assessments?
And the feedback from the teachers was amazingly powerful about the vocabulary needed on these tests, about the academic challenges.
And I had actually asked ETS and CDE if there was a way from the standard setting process that we could create a guidance document as people are working on implementation, because we know people are just
adopting aligned materials in the next year or so, and it is a slow transition process.
But let me just say to credit to ETS and the teachers that participate in the standard setting, they have a lot to tell us about the implementation that I think we should listen to if you've been, and I know Patricia's actually been on a standard setting committee, you really learn a lot that might help us in instruction.
So I'll just put that on the table.
I'll move to our member Ortiz-Lacon and then other clarifying questions.
And thank you for the presentation.
Actually, that was part of my question.
What do we know from the reflection of teachers, not just the ones that were part of this threshold score setting committee, but just teachers in general?
Because when I read, for me, what was fascinating was the survey to students.
And I wanted to know, is this mandatory?
Did every student that took the exam, they had to, was it a mandatory selection before they exit?
Or did we miss some data?
Not every student, was it optional?
It looks like it wasn't all, but the majority of students did answer.
Yeah, because I thought, well, this would be great if districts had access to the information from the students and then maybe triangulate that with their scores and teacher feedback.
Because I know that this is something that is of interest, and we want to make sure that it also resonates and people understand, are we really equipping our students and our teachers for this?
So just so I can respond to that, we are currently working on getting the student results in a summary for districts that we can provide to our districts.
We hope to have that done by the end of the month.
Well, Michelle, you and your team never cease to amaze me, not only with the level of expertise you have on the work that's being undertaken, but just how you make something so very complex really understandable in very plain English.
So I truly appreciate that.
and Board Member Strauss is correct.
I have participated on a standard setting panel and this one, this standard setting method was very different from what was used to do the standard setting for the other two assessments that we have in our accountability system that's in our academic indicator.
One of the reasons why I was asking for the explanation about what a borderline student is
is because that was a term of art I hadn't heard before in the standard setting conversation and that seems to, so I'm going to ask you just to correct me on this, it seems with the other standard setting method used for English language arts and math, the indicator focused on a definition of proficiency.
So is this, and I'm using that word on purpose because it was level three, what is the difference in how, since there's more than one dimension that went into this definition, how was that actually explored?
Is it related to the standards that were identified for the assessment, the blueprint standards that were identified for the assessment?
And I think I know, so identifying and defining the borderline student is not different to this methodology that is used in the bookmark method also, which is the methodology that we have used for some of our other tests.
But you are also correct that when we have this conversation about the borderline student, we also use the policy definitions that this board adopted.
And when you think back to the policy definitions that you adopted, you, in essence, told them
which level met standard, right?
So that proficiency, if you will, conversation is part of that in the sense that when you are defining that particular borderline for that specific level, you are talking about from that point on, you've identified that as meeting standard.
That was the other piece I was trying to get you to say.
Thank you.
OK, so you can continue.
OK.
So not that that wasn't fun, but let's go on to some more fun things.
Okay, so now we're going to do some updates with you, and since we've been talking about science, we'll just continue and start with the science updates that we have for you.
So, the second operational CAS test is going to launch on January 14th.
So, it's never ending.
We don't get a break.
So, January 14th.
We have refreshed our training and practice tests, and those are available now, so students, parents, guardians, educators can all go online.
They can use our training tests to become familiar with the different item types that we have on our test, and they can use the practice tests to really review more of the depth and breadth that we have represented on the test as a whole.
So now a little bit of an update on our English language proficiency assessments for California, or ELPAC.
I'm really trying to get out of using acronyms so much.
So as you know, the computer-based ELPAC field test has been going on.
It's in its final week, and hopefully it will end this Friday.
I want to extend a huge thank you to the 370 LEAs that volunteered to participate.
I know there were others that wanted to participate, but with some of the power outages, they were unable to do so.
So thank you for the 370 that were able to participate.
So, just as a reminder, the purpose of the field test was to collect item level statistics on our science items as we prepare for the, not our science test, sorry, did I say that?
On our LPAC.
On our operational LPAC that begins on February 1st.
So a post-test survey was sent out to all of them who participated, or will be sent out since we've extended the timeline, to all that participated.
We're gonna collect feedback about the administration of the computer-based test.
We will use that feedback to determine improvements that need to be made to the administration materials, as well as future administrations of our computer-based test.
A summary of the post-test survey will be provided to this board.
We anticipate that to happen in February.
We are also still in the process of collecting data for the comparability study.
I know that Cindy mentioned the comparability study in her presentation a moment ago.
Part of the data collection during the comparability study is information on mode effects between test items administered on a computer and test items administered in a paper version.
That work is being done to ensure that scores across those two modes are comparable.
The comparability study report, we anticipate we'll be able to provide that to the board in spring of 2020.
We are also in the process of conducting two LPAC studies.
The first is an accessibility pilot and the second is a cognitive lab study.
The purpose of the accessibility study is to try out accessibility resources, ensure they are working the way that we intend them to work for our students.
The accessibility pilot is open to any English learner who would require any accessibility resource during testing.
The cognitive lab study is a little different.
It's going to focus specifically on English learners who have a visual impairment or are deaf and hard of hearing.
So we will collect that information.
Of course, we are always dedicated to continuous improvement and enhancements of our assessments in California, as well as the accessibility resources that we provide as part of those assessments.
In August of 2020, we expect to be able to provide the board with some summary reports on those two special studies that ETS is doing on our behalf.
Now, if I can navigate a video and speak, I'm going to share with you a new tool that we have available to our districts, our schools, and our teachers here in California.
And this is based off of conversations that we had with this board about the transition to computer-based.
So one of the key outcomes that we had on the usability pilot study last spring was to develop what we're referring to as the technology readiness checker for students.
The intent of this optional tool is to provide our educators with a means to check students familiarity with device navigation skills.
Those might be dragging and dropping, scrolling, expanding, minimizing screens, windows, those types of skills that our students use on our various assessments.
So the tool represents the student device interactions that we have on our computer-based LPAC.
So it is specific to LPAC, but that being said, we have shared this tool and demoed this tool for several audiences now, including AXI, as well as our CASP stakeholder group that includes representatives from CTA, CFT, AXA, CSBA, Charter School Administration, CSTA, I said that, I'm sure I missed some.
And in all of those conversations, we have heard excitement about using this tool for all students, not necessarily just students who would be participating in ELPAC.
So in developing the tool, though, since it was for ELPAC, ETS wanted to make sure that, one, it was engaging for our students.
They wanted it to be game-like.
They wanted
it to create a storyboard for students.
We thought that might be engaging for them.
And intentionally, we also did not include text or speech in the tool.
So there will be no sound.
So now let me start the demonstration.
And it's a video that I'll just run through here.
And the video that's running through is on the website that is linked from this PowerPoint.
As you can see, the tool begins by selecting the grade, next student information, and teacher emails entered, so the teacher can receive a student report at the end of the session.
It's going faster than I am.
It's important to note that none of the student or teacher information is stored.
So we're not collecting this for use by us.
It is purely for local use.
So it does disappear once it's done, but teachers will receive a report in their email that they can use.
So the tool begins by showing how to select a panel and drag and drop a background.
So you can see here this background is
the ocean, I think.
And so next, if I let it, ooh, that is not what it was supposed to do.
So let it go through that for a second.
So after you select the background, which in this case was the ocean, and you saw a different background, which was the sky, you then select a character to be a part of your story or your storyboard.
And then you can drag that character onto the background.
So you can see here all kinds of different backgrounds that students have to pick from.
And you can see that they are engaging in navigation skills, right?
did a drag and drop, they just expanded that screen to view things.
Next, we wanna make sure that they have fun things to do, so you can see accessories that they can put on their characters, right?
So, sunglasses, I think there's ice cream in there, I don't know why, but of course I remember the ice cream.
And then, what you see here is a demonstration of students have the ability to use the record function,
to mimic what is done on our test.
For some students, we are asking them to record so that we have some read-behinds, but they're oral speech-behinds, if you will, to ensure that we have
appropriate local scoring happening.
So you can see they also can, which is fun for our students, hit the record button and tell you a story that goes along with the storyboard that they have just created there.
And then they can play that back.
So once the student does that, then you get what we're referring to as the student progress dashboard.
And by the way, I've told them it can't be called the dashboard.
We have to change that name.
So sorry, it will be changed.
OK.
So the teacher will get this.
set of information in an email that goes back to them.
So if you look at this report, you can see how many times the student was able to demonstrate each of the skills.
And they're the things I talked about, scrolling, selecting, and answer.
They're not really answers, but it mimics that.
So if you looked at this screen right now, you can see that the student can demonstrate scrolling, but they did not demonstrate that they know how to expand or minimize.
And you can see that from this information.
So this is where we are right now.
And currently, our LEAs are participating in our field test of our computer-based LPAC.
And so we'll be asking them for feedback.
on this tool so that we can gather that feedback and have conversations to determine what guidance we should provide our educators for selecting our supports for students.
So you might recall, in terms of our last action we had before this board, there are two technology supports that can be used for students.
So if you saw this student, you might think they need a support, or you might actually sit down with them and say,
show me how you expand a screen, right?
Or you might just look at this and decide they need a support.
So first is the technology navigation assistant.
This is a trained test examiner that can support student navigation in the test delivery platform.
It's considered a universal tool.
In other words, any student can have it.
You don't need any kind of label associated with you to get this.
These types of support provided may include showing a student how to move the mouse, how to scroll.
If they get stuck and you just need to go and do small amounts of interactions with your student, that might be appropriate.
The second is a designated interface assistant.
So these are students who need more help, right?
So we have a tiered approach for students who may need more help.
So this is, again, a training test examiner.
And in this case, the examiner enters all the responses for the student.
So the student does not need to engage and have proficiency in navigation skills
In order to take the computer-based LPAC, they could be assigned a designated interface assistant.
That is considered a designated support.
So again, that is available for any student.
You don't need to have a label.
You do need an adult to select that for you in terms of our accessibility designations.
So, I'm gonna stop there, I'm gonna pause there, I'm gonna look for the tissue box, and then I'm gonna answer any clarifying questions that you have.
So, okay, so, okay?
Yeah.
Pass the box around.
Allergies, sorry.
No, I know.
All right, so there's just clarifying questions on LPEC, that's all we're talking about, and I know, Felicia, you went, did you go to this standard setting or the Spanish assessment standard setting?
Oh, yes, you did.
Okay, so again, we're not done with the item.
We're just trying to clarify this part, and then we have a little bit more, and then we'll go to comments and discussion.
I got more.
Because Patricia told me I could have some time.
Mega item, right?
Okay, President Darling-Hammond.
First of all, I'm really excited to see this.
It was a great, I think, innovation and I agree with the folks who think we might want to be able to use it beyond this LPEC.
I'm wondering, so how do you then guide the districts when they get the profile on the student like the one we got?
What would they then decide to do or how would you help guide them?
So we started having those conversations thinking that we could create that guidance.
And then I paused and suggested we not do that right now.
I would rather, I feel more comfortable using the information from our educators and having conversations with those educators that were involved in the field test so that we can have a document developed that would provide the guidance.
So we have every intent to do that.
But I would feel more comfortable talking to our teachers before developing it.
Some of the people using it will be assembled to help begin with the guidance.
Yes.
Member Ortiz-Lincoln.
I also had a similar thought.
I thought, well, would a teacher know what would trigger sort of the need to use it?
And then when I was looking at the check marks, I thought, well, is it, if you're above three, then, you know, you could do this.
So I do think that there's gonna be some tighter guidance needed, but I'm also wondering, once a school system or a district in a school, once they have the information, will they have the capacity to assign somebody?
to say, hey, we know that Jose or whomever needs that one-on-one.
Somebody needs to administer this assessment.
So is there going to be a feedback loop where that, those reflections, first year administering a computer-based assessment, when is that gonna happen so that we know what we're looking at?
Is it a function of support, technology, or skillset?
Absolutely, every year after our testing we do a post-test survey and so I know that ETS behind me is listening to your remarks so we will make sure that we include questions that address your concern in the post-test survey this year.
Member Sanghez-Lazon, do you have any comments?
I just, we had some questions around the technology piece of it and I just want to just commend you guys for doing such a great job.
Member Rucker?
Well, Michelle, one of the questions I always ask you every year when you do the report on the assessments itself is what kind of information do you have from the field about the use of the accessibility tools?
And so I hope that as you're building out the guidance, especially for the implementation of this, that we have some way in that feedback loop of also collecting summative data about how the accessibility tools were used by how many students
in how many different districts because I still have a concern even when the guidance is well written that there's still an underutilization of the tools for the students it was intended for.
So I think having the data about who's using it and where will give us some better information about how to clarify that utilization.
And by the way, I didn't get that information from you this year about this year's state assessment.
So I think that it's a continuing conversation for us because it continues to be a problem of confusion in the field already with the accessibility tools and who can use them.
And it's still my concern that they remain underutilized.
And so going then to this new computer-based assessment, because for the same reasons that districts are not making the accessibility tools available to all students as they should, we may see the same kind of thing happening as we go to this computer-based assessment as well.
So you are absolutely correct that I thought I would come to this board providing you with data on the use instead of the assignment.
And I had every intention to do that.
In reality, what happened was we did receive a data file.
So imagine a data file for millions of students for every single item, whether or not they used each accessibility support.
It was a small number that we were taking on year one, right?
And so we received that, and there were obvious questions that we had about the criteria that were used to set up that data file.
And those questions are outstanding.
They are questions we've submitted to AIR.
I've also requested that AIR, I believe,
Stephanie Gregson was in one of her first meetings when we had a very honest conversation with them about how this is a priority in California and asked them to fulfill their commitment to helping California understand that data set.
They have not done that.
And so we are continuing to do that and we are continuing also our conversations with the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium.
so that maybe multiple states can come together to try and figure out how we analyze this data.
We're also working with University of Minnesota, correct?
Yes, University of Minnesota, in terms of looking at that data set and how you would take that massive amount of information and visualize it in a way that we could actually interpret it and understand.
So we have also created that partnership.
So it is still something that we are working on, but you are correct.
I have not provided it to the board yet.
Okay, and I wasn't bringing it up to say I got you.
I just want to, you know, that's something I've been continued asking about and it is a concern.
I do want to take, having said that because that did seem like a ding, I do want to make sure I also compliment though the technicians and the technical staff from Smarter Balanced because they've met with me personally and with a lot of stakeholders to look at the current guidance they wrote and they have redrafted the guidance to give more clarity to districts about
the intent of the use of the accessibility tools and clarifying that just because a student used any of those accessibility tools, it doesn't change the status of how information about that student's performance is going to change or be reported in a different way.
So we can learn a lot about how that guidance was developed in creating this guidance also for the LPAC.
Thank you.
So thank you, Michelle.
Do you have a few more things?
Right?
I do.
I know.
And then we'll do the recommendation.
I do have a few more things.
Okay.
Go ahead.
So I'm excited to report that we held our first California assessment conference.
It was designed for our classroom educators in California.
I'm going to play a short video in a moment, but I want to share some details first.
So highlights from the conference include an opening keynote from Rosie Reed.
She's the 2019 California Teacher of the Year.
She spoke about her use of standardized test data to monitor her student progress.
We had a panel discussion from our contest finalists from Sciences Elementary.
They shared their use of formative assessment tools to engage students in the study of science phenomena in elementary grades.
We had a keynote address from renowned literacy scholar, Dr. Doug Fisher, who explained the importance of assessment-capable students and shared examples of students clearly in charge of their own learning.
Of course, the conference also held many other sessions on using assessments to support our student learning.
The evaluation survey is still out because we just had this conference, but we've already heard very positive feedback.
So we've already started planning for year two of the conference, which will be held in Riverside.
So let me, I get to toot my horn a little bit and.
It's great to see some schools really share how they've gone far in this journey, really collecting data, looking at students' work.
We've been able to see some best practices, and we hope to take this back to our district and help our students learn.
And I'm learning the most at this conference from colleagues at other schools.
Teacher leaders this morning really opened my mind to how to integrate these tools authentically into classroom instruction so they are the most useful for teachers and the most authentic for students.
I think absolutely as a participant it was great to listen to the conversations that were generated based on the presentations, the aha moments from educators and recognizing how they can incorporate this learning into their daily practice to make the whole learning process more meaningful so that when the assessment piece comes into play it is just part of their norm.
part of what students are used to for their expectations and they're really addressing how to remove barriers for kids.
And one of the great things about this conference is the focus was on how do we actually use the resources that have been made available in the Smarter Balance system and from CDE to really support teachers in the classroom, to make a difference for teachers and students.
Because ultimately that's what it's about, helping students achieve and succeed.
Those were our science teachers, I think.
They were very excited contest winners.
We did have some donations that allowed us to provide each of our science contest winners with $1,000 each.
They were very happy.
There may have been tears, even.
It was sad, but I was happy that we were able to acknowledge them.
But what was sad is they felt like, as elementary school teachers, they don't get recognized for their content knowledge very often.
And so to be recognized for science was very meaningful for them.
So next, I'm going to invite up one of my staff.
My staff don't get to come up and share with you their great work very often.
And Patricia's already excited.
I can see that.
So the new web tool released by Smarter Balanced is called the Smarter Content Explorer.
No one knows it better than Member Rucker, because she was up until 3 a.m.
looking at it.
So this tool helps educators to better understand the expectations of students on the Smarter Balanced summative and interim assessments, and really to bridge the gap between the language of the test developers and the language that teachers use in the classroom every single day.
It combines the information in the Smarter Balanced content and item specifications, which are incredibly lengthy documents,
and dull, OK, but very important documents, which are key resources that our test and item development experts have used.
And it does this to create an easy to use search interface for our classroom teachers.
So now.
Yes, we did this because member Recker asked us to do this.
So now I want to bring up Rebecca Bauer.
She's an education programs consultant in my division.
And she's going to go ahead and actually demo the site.
And that is not the site.
There you go.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm here, like Michelle said, to share this wonderful resource that we have.
I'm Rebecca Bowers, and I'm an Education Programs Consultant in the Assessment Development and Administration Division.
And prior to coming to the CDE, I was in the classroom as a classroom teacher for 10 years.
I was an English Language Arts, or ELA, teacher, primarily at the middle school level.
So eighth graders, I couldn't get enough of them, I guess.
So, as a teacher, I know I went through, you know, I administered the CSTs and then I administered the SBAC or Smarter Balanced assessments, and I've seen the changes.
I was also department chair, lead teacher, and I worked with teachers on how to use these resources.
And so a lot of times you're given resources, but they're like, you know, the item and content specifications.
What do teachers do with them?
How do they access them?
And, you know, you're downloading zip files that are crazy and, like Michelle said, very lengthy and technical.
So I'm very excited about this application, which I did work on with Smarter Balanced and their member states.
And so as you can see here, this is the landing page, and basically it really does help bridge the gap between the language of test developers and the language used in the classroom, whether it be by teachers or even by students.
So I'll start with...
Let's see, so on the landing page, you can see you have a nice welcome screen, and then also you can dive in and start filtering by the grade level, subject area, claim, and even target and standard.
So if teachers are not familiar with targets, and they're more familiar with Common Core State Standards, which is something I was more familiar with, this definitely helps bridge that gap.
And so as you can see here, this is the Explore tool.
They also have the Search tool, which I'll show you here, which you can actually type in a topic and then start filtering that way.
The Test Development page is very lengthy, but it has a lot of things like blueprints, scoring guidelines, construct relevant vocabulary, a lot of tools or documents that are spread throughout the SmarterBalanced.org site.
But the two primary features that I'm going to share with you are the explore feature and then the search feature here.
So we can get to the explore feature in two different ways.
One is up here on the top and one is right in front of us, right here on the landing page.
And since I was an ELA teacher, I'm going to search for ELA.
But I'll start with grade six.
and scroll down, select a subject, ELA, and the claim.
I'm going to choose Claim 4, which is Researcher Inquiry, because it'll give us the most options here.
And if teachers are not, uh-oh, if teachers are not familiar with what a claim is or a target is, they have these information icons throughout the website.
So they can click on the claim, and it pulls up the math and ELA claims right there for them.
The same is true, yes, I'm excited about that.
The same is true for target and standards.
So if you were like me and more comfortable with standards, you can click and easily select your standards here, which teachers do actually know what all these standards are.
But if you want to start challenging yourself and thinking about the test developers and start reading all these documents that have been available to teachers, you can select a target.
And I'll select Target 2.
And the related standards pop up below.
So again, you're starting to bridge that gap.
And it does it for if you select two targets, et cetera.
But I'm going to focus on Target 2 and click Results.
And then you get this nice resource card here.
And so the resource card has everything that we preselected.
And then I'll click More.
And since this is basically filtered for the content I've selected, you'll see the resource card on the right.
And then on the left, it'll have Target 2, Target 4, 2, 3, and 4.
So you start seeing that progression on the left.
Also, for teachers that are selecting materials that may be on a topic they're studying in class, if they want to understand or choose stimuli that is more relevant to something they're teaching, it does give explanations about what types of stimuli to select as well.
One of the key features that I really like is the sample items button.
And so instead of pulling up the sample items website on the SmarterBalanced.org site and filtering all this content, it's already filtered for you.
So if I click on sample items, we jump out.
It pulls it up in a new browser or a new page.
So if you're like me and you exit out and then you lose your site, you have to remember the millions of sites you're looking at, it doesn't do that.
So it's on a new window.
And it's already pre-filtered for you with everything we've selected.
And when you select the card, it goes right into that test item from the sample items website.
So this is great because you can pull it up, show it to the class.
Maybe students aren't familiar with why does this word have dots above and below?
Well, that is an item that has the glossary term there for you.
Also, I had students, I remember with the transition to the Smarter Balanced assessments, I remember they were hovering over and not quite sure, why is this highlighting and why is it not?
This is great practice for them.
And we have many resources that do this, but again, this is right here, easy to access.
And if I exit out of that.
If I scroll down, you'll see that the hover text or the hover bar above will stay with you as you scroll down the page.
And basically it organizes everything that you're gonna see.
So the overview is at the top.
We have all the standards that are associated there.
The depth of knowledge levels, and since this is a research, since we looked at claim four, it's gonna have many different depth of knowledge levels listed.
Evidence required is one of my favorites because what are students expected to do?
I want it plain and simple as a teacher.
Well here they're expected to analyze information, integrate it while avoiding plagiarism.
So I'm not boggled down with all these different documents.
It's very short and sweet.
The accessibility is great as well because it's catered to that specific criteria that we filtered.
So as you can see here, items that are students with physical impairments, they may need to use an adapted mouse for these types of items or a computer with eye scanning capabilities.
So again, you don't have to go through all those documents.
It's right here for you.
If you do wanna go through those documents though, you can click more and you'll be taken to the Smarter Balanced website where they're all housed there as well.
The stimuli here, again, if teachers want to select different types of passages, it gives you guidelines such as no more than 225 words at the middle school grade level, could be a diary entry, and so forth.
Task models are something that's also very powerful.
If you want to know what does it take to write an item that is filtered in this way, then there are four different examples for you here.
And if I scroll down, you can see the different alignment, how do test developers create distractors and rationales, the rationale for them.
And then this is one of my favorite, are the item stems.
So how is this type of question asked on the assessment?
They give you an item stem right here.
And there's one for that one, but if you go on task model, any of the others, I'll choose seven.
Scroll down and you have four item stems right there.
So again, it's very easy to access and filter.
And if I scroll back to the top, another great function, and this is new.
This function was just added a couple weeks ago, and this whole resource was just released two months ago.
Then I can click on the download PDF functionality, and I can actually create a customized report based on all of this material that I've selected.
So if I don't want to know
Maybe the depth of knowledge, I'm already familiar with that, but I'm really interested in sharing with my PLC the Task Model 4.
I can select that and it'll generate and download a customized PDF for that right away.
The other functionality I was going to share is the
search functionality and this is great.
It looks like I've searched on this computer before because I usually search for theme.
Theme is something I taught a lot as an 8th grade ELA teacher.
If I click on theme and search, you can see there are 12 results now because it's not
catered to the specific grade level.
Now I'm searching all grade levels for theme, and as I scroll down you'll see there's two cards for four, grade five, etc.
So you can go to your grade level, choose the card, and you'll be confronted with all that information as well.
And just because I love this resource, I'm going to try to keep it short.
But if I go to test development, there are many other resources that are here.
So again, the primary focus is those, you know, dive in and search for that content.
However, as a teacher, I really want to know where are the blueprints, you know, where am I going to find all this stuff, the CDE site, you know, CASP.org or Smarter Balanced.
Well, again, it's all here.
So I have blueprints, interim assessment information for the blueprints, and the overview document, one of my favorites.
Bias and sensitivity, because test developers think about all this when creating items.
And as a teacher, I want to know.
I want to know what's going into it.
I have rubrics, which was my go-to all the time.
Construct relevant vocabulary.
Are they saying central idea or main idea?
What type of terminology is used, et cetera.
Content specifications are all there as well.
And the last bit of information is the support.
If I'm a teacher and I don't know what a task model is, they have that information provided here.
So then, again, that helps bridge that gap between the languages test developers and the language used in the classroom.
So if I were still in the classroom, this is definitely something I would have used.
So thank you very much.
And are there any clarifying questions?
So I am so lucky to have staff like Becky, as well as so many other staff in my division, many of which were classroom teachers.
So that's important to know.
Yes, we reach out to classroom teachers all the time in our work, but we are also lucky to have so many in-house teachers that help us really think about things from that perspective when we're looking at our development.
So I do want to go back to the slides.
I was going to pause here for any questions, but that is the last pause and the last topic.
And then I'm going to put up your motion so you can have it on the screen.
So any questions?
So the Content Explorer application that you just shared with us is live on the Smarter Balanced website or on the CDE website?
It's on the Smarter Balanced website and on the CDE site, and it's on our Smarter Balanced resources webpage.
So it's kind of buried a little bit.
That's the reason why I asked the question, because I went looking for it.
I'm hooked on it now.
Couldn't find it.
So if there's a way, you know, most students, you know, they get bored looking for things if it takes more than three clicks.
Teachers have, don't have as much time to use even three clicks if there's a way to make it more prominently displayed both on the Smarter Balanced website.
and on the department website, even if it's featured as one of your pop-ups on your landing page.
I think that that would be important because this is an important new resource that teachers really do need to have.
When Michelle sent me the preview and she told me I could share it with a lot of educators,
you know, when you took down that little preview, now they're, you know, bugging me like on the hour.
Where is it?
It's like they're hooked on crack.
So, it would be nice.
Yeah, it would be nice to be able to tell them how to find it in an easy way.
And that makes me think that Member Rucker is not following our Twitter feed, but besides that.
Yeah.
So that's a good point.
We'll take that back.
I also think it would be good for us to work with ETS, because many of our educators, I know it's hard to believe, don't go to the department's website.
They actually go to the ETS website.
So we'll go ahead and make sure we have a link from there also.
Ortiz-Lacon?
So I send this to my husband right away.
And I tell him, Christmas came early.
Yes.
And I know that why I have the California standards on an app.
I don't know.
I don't teach, but it's there.
And I also have the data dashboard.
Is this going to become an app as well?
Just so that I could absorb all my storage space?
Yes.
We will.
So just to be clear, this was developed by the consortium.
So this is not an ETS product.
But I'm happy to take that feedback back to them.
there any more board questions or clarifications it's just so funny because I also just shared link with people at my school so so we have a recommendation from the CD staff now that was the that's part of this item I believe we have some public comments am i right
We have two people for public comment, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz and Cameron King.
Please line up.
Good afternoon, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
My comments are specific to the LPAC.
We greatly appreciate the two studies being conducted on the computer-based LPAC administration and we also appreciate the steps taken by CDE to involve educators
on the LPAC transition review panel to review the results of the comparability study and LPAC items used in the mode comparability study.
We look forward to being able to discuss the results and implications of these studies as well as the results of the comparability study with CDE staff.
Lastly, I appreciate the interest expressed by some of the state board members on the use of accessibility tools by our students because it is important to know the extent as to whether they are being used or not being used by our students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Cameron King with the California Science Teachers Association.
I just wanted to take this opportunity to publicly reiterate our comments that were submitted previously and express our appreciation to the State Board and to CDE for your commitment to science education, high quality science education, and to the assessment staff for their commitment to incorporating educators in the process of evaluating and implementing these assessment tools.
We stand ready to continue to be partners and collaborators with CDE and with the department staff, as well as with each and every one of you, as we continue to implement the California NGSS standards, assess those, and evaluate the amendments that may need to be made accordingly.
So thank you so much for the opportunity and your commitment to science education in the state.
Thank you for our comments.
So we'll come back now.
We have a recommendation to approve the proposed CAS threshold scores beginning with 18-19 administration as shown in the attachment to this item.
So do I have a motion?
I would move the staff's recommendation.
Do I have a second?
Felicia Ortiz-Lacon, second.
Any discussion or comments on the item?
So all those in favor, say aye.
Raise your hand.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Okay, that was passed unanimously.
Thank you.
Okay, so now we will move to item number seven.
Thank you so much for getting us through all the items in between.
Item 7 is, guess what?
Another assessment item.
By the way, I just thought it was delightful to see all those teachers so happy about assessment.
I know!
I tell people that I strive to make assessment fun and they laugh at me.
But we truly do.
We're laughing with you.
Assessment stuff is another assessment item.
We're getting the release of up to 10% withheld for the 2018-19 regions of the University of California contract.
Take it away.
So the item before you is an action item.
I do not have a PowerPoint with this.
You just have to look at me, so sorry.
But the CDE asked the board to release the full amount of $13,769.26 of funds withheld from the UC Santa Cruz regents contract.
There were no contract deficiency that would warrant any withholding of funds.
So as a short little bit of background on this item, because this is the first time I've ever come to this board with a 10% release item for UC Santa Cruz.
You are all familiar with the fact that I come every year with a similar item for ETS, but not for UC Santa Cruz.
So the contract with UC Santa Cruz includes two components.
The first component is the Smarter Balanced membership fees.
The Smarter Balanced membership fee portion of the contract is not subject to the 10% withhold and release that is a normal part of what you see for our assessment vendor contract.
But the second component within that same contract is the expansion and customization of the California Educator Reporting System, also known as CSRS.
CSRS is not being paid for out of our membership fees, except for the CSRS component specific to Smarter Balanced.
So SIRS will eventually include summative and alternate English language proficiency assessments for California or LPAC.
It will also include Smarter Balanced assessments as well as the non-Smarter Balanced CASP assessments.
So those include our science test, our Spanish assessment, our alternate assessments in English language arts, math and science.
So eventually, over time, SURGE will allow educators to view student results from CASP, from LPAC, in a single one-stop shop for them to see results.
So it is the development of SURGE within the contract that is subject to the 10% withhold.
In order to engage in this expansion and pay for this project, you may recall that when this board actually acted on this contract to customize and add CSRS,
We used a one-time credit of $390,000 that we had in order to pay for some of the work in year one.
So that is why you see these costs slightly lower than what you would think it would cost us to do this work is because we had a one-time credit because there was an increase in consortium membership revenue that allowed us to have a one-time credit in year 18-19.
So the credits were used to offset the year one costs, which was a planned use of those funds.
That one-time membership credit is not a permanent reduction.
So we are paying for the expansion of CSRS for the rest of the years.
You may recall we actually cut some money out of our other contract in order to put it into the UC Santa Cruz contract to pay for this.
So in this contract, only tasks one, two, and four are subject to the 10% withhold.
One includes activities for the development of SERS for summative and alternate LPAC.
Task two includes activities for the development of SERS for CASP that are not Smarter Balanced.
And task four are all the other activities related to contract oversight, management meetings, schedules, communications, and that type of work.
So in summary, I'm asking that this board approved that the funds be released for the UC Santa Cruz Regents Contract for work that has been completed to our satisfaction Okay Tingson our assessment liaison.
Do you have any comments on this item?
No, I think we've heard about this item a little bit before in the past as well.
And this is Pretty standard I think at this point.
Yeah, I
Great.
And is there any clarifying questions?
It's a pretty clear presentation.
Any public comment?
All right.
Hearing none, do I have a motion?
I'll move the item.
thank you second thank you any further discussion all right all those in favor say aye any opposed nay any abstentions motion carries thank you Michelle you get to sit down we appreciate you
We're moving on you guys have wonderful stamina and we're just going to keep plowing ahead Item 8 is the public hearing regarding the bay point preparatory academy san diego We have a consideration of a material revision of the charter to change admission preferences
The CDE recommends and proposes to recommend that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the request for the material revision of the BPA San Diego petition to amend element 8 admission requirements for the remainder of the five-year term of July 1st 2008 through June 30th 2023 under the oversight of the SBE based on the CDE's findings.
And so I'm going to let Lisa Constancio of the CDE present the item.
Good afternoon.
Is this one working?
Yes?
We're good?
Okay.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I need to open the public hearing.
Not yet.
After that, okay?
Yeah, you will in just a little bit.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Lisa Constancio with the Charter Schools Division here to present item number eight for Bay Point Preparatory Academy.
This is a request for a material revision.
During the term of a charter, the school may request an amendment to its current approved charter.
Material revisions are governed under Education Code 47605, and what that means is that on top of looking at the request for material revision, we also look at the petition again, we take a look at their fiscal viability again, and then we also take a look at their charter elements again to make sure they're reasonably comprehensive.
So we do a comprehensive look again on top of the request for material revision.
Material revisions to a currently approved petition may only be with the approval of the authority and in this case with the State Board of Education that granted the charter.
A little bit of background on Baypoint.
Baypoint Preparatory Academy in San Diego was approved by the State Board in March of 2018.
It's a TK through grade 8 school and they're approved for a five-year term from July 1, 2018 through June 30th of 2023.
They're currently in their second year of operation serving 159 students.
Currently at a temporary facility at the Boys and Girls Club and they are planning to move to a permanent facility in San Marcos in January of 2020 within the San Marcos Unified School District.
July 29, 2019, CDE received a request for material revision from Baypoint to amend Element 8, the admission requirements.
The admission preferences would need to be revised in order for the school to maintain their eligibility in the Charter School Facility Grant Program, previously known as Senate Bill 740, which is for grant and lease costs for charter schools.
The grant amount we're talking about here is about $88,000 to the charter school.
And if the material revision request is not approved by the board today, the school will continue to operate but without access to this grant.
So they just wouldn't have access to this additional $88,000.
The CDE recommendation is the state board hold a public hearing to approve the request from Bay Point San Diego for a material revision for their admission requirements.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on October 8th, 2019.
The Advisory Commission moved staff recommendation to approve the request for a material revision.
The motion passed unanimously by a vote of six to zero with one commissioner not in attendance.
A little bit of background on the Charter School Facility Grant Program.
It is administered by the California State Treasurer, the California School Finance Authority.
There's currently $137 million for the fiscal year 19-20, and it provides annual reimbursement assistance with facility rent and lease expenditures to charter schools that meet the eligibility criteria.
Charter schools are awarded $1,184 per unit of classroom ADA, and that is up to 75%, so it doesn't cover 100%, it covers up to 75% of their annual facility rent and lease costs for the school.
And according to CSFA, the program is currently not projected to be oversubscribed for those that are applying for lease costs only, which is what Baypoint is applying for.
In order to be eligible for the program, you have to have an approved charter on file.
It needs to be a classroom-based school.
The school must meet one of two low-income priority provisions.
The first is that at least 55% of the students at the school meet the free and reduced-price meal criteria,
or they're located in an attendance area of an elementary school that has at least 55% free and reduced price meals.
So in order to meet the second prong here, number two, there does need to be a preference in admissions to qualify and to allow the students that are in that general area or in that local elementary school to have first priority.
So that does need to be included in the admission preferences, which is why the school is before you today.
Currently, they are at 48% free and reduced price meals, so they don't meet that first prong because the school itself does not have 55%.
So they are requesting to come before the board for this material revision so they can qualify under the second criteria, which would be to be located in an attendance area of an elementary school that has at least the 55% free and reduced price meals.
So the petition will include, and we have verified this, a preference for pupils who are currently enrolled in or who reside in the elementary school district, in this case it's San Marcos Unified, of the public elementary school, San Marcos Elementary School, in which Bay Point is located.
As I mentioned earlier, as part of the material revision, CDE does do a full review.
We've taken a look at the petition again.
Even though it only been about a year and a half, we take a look at the educational program, we take a look at their multi-year budget for their fiscal viability, and then we look again at the charter elements that are in the petition.
Based on our review, the projected budget indicates that the school is projected to have a positive ending fund balance of about $276,000.
They are over their reserves right now.
Currently, we recommend a 5% reserve in our MOU with them.
They do also have positive ending fund balances out for the next two fiscal years as well.
Now, the monthly rent for the new facility is going up from $6,600 a month, which is what they're paying now at the Boys and Girls Club, to $31,000 a month.
So it is going up from $6,600 a month for the Boys and Girls Club to $31,000 a month with this new facility.
Facilities are expensive.
Yeah, $31,000 a month.
So over a nine-month period, the cost to lease the facility, the new facility, is about $279,000 compared to about $59,000 that they're paying now with the Boys and Girls Club.
So this grant would substantially help them with those additional facility costs.
In summary, CDE staff is recommending approval of the material revision in order to allow the school to meet the eligibility criteria for this grant and allow them to revise their admission preferences.
And again, we did a re-review of each of their elements to ensure their fiscal viability, their educational program, and their comprehensive description of their charter elements.
So that's all I have.
Are there any questions I can answer for you at this time?
The school is here also and will be giving their presentation as well.
Now we want to open the public hearing.
Yes.
how they meet all the other criteria and how they don't meet the specific criteria about the current enrollment and you explain that the purpose of the hearing is to approve this material revision on their enrollment criteria.
The one thing that you didn't, I didn't hear in your analysis is whether or not this material revision will actually result in a net increase in the number of low-income students that actually enroll
at the charter school.
So I want to understand why I didn't hear that in your analysis.
And again, if that's not a question I should be asking now, I'm willing to wait for that answer till later.
I think it would be good to hear the presentation from the school and then if we still have the question, we can talk more after that.
So I hereby open the public hearing at 3 10 p.m.
First we'll hear from the petitioners the petitioners have 10 minutes then we'll hear from the county or districts that are opposing the material revision they will also have a total of 10 minutes after the presentations from both sides then there will be a opportunity for public comment from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each so the petitioner
Good afternoon board members and CDE staff.
My name is Nancy Spencer and I'm the executive director for Bay Point Preparatory Academy in San Diego.
I want to thank you for the opportunity to present on behalf of Bay Point San Diego's petition for the material revision, specifically element 8, admissions requirements.
As presented by the CDE staff, in 2018 the California School Finance Authority changed the requirements for qualifying for the SB 740 facility funds.
In order to receive these funds, CSFA required element 8 of the petition to include specific lottery language and guidelines.
Because Bay Point San Diego's petition was written in 2017, it did not have the CSFA required language in that element.
A change to that element requires a material revision based on our MOU with the State Board.
We are seeking this revision in order to qualify for these reimbursements that will allow us to spend more of our funds on educating our students.
I'd like to illustrate this through the next several slides.
In the fall of 2017, we began our facility search.
After an exhaustive search, our only option to open on time for the 2018-19 school year was to locate in a light industrial building formerly occupied by a non-classroom based charter school.
The city approved this location on the condition that Bay Point San Diego only operate there for one year as well as limit the number of students enrolled.
Despite the facility and city imposed challenges, we successfully completed our first year.
This facility was located in the La Mirada Academy boundaries, but it did not qualify for the FRPM elementary school criteria based on CDE data.
Last December, we began negotiating to lease the facility located at 520 East Carmel.
In June, a lease was signed and the city's required approval process began.
Because that process is not complete, we opened this school year in the San Marcos Boys and Girls Club adjacent to San Marcos Elementary School.
Again, the city has limited our enrollment numbers at this location.
Since our inception, our goal has been to serve the underserved students in the community.
Because the Carmel site is located in the San Marcos Elementary School boundary area, which currently serves a demographic population of more than 77% FRPM students, we meet the requirements for the SB 740 facility funds.
Despite our facility constraints, our FRPM has increased from 30 to 48% in just one year.
Relocating into this large facility allows us to serve more students and continue the growth.
Our plan, after meeting all of the city's change of use entitlement requirements, is to relocate in this permanent facility in January.
This data chart details the FRPM for both Bay Point San Diego and the two elementary schools whose boundaries we have been located in.
At the beginning of the school year we came close to reaching the same percentage of 49.9% that La Mirada held with our school now and our goal is to continue as you see on the blue there to continue to reach out as we now have room to expand on the two facilities.
The facility on
Linda Vista that we rented the first year was 9,000 square feet, and we paid 18,000 rent on it.
We were able to get into the Boys and Girls Club.
They gave us a deal, but they would only let us stay there, the city, for the rest of this year, and it's not large enough for expand.
We were limited on the enrollment as well, and so they cut us a deal with 6,000.
This new facility is 41,000 square feet, plus it has areas for playgrounds and outside activities.
So it's a much large facility that will accommodate the number of students that we presented in our petition as our growth over the five years of that petition.
I hope these slides have put a face to Bay Point, the students we serve, and the qualifying FRPM data.
We'd like to thank Lisa Constancio and the CSD for their thorough review, their ongoing support, as well as the CDE and the ACCS recommendation for approval.
So questions now or am I done and questions later?
Oh, okay.
I'm okay.
This will make it go faster too, the meeting will be over soon.
Do we have opposition presentation?
Okay.
We have two speakers for public comment.
Angela Doramos and Katlyn O'Halloran.
Catlin O'Halloran with the Charter Schools Development Center.
We support the CDE's recommendation and the ACCS unanimous recommendation.
We support the Bay Point Preparatory Academy's request for the material revision and we think that the $88,000 from the grant will help them with their increase in the facilities cost in particular in addition to just supporting their students and their growth.
Thank you.
Hi.
Angela DeRamos representing California Teachers Association.
We ask the state board to deny Bay Point's request for material revision.
The intent of the charter facilities grant is to provide funding for low income areas.
Despite being located in an area in which 80% of students are eligible for free and reduced lunch, Bay Point has been unable to recruit a student body that reflects the community in which it operates.
We ask instead that the school do the hard work of engaging in meaningful outreach So that the student population of their charter actually reflects the neighborhood in which it's located.
Thank you That's the end of public comment then
All right.
So, seeing no other public comment, I now close the public hearing for this item at 3.16 p.m.
and commence with board discussion and action.
And first, I'll ask Sue Burr, our liaison, if she has any initial comments.
I don't think I have to add anything.
I do think that I appreciate Lisa's presentation.
The department did a very thorough review.
I think this is fairly straightforward.
It seems like the school kind of got caught in the middle of an eligibility change on CSFA.
They've also had this transitional facility issue that they're trying to work out.
And the ACCS was unanimous in their approval.
And so when you're ready, I'm happy to move the recommendation to adopt the material revision.
Okay, I'll see if the board has any clarifying questions at this point and if any of those need to be directed to the petitioner, we can invite them back to the yes, member Rucker.
I'll direct my question to the petitioner that I originally asked.
I'm not, I don't really understand what is your recruitment plan to improve your enrollment of the students that are the target of your adjustment, your request?
As I mentioned before that we're limited in the number that we can Serve at the current Boys and Girls Club site and so we have people that are waiting to see when we're going to move into a new facility because we're pretty much maxed out there and What our plan to do then is to reach out to that area as I mentioned the Linda Vista site was in the La Mirada Academy or Alvin Dunn who's called before and
Area and then we're relocating into we found a facility that we could lease And so we're moving into that which is the san marcos elementary boundaries So then our goal is to go out and reach out to the neighborhoods We've got apartment buildings that are near the the new facility site as well as neighborhoods all around there that we want to reach out but we've had to limit it just because of our constraints on the number that the city would let us have to occupy the site and
And explaining in the Boys and Girls Club, I know you look at the numbers and go, wow, the difference in the price, $6,000 versus $31,000.
It's a smaller facility, obviously.
But the Boys and Girls Club will only let us operate during certain times in the day because they serve an after-school program for the elementary school district.
So we currently have to end school an hour early.
And then on Wednesdays, it's minimum day.
We still have over the minimum number of minutes required for all the grade levels.
But what that entails to is every day we have to set all the desks, tables, chairs out and then put them all back, put everything piled away so that the Boys and Girls Club can do their thing.
And the city is graciously letting us stay there until we get all of our conditional use permit stuff in the CEQA studies and things done.
So they've approved that for now.
Okay, again, I appreciate all the detail that you've given me on all the other things.
but I don't hear the detail about what your recruitment plan is.
Oh, okay.
So we mentioned we're going to go door-to-door, which we had started initially when we opened the school.
We've been on social media, we've been on Facebook, we've got parents involved with us.
We have an extremely active PAC Parent Advisory Committee.
We're really excited about it.
Four of the members have joined our board and we have others that are interested in participating in it.
So using them, we've done some fundraisers in the community.
It's exciting to see that the parents are behind it and supportive of the whole thing.
I applaud them and appreciate what they've done because we were in a small facility that had really no playground areas.
We had to use a parking lot, rope it off the first year, and then it's taken longer to get this facility approved.
So now that they're sitting there and supporting us, they're still there and they still want to help and do whatever they can to reach out.
Did you want to add something we have somebody so we've already demonstrated that effort in that did you tell us I'm sorry I'm Frank Aguero CEO of Bay Point Prep
This year alone we increased our enrollment from 80 students to 168 students.
We were able to, about 60% of those parents actually utilize the before and after school care program so we are directly serving the underserved community.
And our Hispanic population and African American population have increased substantially.
We went from, like was mentioned in the slide, 30 to 48% in our FRPM data.
So we're directly, we have direct success in that effort and we plan to continue to do so in the new facility.
We pushed very hard within two to three weeks right before the summer
Target the the demographic and try and mirror the school to our community schools given that we were stuck in that initial facility in year one I'll second the motion You're ready to second the motion, okay
This is just a clarifying question, I think more for Lisa.
The standard isn't, is the standard that in order to qualify for the facilities grant that they need to hit 55% enrollment or just open up and offer a preference?
It's procedural, it's not actually a numbers requirement.
It's procedural, correct.
Okay, any other clarifying questions?
Member Sun?
Go ahead.
Then I'm ready to make it.
I don't know if she did make it yet.
We'll officially make it.
We adopt the department's recommendation.
And I'll second that.
All right.
Any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed nay.
Any abstentions.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Lisa.
We are moving on to agenda item nine, and I see in my notes that we will be able to take a break after this item.
Hang in there.
We will now take item nine to consider the appointment of instructional materials reviewers for the 2020 Health Instructional Materials Adoption, and this item will be presented by Stephanie Gregson of CDE.
After this item, don't go yet, if you can manage it.
Be quick.
If you can manage it.
All right, I was going to say good morning, but it's good afternoon.
It's way into the afternoon.
So Stephanie Gregson, Deputy Superintendent of the Instruction and Measurement Branch, and I'm here with the newly appointed Director of the Curriculum, Frameworks, and Structural Resources Division, Shanine Coates.
Yes.
So we're going to share the presentation of this item because I'm training her to take over all of these items.
And so with this, let's see.
So for our new board members, just kind of give you context of where we're at in the process with health instructional materials.
So we started in March 2008 with the adoption of the health education content standards.
And once the standards are adopted by the State Board of Education, then we
work through developing a curriculum framework to align to the standards.
So the standards are the what, right?
It's what we want our students to know and be able to do.
The curriculum framework is the how.
It's the guidance to teachers and administrators on how to help students meet the standards.
And so in May of 2019, this year, we adopted the health education framework.
And within the framework is a chapter that outlines the criteria for instructional materials development.
And so with that criteria, publishers are then developing their curriculum that's aligned to the standards and aligned to the content of the framework.
And so now we are here in November 2020 to start the process of the health instructional materials adoption.
Great, thanks.
So the recruitment of reviewers took place from April 5th through August 15th, 2019.
And if you look on the slide, we're about right in the middle of this diagram here.
And that is the point where you may appoint instructional material reviewers and content review experts that are being recommended by the Instructional Quality Commission.
So, in January, looking forward, just to give you an idea of what's coming next, January 2020, the CDE will host the publisher's invitation to submit.
And this is where the statutory and regulatory requirements for participation in the adoption process will be explained.
And this is a public meeting where we will invite public comment as well.
And then in April, the commissioners with support from the curriculum frameworks and instructional resources staff will facilitate a training for all of our instructional material reviewers and our content review experts.
And that would be on the SPE adopted evaluation criteria.
On the final day of the training, our publishers have an opportunity to essentially present their specific programs and walk the reviewers through their materials prior to submitting them for review.
After the training, each reviewer receives the materials to be reviewed as well as any items necessary for review directly from the publishers.
This includes things like the workbooks,
small readers, or sometimes in the case of electronic resources, the appropriate device for viewing those materials.
After those materials have been delivered to the instructional material reviewers and the content review experts, they reconvene for deliberations, and that will happen in July of 2020.
So at the deliberations, the reviewers will rejoin their panels and discuss the findings of their individual reviews.
The IQC, the commission, will serve as facilitators to help the panels come to consensus on their recommendations.
They will write and submit to the commission a report, which is their panel report, to describe whether the materials met the requirements or not.
Again, there will be public meetings in this case as well.
So following the work on the panels, the IQC will conduct, again, public hearings, two of them, one in August, one in September, where they will also make their recommendations to the state board.
And over the entire process, the IQC will receive public comment in person and via the CDE email box.
So, and finally, you will receive the IQC recommendations and hold your own public hearing and take action on the program submitted for the 2020 instructional materials adoption.
All right, so what we're here today is to talk about the Instructional Material Reviewers.
So on April 5th, 2019, we began the application and recruitment process for Instructional Material Reviewers.
We had to extend it through August because we did not receive enough applicants, a large enough applicant pool.
So we did extend it through August and reached out to recruit more, and we did get more, thank goodness.
Woo-hoo!
And so...
So went through a process to look at our content review experts.
So all of our panels are required to have a content review expert.
A content review expert is an instructional material reviewer that has a doctorate in the related fields.
So they are there to provide their expertise on current research.
Then you have the instructional materials reviewers that, again, do the same review process as the content review experts, but they're coming from the lens of being a classroom teacher or an administrator.
And the majority of our panels need to have
K to 12 classroom teachers on them.
So those are the voices that are being heard during the review and deliberation process.
So are there any questions on the difference between instructional material reviewers and content review experts?
They do the same review process, they're sitting at the same table.
I just thought that would be important to share that they're not separated, they're part of the panel.
They're part of the panel, there's no difference except for the content review experts have a doctorate degree.
in the related field.
Must have.
Yeah, they must have.
So now, because Shanine's going to have to get used to this, when she gets turned over as the Executive Director of the Instructional Quality Commission, she'll get the recommendation.
But we have a question.
So the Ed Code refers to the instructional materials pertaining to kindergarten through eight, but the instructional materials will be made available for K-12, is that right?
So, well, the instructional materials that are submitted are for the grade levels of K-8 only.
So material, are you talking about the instructional material reviewers that can be K to 12 classroom teachers?
Yes, so as I'm looking through the list of requirements and where teachers come from, it's a very heavy, there's a lot of nine to 12 teachers, but they won't actually be reviewing materials that will go to high schools.
That's correct.
And the reason why it's heavy on 9 through 12 is that is where the single subject health credentials are mainly held.
That's where the single health courses are housed at.
They're in 7th through 12th grade.
You don't find a single health teacher in K to 6.
Okay, great.
So the instructional
review experts.
The California Department of Education recommends that the State Board of Education take the following action.
Appoint instructional material reviewers and content review experts as recommended by the Instructional Quality Commission.
Any questions?
Yeah, I'm gonna first ask member Ortiz-Lacona as our liaison if she has any comments and then I'll go to member Rucker and then we'll see if there are any other comments or questions.
I have no comments, but I am hearing some side conversation about the actual number.
Is this on average how many we recruit to serve as reviewers?
Are we over, under, right about the number that we typically have?
It's really based on the content area.
So English language arts, you're going to have a lot more publishers that are going to be submitting programs.
So we need a larger amount of reviewers.
Math the same way, science the same way.
We had the largest science adoption.
This is health.
It's a very finite.
topic and not a lot of publishers are creating health instruction materials to go through the adoption process.
So therefore we are kind of actually over planning with our reviewers to ensure that we're ready for five to eight submissions from publishers.
We don't expect that many.
I reviewed the list.
I think it's a lot more diverse than what we saw with the initial group of advisors.
This is help.
And so we will have to make sure that we follow this closely as the process unfolds and that there is obviously fluid and constant communication with the board so that
It is exactly what we had envisioned.
It adheres to the standards, the framework, but we also are very mindful of the materials that we're adopting.
So I'm glad that I get to follow my colleague on the board in asking this question.
So I recognize in approving your recommendation, what we're only approving is the list of reviewers.
But my question really relates to the training that you anticipate that the reviewers will be receiving.
We learned a lot from the adoption of the history social science material because there was a series of very controversial discussions and a long running dialogue about the content and the intent of the materials and the adoption.
And so we've learned a lot from that in preparing those trainers and there was a conversation to help those reviewers
in preparing to do the work of that adoption.
And so, as was already stated, this is health, and we are aware of what the controversy is about the content that many anticipate the materials will include.
And so, in looking at the list of reviewers, I'm very satisfied with who is chosen to step into this process and become involved, but I want to understand
for the training or the work that they will be given, how will that conversation be facilitated based on what we learned from what happened with the history social science reviewing process?
So we took what we learned from the history of social science adoption process, specifically around the Fair Education Act, and utilized that in our science adoption training to see if the clarity that we could provide helped the deliberation discussion when our reviewers came together.
And we found that it did.
So we are going to even do further clarity because it's not just around the Fair Education Act in this instance, it's around the health education standards themselves and the actual content of the framework versus what people perceive is within the framework.
So there will be a lot of clarity within our training.
We have the reviewers for a four-day training.
And they are trained by the commissioners and CDE staff so that we are able to ensure that they are fully understanding what their role and responsibility is in the review process.
We do have a lot of reviewers that come to this process thinking that they're going to be able to change the entire content of a textbook.
And so through our training process, we help them understand what their role is and what their role isn't.
And as a former reviewer, it's hard.
It's very difficult.
You spend hundreds of hours poring through these textbooks for alignment to the standards as a very first criteria and then looking for all of the other elements that are outlined in the framework chapter on the instructional materials development process.
So it is a rigorous process and our training is rigorous as well.
We've done a lot of changes since we've been learning with the history social science adoption.
So, I appreciate you bringing that up.
I just like to reinforce the strength of CIFR in the training.
They've really learned a lot.
It is so impressive to watch how the team takes the reviewers through the process and for the reviewers themselves, the personal commitment to going through the 4-day training, getting a pallet of materials delivered to their house.
going through all of it and then coming back to review it again.
It's really a commitment to the quality of materials we're going to provide to students.
I will agree with that.
I have sat through and participated in three of the four adoption trainings, and I did not sit in with the science adoption training, so I am looking forward to seeing what will happen with this as well.
And just to bring up one another area of sensitivity and it was came to mind Through board member Patio Bronson's comment around more health K. Sorry high school 912 educators that we want to make sure that for younger students that the material is sensitive to kindergarten and elementary so
Yes, absolutely.
And like I say, I'm just going to reiterate, the reason why you see so many upper grade teachers is because they're also experts in the health education content standards.
No, I understand that.
But we do have experts in early childhood as well.
We do.
We have that developmental appropriateness.
Yes.
Are there any other questions or comments at this point?
We're going to move to see if there's any public comment.
There is no public comment.
So do I have a motion?
It's been a long day.
I move the CDE's recommendation.
I'm so sorry.
All right.
We have a first and a second.
Is there any further discussion?
You guys are getting punchy now.
All in favor say aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
Motion passes.
You may take a 10-minute break.
It's time.
Go run around the building or something, you know, take some recess.
Okay.
I just want to let you know as we're reconvening that if we press on ahead we may finish by 5.
Little motivation there.
Well, don't change it yet.
Don't change it yet.
Well, this has been a very expeditious board.
I think Eileen, you must have really moved things forward when you were... Okay.
So we're going to move to our consent calendars at this point.
And we will take up the waiver consent items.
Waiver 01 through 04 and then 06 and 07.
Is there any public comment on waivers one through four?
No.
All right.
Then do I have a motion?
Member Sandoval, thank you.
Thank you.
Is there any further discussion?
Seeing none, all in favor say aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
And then I think now we're moving to numbers six and seven and member Rucker do you need to read on that or not?
No, okay, we're fine.
The one that got pulled was the one that you might have had to leave for, yeah.
Okay.
Just want to be sure that we're remembering all of those.
So is there any public comment on item six or seven?
No.
We'll be ready for you in a moment, Cindy.
I'm ready now.
I know.
No public comment.
So do I have a motion?
Thank you.
A second?
I'll second.
Member Sun, thank you.
Any discussion?
All right.
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
All right.
The motion carries.
So now we're going to take up the regular consent items, items 10 through 14.
Are there any public comments on items 10 through 14?
No.
All right.
I will now ask for a motion.
Okay.
Thank you.
Is there a second?
Second.
Thank you, Member Sandoval.
Any discussion?
All right.
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
All opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
And now we're going to go back to item 5, which we had moved to this point in the agenda.
So you'll be happy to know, Cindy, it is your turn to come to the podium with Barb, I guess.
This is the update on the development of the California State Plan for the Every Student Succeeds Act, technical amendments for inclusion in the state plan for resubmission to the U.S.
Department of Education.
Take it away.
while they find a replacement.
So today I will present, I'll open the item and then Barb is going to, Barb Richardson is going to talk about the educator equity and then I'll close it out with the increase of the goal for graduation rate.
So just
A little background, we're now three, four years into this law.
Obviously it's part of the reauthorization of the Elementary and Secondary Education Act.
I'm not going to go into it much further because we talk about this plan almost all the time.
So these are the topics we're going to cover today.
equity, and then long-term goal for graduation rate.
The Department of Education approved our plan over a year ago.
You took action a year ago to send amendments to the U.S.
Department of Education, and we have still not received official word whether or not they've accepted our amendments or approved our amendments.
So a year later, the submission is still pending.
We are on track to submit another round of amendments for everything that you've done this year, the actions you've taken around the accountability system, among other things.
You will get a high-level summary of that in an information memorandum in December.
And then in January, we're going to give you the plan and track changes.
So that is the bulk of it.
It's a very bulky item, but it'll just have whatever we've looked at for this year, assuming
we are still on track with our prior amendments that hopefully will be approved by then.
But that is the plan moving forward for the next two months.
So with that, I will turn it over to Barb.
Good afternoon, everyone.
President Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy Alcala, and board members, I'm Barb Murchison, Director of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division here at the Department of Education.
So, our SSA state plan requires that we describe how the state educational agency will evaluate and publicly report information regarding how low-income and minority children in schools supported by Title I funds are not served at disproportionate rates by ineffective, out-of-field, or inexperienced teachers.
Further, ESSA requires that LEAs applying for federal funds to describe how they will identify and address any disparities that result in low-income and minority students being taught at higher rates than other students by ineffective, inexperienced, or out-of-field teachers.
More than 1,600 LEAs have responded to this requirement already in their LCAP federal addenda this year.
Just as a small side note, when I presented information on this topic to the CPAG last month, the California Practitioners Advisory Group, sorry, I'm gonna try and avoid all acronyms, one member of the group shared that she thought that labeling teachers ineffective was not very helpful.
So I wanna be very clear right here at the outset that we 100% agree with her.
This is a term that is used by the federal government and we only use it at the state level for this specific federal requirement.
Further, we know that some of the disproportionalities or equity gaps that we see in California schools and districts are greatly exacerbated by the fact that California is in the midst of a severe teacher shortage.
So it's really important to just sort of set this is not about blaming people for things.
This is our work to meet this federal requirement and also to do our best to make sure that kids have access or equitable access to the best prepared teachers we can find.
Finally, I want to really say that collecting and reporting this type of data is extremely complicated.
To do it properly, you need folks with deep expertise and credentials, federal and state law, standards and courses, and who's teaching what, and of course, data.
So you may notice that behind me, I've
amassed a small army of experts from two agencies.
We have colleagues from the Commission on Teacher Credentialing here to help support the conversation this afternoon.
And our data friends are here, Cindy and her team.
And I think it just shows you we've been working together across the two agencies, program, data, folks from both agencies, really working hard to do the best we can to meet this federal requirement and serve our kids.
So with that, the CDE proposes to clarify the definitions for ineffective and out-of-field teachers that are currently in our ESSA state plan.
The state plan right now defines the term ineffective teacher as a teacher who is misassigned or teaching without a credential.
A teacher who is misassigned has been placed in a position for which the employee does not hold a legally recognized certificate or credential or a certificated employee placed in a teaching or services position in which the employee is not otherwise authorized by statute to serve.
This definition was designed back in 2017 to align to LCFF Priority 1, which addresses appropriately assigned teachers.
An out-of-field teacher in the current plan is defined as a teacher who is assigned based on a general education or special education limited assignment teaching permit, also known as a GLAP or a CLAP.
And even though I'm going to avoid acronyms, some of them are too hard to resist.
More as we move forward.
So, GELAPs can be issued at the request of an employing school district, county office of education, charter school or state agency to fill a staffing vacancy or need.
They're issued for a one-year period only and can be reissued in any one subject twice if the holder completes the renewal requirements and the employing agency requests the permit.
Similarly, CELAPs can be issued to fill a staffing vacancy or need for a one-year period and can be reissued in any one special education specialization area twice if the holder completes the renewal requirements and the employing agency requests the permit.
An inexperienced teacher is defined as a teacher who has two or fewer years of teaching experience.
Fortunately, we do not propose to update this definition in the new plan.
That one will stick.
So as I mentioned, each LEA receiving ESSA funds must submit a plan to the state educational agency that describes how it will identify and address any disparities that result in low-income and minority students being taught at higher rates than other students by ineffective, inexperienced, or out-of-field teachers.
In the 2018-19 school year, more than 1,600 LEAs addressed this requirement in their LCAP federal addendum.
This is probably a good time to mention that the CDE has developed the Promoting Equitable Access to Teachers, or PEAT, program to assist LEAs in identifying and addressing local disparities or equity gaps.
The PEAT program includes a suite of equity tools designed to assist LEAs as they collect and analyze the appropriate data
conduct data analyses to identify equity gaps, conduct a root cause analysis, and consider various strategies to address disparities and engage stakeholders throughout the process.
These tools were developed to help LEAs successfully complete their LCAP federal addenda this year and also to continue to address any equity gaps in the years ahead.
You can take a look at them if you go to our webpage and just type Pete, like the soil amendment, in the search box.
P-E-A-T, not our friend Pete.
But Pete in the search box, you'll get to the page and you'll see all of the tools.
Further, to meet ESSA data reporting requirements, the CDE, in collaboration with our colleagues at the Commission on Teacher Credentialing, has been working to update several elements of the educator data collection process.
The two agencies have entered into a data sharing MOU in order to modernize and digitize the current system for assignment monitoring statewide.
The Commission is currently developing a new system that will use both CTC and CDE data to identify potential misassignments and provide communication platforms for counties and school districts to address and resolve those potential misassignments.
So we're going to automate this process that the CTC has been conducting for many years under state law.
Finally, in order to effectively assess which credential and authorization is required to teach a course based on the state course code name and description.
CDE staff has updated the entire set of state course codes to bring them into alignment with all of our new standards.
And those course codes are collected in CALPADS.
And we've also added a number of attributes that further refine each one of those course descriptions.
So again, we have a better understanding and our LEAs have a better understanding so that we can do a better match to figure out who is and isn't appropriately assigned.
So to share information around all of these updates, Department and Commission staff partnered this spring and offered 31 in-person trainings and several webinars around all of these updates.
3,300 people through in-person trainings at county offices of education and over 1,900 additional participants via webinars.
Staff continue to offer support to the field through office hours held every Monday for one hour.
The hour is dedicated to informing the field of any changes or updates within the various programs and to take any questions from LEAs.
As staff traveled the state to share all of this information about changes, participants requested quite often clarification around how specific authorizations and permits fit into those 2017 adopted definitions because they're relatively broad.
Particular people were like, well, where do the PIPs and STIPs go?
So staff proposes to update the definitions adding more detail to clarify where each of California's permits and authorizations falls into our as a state plan definitions.
We think that these clarifications will both help LEAs more easily and consistently identify and address local equity gaps and they'll also provide the state with a more accurate picture of our state level equity gaps and this will help us provide more targeted and effective technical assistance.
So, we propose to clarify the definition for ineffective teacher to include individuals whose assignments are legally authorized by an emergency permit that does not require possession of a full teaching license,
Individuals who hold a full teaching credential, but do not hold a permit or authorization that temporarily allows them to teach outside of their credentialed area, those teachers are misassigned.
They have a credential, but they're not holding the proper permit to teach the students and content that they're teaching.
And finally, the individuals who hold no credentials, permits, or authorizations to teach in California.
Under this new clarified definitions, teachers with the following permits would be considered ineffective.
That would include those teaching with provisional internship permits, short-term staff permits, variable term waivers, and individuals teaching with substitute permits or teaching permits for statutory leave who are teachers of record.
They would all be considered ineffective under this refined definition.
So a couple of explanations of what PIPs and STIPs and TPSLs are.
See, I can't resist those acronyms.
Who doesn't, you can say TPSL with me, because it just feels so good to say it.
PIPs and STIPs and TPSLs, come on.
The board is fortunate to have two former chairs of the CTC on it.
But for those of you who haven't worked at the CTC, come on, pips, tips, never mind.
So.
See?
You want to do a little spin.
Here we go.
All right, so.
Provisional internship permits can be issued to individuals who have not yet met subject matter competence requirements needed to enter an intern program to fill an immediate staffing need in an employing agency.
And short-term staff permits, or STIPs, can be issued to individuals that possess a baccalaureate degree or higher, have satisfied the basic skills requirement, and completed required coursework to fill an acute staffing need in an employing agency.
Variable term waivers can be issued to individuals to give them a little more time to complete credentialing requirements when a fully credentialed teacher is not available for the assignment.
And TPSLs can be issued to individuals with baccalaureate degrees that have satisfied basic skills requirements as well as an initial 45 hours of preparation to fill a position where the teacher of record is unable to teach due to a statutory leap.
Individuals teaching with PIPS, STIPS, variable term waivers, and TPSLs do hold official documentation from the Commission on Teacher Credentialing to fill immediate staffing needs when a fully credentialed teacher cannot be found.
However, these individuals have not yet completed a preparation program and are fundamentally teaching without a credential.
So that's why we recommend that they move into the ineffective definition.
Staff also recommends clarifying the definition of out-of-field teacher.
The current definition for out-of-field teachers includes individuals teaching with G-LAPS and C-LAPS.
Staff proposes to include individuals teaching with short-term waivers, emergency English learner or bilingual permits on local assignment options, in addition to the G-LAPS and C-LAPS that are in the current definition.
So quick explanations, short term waivers allow employers to assign teachers who hold basic credentials to teach outside of their credential authorization for one semester or less with the teacher's consent.
Emergency English learner permits and bilingual authorization permits allow qualified individuals to be employed while completing the requirements for the English learner certificate or bilingual authorization.
And finally, local assignment options allow employing agencies to place a teacher in a position outside of their credential authorization if the agency is unable to assign a teacher or other certificated employee with the appropriate credential.
So, all of the individuals that we propose to include in the out-of-field definition have completed a preparation program.
Unlike most of the individuals that would be included in the ineffective definition, these teachers do hold credentials but have not yet demonstrated subject matter competence in the subject area or for the student population to which they are assigned.
So once these definitions are approved, we will update our PEAT program resources to reflect these clarified definitions and conduct additional and ongoing outreach and technical assistance to LEAs as they work to eliminate their equity gaps.
LEAs will be required to update the section of their LCAP federal addendum related to educator equity to reflect the updated definitions of ineffective and out-of-field teachers.
I'm not sure if you want to go on.
As I mentioned, we have a large contingent back here who would be happy to address any questions regarding the recommended updates, revisions to these definitions.
We have colleagues from the Commission on Teacher Credentialing.
We have
the Executive Director, Mary Sandy, and two Aarons.
Those of you who work at the credential know that we are so lucky to have both Aarons Google and Aaron.
We have a lot of Aarons here.
And we have Cindy's whole team.
And we will do our best to support you to make this decision.
Or you can go on to accountability, and we'll come back to this.
only take a few clarifying questions, but hold our kind of big questions until after public comment.
So, Member Rucker, a clarifying question.
would make these corrections in their LCAP addendum related to this area.
Is the correction also related to the expenditure that they have in their narrative about the Title II funds or is it just about this definition?
that they have to amend?
All right, so thank you for that question.
That's a good question.
I think probably lots of folks have.
We're not asking them to make corrections because they haven't done this incorrectly.
They have crafted responses based on our current definitions, and we will be asking them to update responses to reflect the numbers of teachers that are involved with these updated, clarified definitions.
Does that answer your question?
I wanted to understand what the revision was, so that's helpful.
We are continuing to support those 1,600 LEAs right now to do this properly.
Most of them have completed and had this section of their LCAP addendum approved, about 75%, 79%.
We're continuing to work with the remaining folks.
And then this spring, we're going to ask everyone to go back, pending your decision on what the new definitions would be, or the clarified definitions would be, and revisit and update that section.
I will wait because now I have another question.
Any other clarifying questions?
Well, I have a couple of comments, liaison, and then a question as well.
So, thank you for bringing up the definition of the word ineffective.
I had a lot of issues with this when we were submitting the ESSA plan.
because it's just an incorrect term for this.
And I had even suggested that we first define what effective teacher is and then we can pick out the effective teachers and then everybody else would be ineffective.
But we didn't have 10 years to get there.
as a plan in.
So this is where we went.
And so nevertheless, you know, given this, it does provide data to us to see where we do have teachers who may not be fully credentialed.
When we did the definition initially, we had not considered all of the different, you know,
types of credential certifications that are out there.
And so, this item here is to help clarify that for the field and to help us with collection of that information.
So, I guess my question is, then, what do we do, other than to send this to the feds, this information, and collect it?
How do we use it in California?
And I don't know if the commission folks might want to speak to that and what they're doing.
if we're getting into our deeper discussion and maybe we should get our public comment and then come back to that deeper discussion because I think there are a lot of questions that will emerge as we do that.
Because it's a great question.
I just want to give it time.
So are there any public comments?
Okay.
You have more item.
All right, okay.
We'll do our other item, then we'll do public items, then we'll have a robust discussion of both items, okay?
Once we get deeply in.
Thank you.
So, the other part of the ESSA item is proposing the shift in the long-term goal for the extended graduation rate.
So, you all... So, completely change your brain.
Yeah, change your preview.
Yeah, yeah.
It is hard to do that, I know.
We'll try to change our brain.
So back, if we go back two months to July, you all adopted a combined four and five-year graduation rate.
Nationally, they call that the extended year graduation rate.
There has been a series of consequences that we need to deal with within our ESSA state plan.
And so this is the last piece of it is that we need to set a more rigorous long-term goal.
So in order to come into compliance, we are suggesting you shift the goal for our graduation rate from 90% to 90.5%.
Based on our analysis, it would impact from the prior year 56 LEAs and schools that had graduation rates between 90% and 90.4%.
So this is a just a nice chart that just shows you where the shift is and then in the board item it actually had the tables note that there was an Error on one of the tables for the DAS we didn't update the high it actually stayed at 90% it should have been 90.5% So essentially what is not changing?
for our Traditional schools is a very high rate what is changing for?
Traditional schools is changing shifting it from 90 to 90.5 percent to less than 90 percent 95 percent and then for median
medium, you need to go up to that 90, your top of the range will be 90.5%.
And the same shift is being done for our dashboard alternative schools as well.
That is the end of my piece of the presentation.
So again, we'll take clarifying questions, but can you go back to the chart?
I can, and I should have mentioned that before we got to today, we have been conducting as a stakeholder meetings.
And so we do these about, I think it's been about every month for the last couple of months, or at least the entire year.
And those are very well attended.
We always get over 100 people on those webinars.
So this is something we have taken to the field as well as the information that Barb just presented.
Are there any clarifying questions on this item?
Yes, member of Ortiz-Lacombe.
I have a question about sort of the modest increase from 90 to 90.5.
Is it because we looked at the data and that would have great impact on those schools that were in the blue for graduation or I know why we did why we increased it but I'm wondering why the 0.5?
The .5 is something that we felt we could stand behind.
We had looked at other states, so the shift is modest.
We know that a lot of schools, majority of our schools are not actually graduating.
large numbers of students in that fifth year.
So it's sort of in keeping with the data in general about the actual number of students who are in the fifth year.
But beyond that, you get to sort of take a guess.
And I don't know that 91% would have been, I don't know that we've actually done, I need to double check on whether or not we did the simulations for that.
So it's time to get to any public comment.
I should note, I probably should have noted earlier that I am going to, when we get into deeper discussion, propose an amendment to the item on definitions because our ESSA plan states that an out-of-field teacher is a teacher who has not yet demonstrated subject matter competence in the subject areas for which he or she is assigned.
and some of the areas in which that is true are not currently in the definition.
So this is really CTC speak, but just to flag that I believe that all of the areas in which subject matter competence has not been demonstrated should be included as examples there.
There will be potentially different perspectives on that, but I'll just, we'll come back to that when we get into the deep discussion.
All right, so public comment.
How many do we have?
There are four.
Sheila Whitley, Dean Drescher, Rigel Massaro, and Sarah Lillis, please line up.
Hi, Angela de Ramos on behalf of CTA.
We don't have a position on the changes themselves, but we did have some questions and a suggestion.
Will the new changes require consolidated application for this year to be redirected, or will the new changes be added to be in line with the LCAP template that is being adopted in January?
And then CTA also recommends that the state would prioritize Title II funds and that you direct school districts to meaningfully consult and strategize with their bargaining units to develop local plans to help improving teacher quality and effectiveness, particularly for beginning teachers and out-of-field teachers with that goal in mind.
Thank you.
We have to take note of these questions so we can ask them to you when we're done with public comments.
Good afternoon, Chair Darling-Hammond and members.
Rigel Massaro with Public Advocates.
I'm speaking to the letter submitted by the LCFF Equity Coalition on these revised educator equity definitions.
We appreciate the board and department staff's engagement with stakeholders in this item, and we support the revised ineffective and out-of-field definitions.
I will avoid both spelling them out and the acronyms.
While imperfect, as Barbara described, these definitions are the only current measure.
of statewide and local teacher equality, and how prepared and experienced teachers are equitably placed to teach our low-income and students of color.
I'd love to hear more about the chair's proposal.
We would support the out-of-field definition being inclusive, that is actually including everyone that is under the ineffective definition, but that is also out-of-field, which is often the case with misassigned teachers, permit holders, and waiver holders.
If that is not the way the board goes, we would urge the department to aggregate both ineffective and out of field into a distinct combined measure that is actionable for policymakers and local communities.
Thank you.
for the lines of comment.
Okay so we want to take up these items in in turn and maybe we'll invite Barb back to the podium first to talk about the
First item and member Sun you were about to Raise a set of interesting questions, and why don't you go first so yet, so I was gonna Ask a little bit about that is how do we look at it as a state?
You know I and I do think that this isn't this is a problem and again Thank You Barbara for bringing up
that collecting of this data is for us to see where we have gaps in fully credentialed teachers or teachers who are credentialed in their field for the purpose of supporting students.
But we also know about the teacher,
the lack of teachers in the state at this point.
And so it's not about blaming and shaming, but as a state, we really need to take on that responsibility as well.
So I was curious about what we do with this data at the state level.
So we do a lot of different things at the state level.
And I think everyone here knows how much work has been done and has been able to move forward because we have these huge teacher shortages.
So we have loan forgiveness programs now.
We have teacher residency programs now.
We have new professional learning programs, which we are optimistic will help people to stay in the profession because they're better prepared and better supported.
So from a policy making place, I think having this information that shows that we have
overall shortages of fully prepared teachers is very helpful to us.
Under No Child Left Behind, the state was required to intervene and provide sanctions
You remember as a school leader.
So the very broad thing is we can advocate for policy because we have issues.
But in a much more targeted way, we help individual LEAs think about their equity gaps and encourage them.
Because it's one thing to have inexperienced teachers.
We were all inexperienced once.
And it's one thing to have a teacher shortage that requires you to have various,
types of authorizations in your district, but should all of the less than fully prepared teachers be teaching certain student groups?
in certain schools.
So under No Child Left Behind, we were authorized to require folks to do an equitable distribution plan if they had gaps.
We went in and intervened.
In the third year of Compliance Monitoring Intervention and Sanctions, we went in and said you have to spend your Title II money
to address these gaps and you have to have board policy that says we will not have all of our underprepared teachers in one school, we will spread them out.
So we don't have authority to do that anymore and that's fine, that's not really consistent with LCFF anyway for the state to come in and require districts to move, right?
That's not who we are, but we still do provide lots of technical assistance to LEAs as they're calculating their equity gaps and trying to figure out who is teaching which students in which schools.
We can provide them with support to say, hey, maybe you want to try this and maybe you want to think about that and provide that level of technical assistance and support.
I don't know if, no, that's fine.
Other?
Yeah, Member Ortiz-Lacon and Member Burr.
You know, as you were describing, and this is an educator equity sort of audit that we're holding to see where we have our concentration of inexperienced, ineffective.
But as you were answering the question, I thought the initiative that the superintendent has to recruit more males of color,
would actually fall under perhaps inexperienced because we're trying to recruit them, right?
And where are they going to go?
We're going to put them in racially isolated schools because we also want them to be mentors and for students to see themselves in the teachers.
Some of them may actually qualify under this ineffective teacher category.
So it is important for us to also think not only on the accountability side, but the support side, because sometimes this will, as we're trying to recruit and diversify the student or the teacher pool, they fall under these categories.
And, you know, ineffective, I also struggle with that, because you can have somebody that doesn't have the proper credential, it's there in an emergency,
or any of these classifications, but they really can connect to the students that they're serving, but they do need support because they're new and we put them in hard to staff and under-resourced schools.
So I think it's more than just the accountability, though I agree that that's important, but it's also how do we support and strengthen this if we do really want to diversify the teacher pool and bring them to the students in racially isolated schools.
Many of those educators will fall under these buckets.
and already do.
May I ask a question about the reporting because I think it's related to this.
In the item that you sent us in August, the
Summary of key issues on the educator equity data.
There's a lovely chart which I really love.
It's table three and it lists each of the credential types just very without any other labels or descriptors.
Fully credentialed, university intern credentials, district intern credentials, limited assignment teaching permits, PIPs, STIPs, variable term waivers.
Those of us from the CTC just love to use these terms over and over again.
But it gives people like just like here's just the facts and I'm wondering are we going to as our ESSA plan had suggested publish this at the state district and school level you know irrespective of these labels that were required also to give people information on
That is something that we are working on.
Our intent is to be able to provide, because as we've supported districts to calculate their equity gaps for the last six months or so, we've realized that they need more help to be able to do that.
So our goal is to be able to automate that calculation for them and include it in the student accountability report card.
That'll take a little time and a little resources that would fall under Cindy's shop to be able to
do that and as you know she's pretty busy doing 72 other things but it is on the list of things that we want to do.
We want to be able to have this data be readily available for schools and districts as well as compile it at the state level.
One of the reasons I ask is because it comes without affective labeling.
of the kind that we have to report for comparability purposes, but it is just very clear and factual and gives people the information that they can use.
So I appreciate that.
Member Burr.
So, excuse me, Barb, it is late in the day and I may have fallen asleep at the beginning part of this about, but I- I should have said tips a little sooner.
I'm trying to understand what changed since we did our first plan that caused us to go back in and want to change the definitions.
That's my first question, just to sort of understand the context.
But my second one is my anti-ESSA hat.
which is how does this interact?
And it's kind of, I think it's consistent with what people are saying here is that A, I can't stand the idea that we're labeling again and we're calling people ineffective because of where they are in their experience level.
But B, we have a lot of state mechanisms for this purpose, assignment monitoring, we have the LCAP about basic conditions, we have the Williams Settlement.
I mean, there's no doubt in my mind that the state has a huge commitment to making sure that we have fully qualified teachers in all of our schools.
And we don't call them ineffective or effective.
So I'm struggling with this a bit on the two levels.
What changed and why do we have to go in and change it?
And maybe again, I fell asleep and don't know what that is.
But secondly, how is this going to enhance what our state level commitment is to educator equity, separate and not, once again, bow down to the federal government?
I plan to, thank you.
Oh, Dave's gonna help.
First of all, as we went out and did the roadshow this spring, we heard from a lot of folks a lot of confusion about where various authorizations and certifications landed in these definitions in the 2017.
for the definitions themselves.
I think that's what Sue is asking.
So in ESSA and even before that in CLB and before that, there's a comparability requirement that districts must show that in Title I schools there are no more
There's not a greater proportion of out-of-field teachers than in non-Title I schools, of inexperienced teachers than in non-Title I schools, and then they moved to the term ineffective rather than uncertified, which was...
I thought it was, anyway, we used to just be able to report certification.
So they moved to that term for measuring comparability.
So that's the genesis of us having to do it because it's part of the federal law.
Now Barb can explain how we're changing from one plan submission to the next, the way we're classifying those.
Yes, so it's a federal requirement.
And the reason to bring the proposal to clarify is fundamentally, as we went out in the field and we talked to thousands of folks who are responsible for pulling this data together and reporting it to us so we can report it to the feds, they had questions about, well, where do PIPs go?
Where do TPSLs go?
I just want to say TPSLs again.
I don't know if you have questions about TPSLs.
Where do all these various
So this is us trying to provide more information to the field as they do what they're required to do, because not only does the state have to,
collect and report and evaluate this data, under ESSA, LEAs are required to describe how they're going to address any identified equity gaps.
So they just need clarification on if we're using these buckets, the state is using these buckets, who's actually in the buckets.
Dave Sapp, Deputy Policy Director for State Board of Education, offered to help Barb on the second question, which is sort of, there's a lot of things in state law, what role does this have?
And the reason why, because of the transition for Shanine and how the different pieces fit together, just think this interacts with the board's accountability work very closely, and so I just thought it would be helpful to provide some support, is that
This year's budget trailer bill which was SB 75 included some some new language that will require the board to review the existing local
Siri's listening.
Siri loves TPSLs too.
But the board will be required to review and update the existing local indicators for which the state has comparable school level data on a statewide basis.
By 2021, the Board will have to take a look and update local indicators if such data exists.
This is one area for the existing local indicators where such data will exist.
In fact, it may end up being the basics priority, that priority one under LCFF may end up being the only one of the current local indicators that meet that requirement.
So, I think this goes both to Member Sun's question, to Board President Darling-Hammond's questions about what do we do with this data.
This is truly a federal reporting requirement.
The data has to be carved up and reported in a particular way.
As far as how to make it actionable, that is something that can be addressed within the state accountability process and the board actually has authority.
Under that new trailer bill language, we will be required to actually look at within the dashboard itself, going back to the question of can the data be reported granularly as opposed to just this broad category of quote-unquote ineffective.
the sub-breakdowns of these different authorization statuses and how they're combined or not combined.
I understand there will be a discussion of is ineffective plus out of field, do you look at those together or are they overlapping?
Whichever way the board comes down on the federal reporting, that's federal reporting.
For state accountability, it can be looking more at a broader base of what's going on in schools.
And what is the quality of the credential status of the teachers in schools and the disparities across a district where there are multiple school sites?
And if there are disparities, how should that factor into determining if they're eligible for differentiated assistance?
I think there will also be opportunities, and this will be more of a legislative-type conversation, of thinking about how this data might fit in to these new initiatives that Barb referenced,
the teacher residency, loan forgiveness, etc.
If we know that there are certain schools that are disproportionately relying on teachers that both have not completed teacher preparation and lack subject matter expertise for the subjects that they are teaching, maybe that should be factored into eligibility, etc.
So I think there is a lot of
It's really exciting because this data can be used to inform those state policymaking questions.
I think the decision today for the board is simply one of how to report in a federal report, and that's not limit how the underlying data can be used for state accountability, support determinations, and otherwise.
So I think sort of how they fit in together is this is one of those examples of we need to do it as a condition of $2.5 billion.
And so updating the definition to ensure, frankly, just to be blunt, the first definition included terms that was subject to two interpretations.
And that was the source of the confusion in the field.
And it also would undermine the quality of the data looking at it from a statewide perspective because people may be using different definitions.
different understandings of the definition because they were susceptible to those different definitions.
So this is trying to be more specific and comprehensive to ensure that the data are in fact comparable and then that can inform future actions as appropriate for state accountability and support determinations.
So, first of all, I just want to say $2.5 million, even though we can sit billion, $2.5 billion with a B, B, B, B, B. That's a lot of government cheese.
That may not seem like a lot of money at this level, but in those LEAs that receive that money, it's a lot of money for them.
So I can understand why we need to take the steps of meeting the compliance requirement.
But again, I heard you say something that gives me some pause for concern.
Board member Burr has pointed out we have mechanisms in the state to address not only accountability, but the work that needs to be done with districts concerning these teacher quality issues.
Because this is a persistent and seemingly intractable problem.
And so one of the statements that I heard was that, you know, we don't have necessarily the levers to make districts do certain things, and I'm not sure I agree with that.
Under Title II, there's 23 approvable activities or acceptable activities that can be used for using Title II funds.
And part C of Title II requires districts to meaningfully consult with their local associations before they spend any part of that money under Title II.
With the teachers that we are adding who are misassigned,
Districts have an obligation under our state law to provide the professional development to make those teachers whole, to address whatever the issue is of that misassignment.
Further, we know in this state there was a moment in time where teachers who were going through induction were being charged a fee by their districts to pay for their induction, even though teacher induction and certification programs can also be paid for by Title II funds.
So I think that we're missing the opportunity here to do some additional enforcement and to do some additional mandating with our LEAs by identifying this as a state priority.
That's one of those approval activities under Title II.
If we decide that this is a state priority, we can direct to districts.
They have to use those funds to support their beginning teachers.
on their certification issues and make sure they pay for induction.
But we can also make sure that when they have identified teachers who are misassigned under this new definition, that they are directed, as a condition of approving whatever we're going to be reporting in the spring, as a condition of approving that,
that they show in their plans, that they revise their plans to address that as a priority as well.
I think we're not using all the policy levers we have, not just in writing the definitions, but in establishing conditions for approving their plans and their LCAPs to make sure that this actually happens in the way it's intended.
That would be something we might want to come back to as an additional policy conversation.
Okay.
Member... Okay, Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I like ESSA.
Board Member Burr.
We have the sisterhood, but there was a little bit of distance there.
And so I just want to remind us that we opted for these definitions.
So when we're looking at the ineffective teacher, not every state is defining it like this.
There are states that are defining it based on performance, right?
We chose to move away from that.
And so,
We have to live with this because this is what we chose.
There was a robust discussion that we had about, are we looking at performance?
I remember Bruce Holliday and Michael Kerr saying, I feel uncomfortable with this definition.
But we also didn't want to reach into collective bargaining agreements.
And so I just wanted to remind us that, hi, we created this.
And so this is where we're at.
We own this.
So I have to apologize to everybody because when this item came up in our discussion on our liaison call, this is, for me, this was simply we needed to change or be more explicit in the definition to help the field.
to figure out what bucket to put things in.
I had the suspicion that it could open up this can of worms of this whole conversation here, and I think I inartfully did this, because I'm tired, by bringing up the whole, what does California do with this data?
Yeah, I know, and I so apologize, but the item at hand is
you
providing more clarity on those buckets for the field to report the data.
And so it's simply just a reporting mechanism piece here.
Now what we wanna do with educator effectiveness, all of that is more of a state conversation that's much, much broader that we do need to take up and we do need to ensure that we continue that conversation.
So I know, that's why I'm apologizing.
But we appreciate.
the mea culpa, but we have to have this conversation so we don't blame you for those of us whether we like us or we don't like us.
And I would like to just point out one other piece of the clarification.
so that we can consider it.
So I noted that the ESSA plan had said that an out-of-field teacher is a teacher who has not yet demonstrated subject matter competence in the subject areas or for the student population to which he or she is assigned.
And if we were to go back, I don't know if you can do this, Barb, to your ineffective teacher slide.
As you noted when you were briefing it, there are a number of the PIPs, the STIPs, we all like to say it, the Variable Term Waivers and Substitute Permits, TPSLs, also lack subject matter verification.
So they are, by that definition, they are out of field.
The way that out of field in the next slide is currently proposed to be defined, wherever that is, is really, I'm not sure about all of these, Ting, Mary, you'll have to catch me on this, but it's mostly credentialed teachers who are placed out of field.
And so if we wanted to
make the definition clear, we'd either say credentialed out-of-field teachers when we publish it to our publics so that they know who's counted, or we should count all of those out-of-field teachers from the ineffective teacher definition as well as out-of-field.
The categories are not used in the federal sense to add up to 100%.
You just compare schools that on ineffective teachers, Title I versus non-Title I, out-of-field teachers, Title I versus non-Title I, inexperienced teachers, Title I versus non-Title I.
many inexperienced teachers will fall in another category, et cetera.
So there can be overlap in the numbers.
But I think there should be clarity because parents, consumers, stakeholders, when they're looking at these numbers, want to understand that they fit the definition.
So we don't want to pretend that people who don't have subject matter
qualifications like emergency permit holders do have those qualifications, which is the problem with the current proposal if we don't clarify it further.
So I think there's, you know, one way to go is to simply say as we, to amend this out of field definition to say it includes the categories that are listed under ineffective teacher and these following ones, which will then get everyone
Counted in that definition who does not have subject matter verification for the thing that for the subjects they're teaching Yeah And so that would be you know a proposed amendment to make the definition actually accurate for what it's saying Pat or member Rucker
And as I said, the other alternative would be in our own reporting to say credentialed out-of-field teachers for this rather than out-of-field teachers and then to make it aligned to the definition so people know what we're counting.
Because here we're basically only counting those people who are placed out of field and not all the other people who lack subject matter.
Verification member Rucker, I think in hearing what Barbara said as she was going through the presentation
When we look at the definition of the ineffective teacher, so both of these categories of teachers have some kind of document that was issued by the state of California.
What I heard in the staff presentation is that the difference between the ineffective teacher and the out-of-field teacher is that the definition for the out-of-field teacher was intended to focus on
California teachers who do have a state credential, but for the subject area they're currently assigned to teach, do not have the subject matter competence.
I think another way to consider it, what was missing for the definition of ineffective teacher, and that's what I was waiting to hear, these are people who don't have state certification because they have not completed a state credential program,
And they also have not demonstrated the required subject matter competence to be issued or to receive the state credentials.
So there's two different issues for these two different groups.
I think if you try to put the first list of folks also under the second list, the problem is they don't have the same kind of piece of paper.
as the people who are being identified under this original definition.
I just think that we have to line up.
Yeah, we have to line it up.
Yes, very clearly because there's a public
Yes, I agree with you.
We need to line it up.
But I think what's missing in the first definition is that they don't have subject matter competence.
And what's missing in the second definition is they don't have subject matter competence for the subject area they're teaching.
It's not made clear.
So I agree with you.
There's something missing from both definitions.
But I'm not sure if combining it will fix the problem.
You could do either.
Either way of solving it.
One of the errands.
The suggestion is to amend the definition of out-of-field teacher to just state fully credentialed teachers who have not yet demonstrated subject matter competence.
Can't be fully credentialed because interns are not fully credentialed, but it could be credentialed teachers.
Basically everybody here is on a permit except for people who have a preliminary or full credential or an intern credential.
Those are the only three credentials.
But fully credentialed would not include interns.
So you would want to say a credentialed teacher who is placed out of field.
Does that address the issues at hand?
That helps me.
But then you would need to change the definition at the top, so that would also change from our previous ESSA plan.
It would say a credential teacher who has not demonstrated subject matter competence, if we leave it.
I do want to clarify that all of the document types that are listed under out-of-field, so the GLAP, CLAP, short-term waivers, emergency, English and bilingual permits and local assignment options, intern credential holders actually cannot be issued any of those.
So those can only be issued to an individual who has a preliminary or a clear teaching credential.
So they actually wouldn't be able to be counted in that bucket.
So that's another wrinkle because under misassignment, for example, which we're trying to get these things to be analogous, you know, intern teachers who are placed out of field would nonetheless be classified as misassigned.
Yes, exactly.
An intern teacher who's placed out of field, they would fall under the ineffective teacher category.
No, they don't.
because they would technically be misassigned for their assignment.
They're not listed.
They're the second bullet in ineffective.
Short-term staff permits are only issued to... The second top bullet.
A teacher who holds a full teaching credential but does not possess the permit or authorization that temporarily allows them.
It wouldn't include your intern teacher who holds the appropriate authorization on their document.
Yes.
Any teacher who's misassigned, yes.
Whether they hold an intern, a preliminary, or a clear credential.
Is a part of the ineffective teacher.
That's not what we currently have on the slide.
If you go back to that slide, it does not
All right, well, we look at the handout which came from the item, I apologize for the slide.
The second bullet at the top of the handout under ineffective.
And this is what's in the item right now as well.
The teacher who holds the full teaching credential but does not possess a permit or authorization that temporarily allows them to teach outside of their credentialed area, those are misassigned.
Right, but an intern does not hold a full teaching credential.
They hold an intern's full needs to be removed from that definition.
Okay.
That would clarify.
Right, and there are only those three.
Take out the word full.
This is so in the weeds for the CTC people.
I realize everybody else is probably going bleh.
So then that would come out of there, and then we would make it clear that an out-of-field teacher, and I would hope we would label it for the purpose of public dissemination, that it's credentialed out-of-field teachers, and we would then put in the definition, a teacher who has not yet
a credential teacher who has not yet demonstrated subject matter competence.
And then you could keep them as orthogonal groups that do not overlap, but they would be accurate to the definitions.
I'm going to propose that amendment.
before we get more confused.
It's intended to be a friendly amendment.
I don't know how it's being received, but it's intended to be a friendly amendment.
Yes, so the ineffective teacher definition would say an ineffective teacher is any of the following.
And in the second bullet, it would delete the word full.
It would say a teacher who holds a teaching credential but does not possess a permit or authorization that temporarily allows them to teach outside their credentialed area.
All right?
And then in the out-of-field teacher, it would read a credentialed out-of-field teacher.
And an out-of-field teacher is a credentialed teacher who has not yet demonstrated subject matter competence.
So it would insert the word credentialed there.
And then I think we would have the clarity that the public needs to be able to know what's going on and what, you know, that we need.
No, then you would no longer move them because it would be clear.
Okay, good.
Yes, I'm totally for that.
Okay.
Got the big item again.
This is part of it.
So I would like so first I'm going to move the amendment and let's vote on the amendment and then we'll vote on the motion as amended.
Okay.
So all in favor of the amendment as stated.
We don't have a motion.
I'll move the motion for the amendment.
All right.
All in favor.
Aye.
Any opposed.
Any abstentions?
You're allowed to abstain if you're just completely confused.
Now we'll move with that amendment to the State Board recommendation.
All right, second?
Second.
Thank you.
Member Sun, all in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
The motions carry.
Thank you.
This is probably the hardest thing we have to do for the rest of the day, and we may not make 5 o'clock, but we'll get out of here before 6, I think.
So we're now going to move on to items 15.
Which is our state board projects and priorities to take up our minutes from our September 2019 meeting our liaison reports.
The state board staff recommendation recommends that we approve the preliminary report of actions and minutes for the September 11th, 2019 meeting.
And consider the State Board screening recommendations for appointments to the Advisory Commission on Special Education, California Practitioners Advisory Group, and the Instructional Quality Commission.
Do I have a motion from a board member to approve the September 11th State Board of Education?
Just the minutes first.
Yes, that's what I'm doing.
Draft preliminary report of action meeting minutes.
and second thank you member Rucker any discussion all right any public comments all right all in favor say aye any opposed nay any abstentions motion carries
Now I'll ask Vice President Strauss to share the recommendations from the State Board Screening Committee regarding appointments to the Advisory Commission on Special Education, California Practitioners Advisory Group, and the Instructional Quality Commission.
And I want to ask her to do that while offering thanks for her amazing role in helping us get to this point.
Let me just say.
the screening committee of Kim Petillo-Bronson and Feliz Ortiz-Lincon and myself read more than 220 applications for all the commissions.
220, more than.
So when we have a second day meeting in January, we will recognize the support and the time they spent on weekends and nights to do that.
So that included, by the way, reading all the applications, then have a call to narrow down the applications
And then another call, which was all the interviews to finalize each of commissions recommendations.
The other thing that you should know is the staff worked really hard to really extend and recruit.
So we did a really strong job and in every category got amazing, amazing field of candidates.
So for everyone who reached out to people they knew and encouraged them, it was really wonderful.
The other thing is state board staff and CDE staff staff each commission.
So for each commission, we have the CDE and state board staff members as part of the paper screening and interview process as well.
So it's really a comprehensive support.
So, with that, we have an amazing recommendation.
The 1st, 1 is for instructional quality commission.
We are recommending for appointments 3 now for starting in January 1 in January 2021, Lily Jarvis, director of bilingual programs and a principal at Monrovia unified was selected to represent the world language category for a 3 year term.
Her term begins in January 1st, 2020.
Dr. Lindsay Gotanda, Assistant Superintendent of Ed Services for Palos Verdes Peninsula Unified School District, was selected to represent the All Subjects District Administration category for three-year term.
She also begins her term in January 2020.
Mariana Estorga-Almanza, Visual and Performing Arts Coordinator for Linwood Unified School District, was selected to represent the Visual and Performing Arts category
and her three-year term begins in January.
She's moving over from CPAC, so she's had some experience on our commissions, so that actually vacated a position on CPAC, but she's gonna add a lot in the VAPA area.
Denae Popovich is a principal in Arcadia Unified, was selected to represent all subjects in elementary administration.
She's selected for a three-year term.
Her term begins in January 1st, 2021.
Amazing candidates, actually huge field, really amazing.
Now this next part is particularly special because we spent the morning hearing what students had to say about what we should do.
Last year, they recommended that we should have a student on IQC.
And this is the first year that the State Board will appoint a student member to serve a one-year term on IQC, and they'll function as a regular voting member with full rights and duties as the other members.
The SBE Screening Committee is recommending the following individual.
This student is also a junior, similar to the cycle we have for student board members, so they're appointed in their junior year to serve in their senior year.
This is Maya Howard.
She's currently a junior at Mira Loma High School in the San Juan Unified School District, and she'll serve a one-year term beginning in September 2020.
So that's our recommendations for IQC.
For the California Practitioners Advisory Group, better known as CPAG, this group, we recommended
So, we're recommending a reappointment of 2 members for 2 year terms.
Nancy Lauro, who's a teacher with the San Diego Unified School District representing teachers at traditional public schools.
So, she will be reappointed for 2 years starting January 2020.
She's done an amazing job in elementary.
focus and really a great voice on our CPAG.
And then Joanne Isken, who's Director of Special Projects at UCLA Center X with Teacher Education, and she's been the chair for the last three years, which we greatly appreciate the service as chair and the working together to bring the committee together.
She's going to represent the educational research category and she's also reappointed for a two-year term starting in January as well.
So in addition, we're recommending an appointment of a three-year term
Melanie Green you might know her as Melanie shoppy green Sheppy she was and she's being appointed as a direct She's director of continuous improvement and support with the San Joaquin County Office of Education.
She's recommended to Take a three-year term and to represent authorized chartering agencies We're also recommending that she begin a two-year term as a CPAC chair chair starting in January as well.
So
So I think she'll, and she's agreed to do that.
And then we're also recommending Ronald Anaya, a teacher with the Rockland Unified School District to represent teachers from traditional public schools.
And his term begins in January 1st, 2020.
So let me just make one more comment.
Special education.
So we are recommending, the Advisory Commission on Special Education, we're recommending a reappointment for a four-year term beginning in January 2020 for Christina Mills, currently the Executive Director of the California Foundation for Independent Living Center.
She's been an amazing participant on the Special Education Commission and was really strongly recommended for reappointment.
And we're recommending an appointment for a four-year term, Christine Oyekawa.
She's board president and teach of another language to kids, a parent of a child with disabilities.
And we're recommending her fill the parent role.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, we had a huge volume of applications, wonderful, but in many, many categories.
So we won't be doing those interviews till a week from Monday.
That's a full day set of interviews.
And so we'll bring that screening committee recommendation back to the board for the January 8th and 9th.
meeting.
So with that, we're recommending that the board approve our appointments to IQC, CPAG, Advisory Commission on Special Ed, I think those were the, and Instructional Quality Commission, yes.
And I'll make the motion to approve.
And Kim Petillo-Bronson second.
With great thanks to our colleagues, is there any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
How dare you?
Or you can be on the screening committee.
Any abstentions?
The motion carries.
Thank you very much for all of the, you know, amazing work.
We have to thank all of the members of those committees for their public service.
It is a lot of work.
Okay, so we're going to take some time for our report outs on any liaison activities that are not related to items on our agenda.
We're going to go in reverse alphabetical order so that Member Sun can begin.
All right, so the California, I'm going to get this right one day with California joint workforce, joint advisory committee.
Sorry, it's late and we are meeting tomorrow because we always like to meet after the state board meeting.
And so our major work right now is to work on the Perkins V application, and we will be doing a full reading of the first draft of that application tomorrow.
And you will be seeing, this body will be seeing a draft of that, I believe, in January.
So we have plenty of work for us ahead, and in the meantime,
The division that is working on this, the Career Technical Education Leadership Office is also conducting several stakeholder meetings throughout the state.
And so if you kind of watch for those and you have people who you want to recommend to go and speak to that plan, please do so.
Thank you.
Vice President Strauss.
So, um, I'm going to report on met for 2 days, September 19th and 20th on the 1st day was member record myself.
And on that day, the, the draft visual performing arts framework went out for its 1st, 60 day public review and comment.
and also the draft world language framework went out for its first 60-day public review and comment.
There also was an update on the mathematics focus group meetings.
I think we'll hear more about it as we move into the framework approval because that's going to IQC next week, the recommendation for the framework committee.
But they're actually going out and having focus groups about while that we've worked with the framework, what do we need to do differently now that we've had
an implementation on it.
And so we also, on the second day, a member, Artisna Cohn, and I were there for the Ethnic Studies Model Curriculum.
That's not a framework, it's a model curriculum.
And the recommendation from CDE was to delay any action or decision so there could be more time for CDE to review, revise, edit, and consider feedback.
You should know that with history, social science, which was a really active framework group, we had about 10,000 comments, and this time we had
20,000 comments.
They were grouped together, 23,000, 22,000, something, over 20,000.
So, and we had 64 people in the public comments on that day, very respectful, very thoughtful, very passionate about ethnic studies.
And there is a plan going forward with a listening tour and listening and experts and
We actually had Assemblywoman Shirley Weber there and State Senator Ben Allen, who are the appointees to IQC.
It was very thoughtful and well organized, so congratulations, Stephanie, on your work on coordinating all of that work.
Anyway, next week, IQC's meeting on Wednesday, and we have four outgoing members, because we just appointed some new ones, and there'll be a luncheon that
We'll honor them.
The Chair, Suman Chow, Jennifer Wu, the Vice Chair, Lisette Diaz has done an amazing job, had been Chair, and Nicole Nades.
So, we really do thank their service.
When you're on IQC, you don't just come to the meetings.
You listen to all the hearings, you read all the frameworks, you go to the materials review adoption.
It's a really intense commitment that I think people don't realize the hours.
And so, Member Rucker will be there next week, and they'll be
talking about the math curriculum framework group.
I did, AXA invited me to present the current state of the state driving forces in public education for their Curriculum and Instruction Academy.
So I did a interesting workshop on kind of where we are and what we've done.
And then we also had a community of practice math meeting.
So you all might remember, hold on, this is not working.
You might remember that there's a group of,
math leaders who are collaboration, and science leaders who are collaboration, and then they also have a community of practice.
And so the math community practice that works on equity and access, support for administrators, content knowledge, all the things that we're talking about that we need to fully implement our math.
They had a wonderful session, Strengthening English Learner Opportunities in Mathematics and Language.
It's totally relevant to all the work that we're talking about.
And there's some materials if you're interested in that.
And then I actually was fortunate, the morning of CPAG, the Science Collaboration Committee met.
So I really got a chance to talk to the leaders of science around the state on where are we in reviewing and piloting materials that are aligned to NGSS?
Where are your counties?
And basically, we're hearing that people are reviewing and piloting now, maybe to adopt for 2021.
but more likely to be adopted by 21-22.
And the discussion was, we're gonna put something on the dashboard, we're giving out the results, when do we think people will at least have a year of using Align materials in their new framework?
So they were wonderful, they're a small group of less than 20, and offered their expertise in all the different counties of our state, and I think they're a resource that we could consider using.
Last week I talked to the Orange County School Board members and administrators about the state.
forward what we do and what it means for them.
A lot of discussion on the Healthy Youth Act and ethnic studies and what we do and what we don't do.
What we don't pass laws, we don't do budget, those kind of things.
And there were 150 people was really interesting.
Last comment, Concurrence Commission, which is a subject matter project, is holding and supporting with UC and CSU a global assignment
Global Climate Summit at UCLA, December 12th and 13th, and Kim is going to attend.
Mayor Eric Garcetti has actually just agreed to be the keynote speaker, and there are going to be table groups and about 200 people, and they're going to make a film for follow-up on Climate Summit.
So that'll be a resource that we'll be able to look at.
Last comment.
I think this is it.
I thought that was my last one.
I'm sorry.
So I'm trying to talk fast, so anyway, CTC met September 26th and 7th, and I'm just gonna highlight a little bit of CTC, although Mary's here, so I might not do as good a job as she would, but anyway, they talked about the single subject theater and dance, so some work on that, that's coming up, particularly for us to think about in our visual and performing arts.
Some straight state grants to recruit teachers, that was in the budget in 18-19 and there's some really a lot of money and work to try to support teacher residency and help our areas of shortage.
A lot of discussion on literacy and the RECA and the assessment of how to be an effective reading and literacy teacher.
That's not – that's part of the next CTC meeting in two weeks.
I just talked to Mary about it.
So it's a lot of discussion about updating the CTC standards to match our standards, and then the assessments and performance to match that as well.
And so there's a law that required the RECA, and the standards that we expect are a little bit different.
Linda's been very involved in that, but I think if this is an area of interest to you, I'll – we'll keep you updated, but it's a very important issue that we need to remember.
Then also there's some more work groups starting on the career technical ed, which is an area that we're looking at in college and career.
So lots of work done in that area.
And then bilingual authorization standards.
So these are areas, and the reason I bring these up, believe that there were more than this that happened at CTC, but these are areas that affect the things we talk about as far as our ESSA plan, as far as our implementation of standards.
And with that, that ends my presentation.
All right.
Member Sandoval, did she have to leave?
Okay.
Member Rucker.
Okay, so I'm going to just cover an update on the California Early Math Initiative that's being led by the Fresno County Superintendent of Schools.
As you already know, math has become a statewide priority for us because 50% of California's children at every grade are not achieving state math standards.
California achievement data clearly demonstrate that elementary, middle, and high school students are not acquiring even the basic mathematical foundations
needed for college and career success.
To address this issue, the Fresno County Superintendent of Schools is collaborating with the Early Learning and Care Division,
of the California Department of Education, the Ames Center for Math and Science Education, the State Board of Education, the California Early Math Project, film director Les Mayfield, and independent evaluation partner WestEd to implement innovative professional development, communications, and resources
to support children from birth to third grade and ultimately decrease the achievement gap in mathematics for California students.
The project is geared to support the mixed delivery system of the early care and education field, which includes school districts, county offices of education, family care, home providers, child centered based child care providers,
and so on.
In July of this year, there was a summer institute with 30 agencies representing county offices of education, school districts, and early learning agencies.
This was led by the Aims Center for Math and Science Education.
The institute focused on developing statewide capacity and expertise in early math and science education.
The participants represent 22 counties across the state, from Modoc in the north and San Diego in the south.
The Summer Institute engaged over 100 early childhood educators from these agencies for a week of professional development and networking.
The goals of the Institute were to help participants develop capacity and expertise in facilitating professional learning with educators in their home context.
Participants were overwhelmingly positive about the Institute
and provided feedback on their own developing capacity as leaders.
Each of the organizations who participated in the institute is currently preparing and presenting implementation plans through which they will work with local educators in their context to scale the goals and outcomes from the initiative.
WestEd reported some testimonies from the participants and some of their statements included, it elevated my confidence in math and training others in math concepts.
I feel more confident knowing I do have a good foundation in math and I have a greater understanding of how to move forward as a leading learner.
In October, a series of public service announcements and math vignettes were filmed in Los Angeles by Les Mayfield.
The public service announcements and vignettes use humor and everyday situations accessible to all to show how every adult can have a great impact on children's mathematical understanding and success.
There is a plan to share an example of the public service announcements at an upcoming SBE meeting.
On November 14th, the Family Math Engagement Night will be held at the Lighthouse for Children Child Development Center in Fresno to pilot a series of math activities, take-home backpack activities, and math installations that will be evaluated and disseminated for replication statewide.
EdSource will cover and write about this event.
And also being developed for statewide distribution is a free early math application for parents, literature reviewers, showing how to support mathematical understanding through picture storybooks, a series of early math research briefs, and a resource inventory.
These components will be tested and refined throughout the project period and will ultimately be made accessible for free on the California Early Math Project website.
I really want to thank Christine and her staff for supporting me and helping me be an active liaison for the board, not only in the Early Math Project,
but in the conferences that they do for teachers.
I do want to say her program and the staff are very successful with recruiting classroom teachers to come to these conferences and to participate in meaningful ways and I think that the work that they're doing is an exemplar for the work that we need to continue doing for math.
Thank you.
Member Patio-Bronson.
That probably helps.
Yes.
And it was convened by Early Edge California.
Assemblymember McCarty, Gomez-Reyes, and Monique Lemone joined.
Sarah Neville Morgan from the Department of Education also joined.
And Toby Boyd and Laurie Easterling were there from CTA.
Edgar Sanzueta from AXA was present as well and a host of early learning
advocacy organizations were there.
It was a really interesting benchmarking of how different state systems look and are structured and are funded, and also weave together LEAs with community-based providers, either center-based providers, family child care homes.
They have a early childhood block grant that is separate and freestanding from their K-12 allocation in the budget, but 85% of their preschool for all seats are administered by LEAs in Illinois.
They have high quality learning standards.
a robust teacher induction program that has been longstanding for many years in Illinois, and they are showing outcomes in early literacy by third grade and ELA scores.
So it was very eye-opening, very exciting.
And also, you know, good learning to think about as the early childhood master plan is set to kick off with the governor's office and the state board and CDE all together.
And then I also will just say I enjoyed immensely working with my fellow board members on the screening committee.
We were ruthlessly efficient in our calls.
I so appreciated that, and it was great.
It is actually really also just lovely to hear.
People were very, I think, genuinely excited to serve and offer a contribution to the work.
So thank you.
Yeah.
So, is it on?
Yes.
So, for the last couple of days, I have been at the Student Advisory Board and Education Conference, and I helped with the student board member selection process.
I know it's been said before today, Vice President Strauss said it, and I just want to emphasize it again, but these candidates were so amazing, and I just want to congratulate all of them, because they all did amazing, and it was so difficult to get
it down to three, but I know that whichever one is selected is more than qualified.
So it was a great experience, and I'm looking forward to seeing who makes it, but also congratulating everybody that was able to participate in the entire process.
Thank you.
Member Ortiz-Lacaux.
So I am a liaison along with Board Member Sun and Board Member Rucker to the Joint Advisory Commission.
You heard that.
We also vetted 200 applications.
Yes, we have a cape hiding behind.
It was pretty, I mean, it was a lot of work.
Even my kids were like, are you done with the applications?
So I think that it's, yeah, it was a lot of our time, but it was great.
We have amazing educators that want to be part of the process and part of the recommendations.
So you heard that as well.
I guess on my page six activities, I deliver the keynote for the California Latino School Boards Association.
And there is a lot of interest in the model curriculum, the ethnic studies model curriculum, Jose Medina's requirement for ethnic studies.
There's fear that we're rolling back.
And so part of what,
I assure some people was that this is something that we are as eager as most to make sure that we do it and that we do it right.
So the other thing that came up a lot was Latinos, Latino students, not English learners, but just Latino students and their academic performance and making sure that as we are looking at achievement gaps,
we are also paying attention to Latino students and not confounding the student populations because we often assume that English learners are Latino students and these are two very different student populations which at times overlap but they have different needs.
So and also I learned that I was the only in the history of the organization the only state board member who has ever attended.
So I want to encourage my colleagues
to participate.
They have an annual summit in San Diego and it's great to see fellow board members at the local level who are really focused on EO roadmap, the implementation, Latino students and issues that impact our community.
Thank you.
I'll bring up the rear.
I can quickly go.
So, as Superintendent Thurman noted, there was a panel on looking at data and understanding our achievement trends and our achievement gaps.
which I participated in just before our meetings began.
I think that was a really productive conversation, not only about where do we see the gaps and the needs, but also where some of the bright spots and some of the strategies that people are undertaking.
There's some terrific people there from Riverside County and a number of districts.
Sanger Unified was represented there, often studied for their progress.
And so I think, you know, we can continue to learn a lot and when we
revisit this conversation about how we want to be involved in the leveraging of educator equity and the way in which our ESSA funds are being spent and so we should revisit the question of what enables places that are succeeding with all groups of students to do so and how can we encourage more of those practices elsewhere.
I was appointed our commissioner to the Education Commission of the States.
They have a meeting coming up in December.
They've been already very helpful to us, as Eileen knows, because she's worked with them over the years in helping us get going on some special education.
examinations.
This is going to be a big issue for us over the coming year.
And we can learn a lot from what other states are doing.
They do a lot of 50 state scans and also do some deep dives within member states and on sort of a whole child approach to early childhood education and to young children.
So they will be, that will be a theme of their meeting.
And they're very, by the way, interested in, you know, inviting folks to participate.
So if anybody's particularly interested in any of these topics, they will have all kinds of working groups and interview processes and, you know, meetings and so on.
They have many, many kinds of meetings.
So those are two issues where we will take advantage of their offers of expertise and help.
And there may be others that we want to raise our hand for down the road.
Member Burr.
So you already heard a lot this morning or afternoon, whatever it was, about the work of the collaborative through the system of support item, and I know they'll continue to do that reporting and hopefully bring additional clarity to the work that they're doing.
The one thing I wanted to call out as the charter liaison is the October 30th memo that was posted to our website, and I want to make sure that everybody has a chance to take a look at that.
I want to thank the board staff and the department staff for doing that.
I think you probably know from reading in the press there are substantial, substantive changes to the charter school law, many of which will affect the work of the state board.
So I would call that out to your attention, actually starting on page three of the memo and throughout the rest of it.
But it will, for those of you who are excited about that,
Because it will reduce our role in some ways.
It will certainly change it materially.
But it won't do that until July of 2020.
So between now and July, we will have sort of our regular charter renewal.
You saw the material revision today.
And I do know that we have at least one charter.
I'm looking at Judy.
that will come up for action in January.
There may be more, but typically January through March is our busy time.
But after that, starting in July 1 of 2020, it will change dramatically.
And for those of you who are working on the screening committee,
The work of the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools also changes quite a bit, so that's why we have to be very attentive to those appointments.
So just wanted to make sure that everybody had a chance to read that and kind of absorb it because it is materially changing what we will do relative to charter schools.
Thank you.
We will now take up agenda item 16, general public comment.
Public comment is invited on any matter that was not included on the printed agenda.
Are there any public comments?
Will the following speakers please line up at the podium.
Jennifer Barajas, David Tako, Rachel Navarrete, and Rigel Massaro.
officer trainer and I'd like to give my time to Jennifer that's okay is that possible make sure the mics are near your mouth hold the mics down a little bit so we can hear you yeah yeah
Okay, start your minute now.
So I had officially came in with the whole speech prepared, but I think we're all tired and we're just going to go through it.
So I'm Jennifer Barajas.
I am your California State Officer for SkillsUSA, serving as your parliamentarian.
And I'm here on behalf of SkillsUSA.
We're officially going to be talking a little bit about Perkins V.
But I got the word that you guys are going to be talking about that tomorrow.
But I have school tomorrow, so you'll hear from me today.
And basically, I just want to tell you my story a little bit.
You know, the first time I was at a SkillsUSA competition, it was in 2018.
I was in there for public speaking, and I lost completely.
I was completely last place, and it devastated me, and it hurt so much.
And then the next year, I ran for state officer, and I got the position.
So I don't think it was that bad.
But SkillsUSA kind of just taught me that confidence level that I needed, those work ethics that I need to keep moving forward in everything I do.
And I kind of just wanted to point out a little bit that SkillsUSA has allowed us to build that confidence and skills we need in order to go within our... Okay, bye now.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so it's allowed us to build the confidence and skills that we need in order to go forth in our professional career and college and or college careers.
And SkillsUSA is growing rapidly with over 427,000 nationwide members.
California specifically continues to hold the first place in high school membership and middle school membership, so that's something that we're completely proud of when we go to nationals.
Washington DC to advocate for career and technical education With the growth of our state's membership 64 new chapters or slash schools have opened up in California So that's going to give the opportunity to hundreds of more students to be able to get that That work ethic that they need those skills
sorry, the skills that they need to be able to be good workers in the workforce for the United States.
And despite our 600 business and trade and union partners, over 17,000 classrooms at Conducting Skills USA training, and the growing CT advocates nationwide, we continue to face that stigma that college is the necessary only way that you're going to reach success.
And I will go to college, and I'm going to study what I want to study in, but SkillsUSA has given me that knowledge and work ethic that I needed to be successful and an exemplary member of the workforce in the U.S.
and anywhere I end up.
So we are career and college ready, and that's something that we really want to point out, and especially when we talk about career and technical education, is really pointing out that.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Good evening, Raichel Massaro of Public Advocates.
I'm making comments on the LCAP template and the California Auditor's Report.
On the LCAP template, I'm speaking to the letter you received from 14 community-based organizations.
We have a lot at stake to ensure the LCAP template provides the transparency our communities need to engage in an informed way and meaningfully participate in local control.
We hope you were able to review the template before the January meeting along with our substantive comments.
And on the auditor's report, you've heard that released yesterday found that SNC dollars are not benefiting high-needs students as LCFF law and regulations require.
We urge the board to take up the auditor's recommendations.
If it does not, the legislature will.
More must be done on the practice of carrying over unspent supplemental and concentration dollars into the next year for required investments in high-needs students, as well as delineating and evaluating the efficacy of those investments.
LEAs have the obligation to increase or improve in proportion to the supplemental funds they receive, and if they don't, they need to do more than explain away their shortcomings.
Thank you.
I think that's it.
All right.
So I now adjourn the November 2019 meeting of the State Board of Education.